Saison 23-24, sie ist auch in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer vorbei. Und Grund genug für uns, mal zu schauen, wie sich denn eigentlich die 18 einzelnen Teams geschlagen haben. Das wachen wir mit Thomas Hürner, Lisa Höfer, Anna Niemz, Marc Schwitzky und Oliver Leister. Viel Spaß! Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Und das an Zürner.
Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, keine Angst, ihr bekommt jetzt keine Zweitliga-Version des Royals vorgebetet. Das wäre dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen viel Content für einen Sommer. Die EM geht ja auch bald wieder los. Aber wir wollen trotzdem auch nach einem durchaus dramatischen Abstiegs- und Relegationsfinish mal auf die Liga schauen und sie eben auch ein bisschen analysieren, was eben auch nach dem letzten großen Blick nach der Hinrunde und den kleineren Schwerpunkten zu den einzelnen Vereinen eben so passiert ist. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ich bin unter anderem für 11 Freunde am Morgen als Podcast-Host tätig und eben auch immer mal wieder hier zu sehen. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass Max sich hat überreden lassen, mir diese Sendung zu überlassen. Und glücklicherweise habe ich direkt eine Handvoll ExpertInnen dabei, die über ihre Herzensvereine, aber auch über andere Teams berichten wollen. Und los geht's da mit Thomas Hürner. Er ist Nordkommissponent bei der SZ und war zuletzt, glaube ich, im Februar hier, um über den HSV zu sprechen. Hallo Thomas. Und dann darf ich auch Anna Niemz in der Gruppe begrüßen. Sie ist Teil von früv und blickt mit uns unter anderem auf ihren Schalke 04. Hallo Anna. Und weiter geht's mit Marc Schwitzky. Er ist freier Journalist, vor allem für die RBB Sportredaktion, ist aber nur nicht natürlich auch Teil von Hertha Base. Marc, ich glaube, wir haben zuletzt einen Rasenfunk-Royal zu unseren beiden Teams in der Bundesliga aufgenommen. Lang ist sehr. Dein Hertha sieht ja zumindest ligentechnisch ein bisschen besser aus.
Die Sache ist, ja, da gibt es viele Mächte und Interessen, die da auf solche Entscheidungen einwirken. Deswegen auch mein Haus op Graz-Vergleich gerade. Ob es da jetzt wirklich diesen ganz großen Brain Drain gab. Du sprichst davon, dass es Kleinigkeiten waren. Ja, es hat dann immer oder teilweise am Ende nicht viel gefehlt. Aber letztendlich über die Konstanzen weg, und das muss man Jonas Volt auf jeden Fall angreiden, ist man fast immer mit dem höchsten Etat oder mit dem höchsten Etat in die Saison gestartet und hat es fünfmal nicht geschafft. Das entbehrt jeder statistischen Wahrscheinlichkeit, was da letztendlich sportlich auch passiert ist. Deswegen, dass es da eine Veränderung geben muss, fände ich total legitim. Ich fand es auch bei Tim Walther legitim. Gerade da muss man auch sagen, Jonas Volt hat es immer wieder mit ihm versucht, meiner Meinung nach zu unrechtern, auch mit ihm weiterversucht. Und dann gab es lustigerweise immer wieder auch Analysephasen, wo man sich zusammengesetzt hat, wo Jonas Volt Tim Walther vermitteln wollte, hey, wir müssen hier übrigens ein bisschen ausverlamsierter Fußball spielen. Dann hat Tim Walther sich ein, zwei Spiele dran gehalten und auf einmal startest du aus der Winterpause wieder in die Saison und kriegst in zwei Heimspielen vier Gegentore. Deswegen war Tim Walther natürlich auch für Jonas Volt in der Hinsicht nicht mehr haltbar, weil er sich selbst natürlich auch, er hätte sich komplett seine Position auch im Verein geraubt und seinen Standing in der Mannschaft auch, weil diese Gespräche im großen Kreis auch stattgefunden haben. Deswegen, ja, wie gesagt, ich sehe Kunst durchaus skeptisch. Baumgart, glaube ich, kann durchaus ein seriöser Aufstiegstrainer sein oder ein erfolgreicher Aufstiegstrainer sein. Das Interessante beim HSV ist ja, ich habe gerade vom Etat noch mal geredet, man hat beste Möglichkeiten weiterhin von den Zweitligisten aller besten Möglichkeiten. Man hat von Klaus Michael Kühne neulich wieder 30 Millionen in Eigenkapital verwandeln dürfen und solche Sachen und das ist ja tatsächlich so. Man hat sich dann für Stefan Kunz entschieden, aber man hat mit ganz, ganz großen Branchen, Namen zumindest mal, sich unterhalten. Und die waren auch alle eigentlich bereit, beim HSV zu arbeiten. Also von Trazzo über Jörg Schmatke und so weiter. Die grundsätzliche Bereitschaft war da. Die Attraktivität dieses Clubs ist vorhanden und das Potenzial letztendlich auch. Und ja, dann ist natürlich die Frage, welcher Weg ist richtig? So ein unangenehmer Fachmann, der wirklich auch alles auf den Kopf stellt wie Jörg Schmatke. Oder wenn es wirklich um Stellschrauben geht, Stefan Kunz. Ich hätte tatsächlich meine Priorität woanders hingelegt. Weil ich eben auch glaube, dass der Weg mit Jonas Boldt sich dann irgendwann verlaufen hatte und so auch nicht mehr vorzuführen war.
Dann eine kurze Frage. Wie siehst du, wenn wir einfach noch mal auf die Spieler gucken. Als ich meine Robert Glatzel, hat er viel dafür getan, dass man auch in der Bundesliga spielt. Ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt. Mit Tabakovic und Jordis waren man eben 22 Tore. Und damit hat man sich zu dritt die Torjägerkanone geteilt. Aber auch ein Laszlo Benis, definitiv einer der wichtigsten Spieler beim HSV-Liste geht immer weiter. Wo siehst du denn die Zukunft auch von solchen Spielern? Denkst du, die gucken sich das auch noch alle zwei Jahre an? Oder sagst du mal, wenn die diesen Sommer nicht weg sind, sind sie vielleicht im Winter weg, wenn sich da keine Besserung abzeichnet?
Das kommt ein bisschen auf die Einzelfälle an. Die beiden von dir genannten haben Ausstiegsklauseln. Die können sie offenbar ziehen bis Mitte des Monats. Das wird sich dann relativ bald was ergeben. Ich denke nicht, dass Benisch bleibt. Das halte ich für nahezu ausgeschlossen. Das wäre aus seiner persönlichen Karriereperspektive auch relativ dumm, so groß der HSV als Verein ist. Und so attraktiv auch irgendwie. Aber natürlich kann man nicht die sportlichen Misserfolge eine Karriere lang mitkompensieren. Das geht nicht. Glatzl, da hieß es immer wieder auch bei diesen Nichtaufstiegen, er könnte gehen, hat sich dann doch entschieden zu bleiben. Ja, das kommt tatsächlich ein bisschen darauf an, wer dann auch Interesse zeigt, wie attraktiv die Angebote sind. Da könnte es tatsächlich zu großen Veränderungen kommen in der Strategie der Mannschaft vielleicht. Und das ist ja auch Stefan Kunz erklärtes Ziel. Das würde ich auch ein bisschen anders sehen. Er will ja nicht so viel verändern. Also wenn möglich, möchte er natürlich auch alle halten und ja, punktuell ergänzen.
Sicherlich wird es da auch eben nochmal spannend, wie am Ende das ganze Thema Vuskovic weitergeht. Der hatte ja mit Jonas Boldt auf jeden Fall immer auch einen starken Unterstützer, würde ich mal sagen, der glaube ich jetzt auch bei den Gerichtsverhandlungen dabei war. Wird natürlich auch spannend, wie das weitergeht. Ich bin auch immer noch der Meinung, dass die Defensive auf jeden Fall punktuell Unterstützung braucht. Also ich habe letzte Saison durchaus etwas geschmunzelt, als man Guy Ramosch geholt hat, der definitiv kopfballstark ist, aber für mich halt zu viele Aussetzer defensiv hat. Also klar gucke ich da auch immer mit einer sehr, ja, aus Bielefelder Sicht aber eingeschränkten Sicht drauf, das gebe ich auch gerne zu, aber da war ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so komplett von überzeugt, dass der so eine Defensive stärken kann. Also ich glaube schon, dass ein bisschen was zukommt und heißt nicht, also es muss ja kein komplettes Umkrempeln sein und man muss nicht keine Ahnung 24 Spieler ersetzen. Aber ich finde es manchmal dann auch irgendwie merkwürdig, wenn dann der Sportvorstand sagt, dann sagt er auch, also viel verändern will ich jetzt nicht, weil man dann natürlich immer sagt, ja okay, ab wann sieht man denn dann im Zweifel das, was er in den Verein reinbringt. Also wenn der Trainer bleibt, also der Staff drum herum bleibt und ein Großteil des Kaders bleibt auch, ab wann ist denn der Punkt, wo wir dann sagen, okay, Stefan Kunz hat das und das verändert am Verein, dass dann der Aufstieg gelingt. Also ist vielleicht ein bisschen naiv formuliert, aber da habe ich dann von außen immer so meine Probleme mit, wenn dann doch vieles gleich bleibt wie in der Saison davor.
Ja, also das ist total mein Punkt. In Italien übrigens ein sehr weitläufig benutzter Begriff von größten Trainern in Deutschland irgendwie verpönt. Ich verstehe es nicht ganz. Mentalität ist ein Faktor im Fußball. Da wird man darauf Wert legen müssen, dass tatsächlich da das Level zu erhöhen, weil es war auch einfach zu nett, wie man diese ganzen Misserfolge dann reflektiert hat und ja, verarbeitet hat. Es war doch dann alles eigentlich doch ganz nett diese Saison. Der HSV steht letztendlich sportlich nur noch für Misserfolg. Es ist so. Man hat jetzt eine Demütigung nach der anderen gekriegt. Zum ersten Mal hinter St. Pauli in der Geschichte gelandet. Das ist eine historische Zäsur. Das hätte man sich einfach nicht vorstellen können vor ein paar Jahren. Man hat kontinuierlich daran gearbeitet oder es geschafft, sich erst mal dem Stadtrivalen anzunähern und sich letztlich überholen zu lassen. Die Geschichte kenne ich aus Berlin nicht. Wobei die Diskrepanz auch beim HSV in St. Pauli traditionell, würde ich sagen, fast noch größer ist. Weil der HSV einfach mal Europas bester Club war. Das war Hertha vielleicht nicht. Es ist irgendwie tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen sediert das Ganze, weil auch das Umfeld und die Fans da relativ viel auch positiv mitmachen. Wo ich persönlich als Fußball-Fan deutlich kritischere Haltungen angenommen hätte.
Ich glaube, wir haben die komplette KAUSA HSV zumindest für die Zeit, die es uns erlaubt, ganz gut beleuchtet. Auf jeden Fall ein großes Dank auch an dich, Thomas, dass du da deine Insight so ein bisschen teilst. Ich glaube, ein Verein, wo es auch viele Nebenshow-Plätze gab über die ganze Saison hinweg, ist der Karlsruher SC. Marc, den hast du dir zu Herzen genommen, hat bestimmt doch überhaupt nichts mit dem doch engen Verhältnis deines Vereins mit dem Verein zu tun. Am Ende ist es Platz 5 für den KSC, 55 Punkte. Eine enorme Verbesserung in der Rückrunde, kann man glaube ich sagen. Also Hinrunde war Platz 12. In der Rückrunde war man das zweitbeste Team. Natürlich eine absolute Kitschgeschichte zum Abschluss der Saison mit Lars Stindl, der seine Karriere beendet. Irgendwie eingewechselt wird und innerhalb von 15 Sekunden mit dem ersten Ballkontakt noch das Tor macht. Marc, was ist in dieser Rückrunde beim KSC passiert? Was hat vielleicht auch Christian Eichner geschafft, dass man es so umdrehen konnte nochmal?
Habe ich mich natürlich auch gefragt und haben auch andere Christian Eichner gefragt. Er führt es letztendlich darauf zurück. Es gab ja so ein Turnaround ab Oktober. Er sagt aber, er würde den Zeitpunkt tatsächlich kritischer wählen, weil in der Zeit hat man dann Ergebnisse erzielt, aber immer noch nicht so, wie man das eigentlich wollte in der Art und Weise. Er war dann so ab der Partie gegen Düsseldorf zufrieden. Was für ihn da im Trend ganz wichtig war, war die Defensive. Das war für ihn der ganz, ganz große Punkt. Man hat da deutliche personelle Veränderungen vorgenommen. Man hat mehr defensiv denkende Spieler eingesetzt. Man wollte eine bessere Balance im Mittelfeld haben. Und diesen Einsatz von einem zweiten Sechser, das hat letztendlich dazu geführt, dass man die Verteidigung stabilisieren konnte. Und das war dann die Basis dafür, für alles, was in der Rückrunde folgen sollte und den KSC so stark gemacht hat. Und das ist tatsächlich eine Stellschraube gewesen. Da sind wir wieder. Die sehr gut funktioniert hat und die auch einfach beweist, nochmal beweist auch, dass Christian Eichner ein überaus talentierter Trainer ist, den wir, glaube ich, bald auch woanders sehen könnten.
Ja, ich glaube, es war ja unter anderem mal das Gerücht erster FC Köln, wenn ich es unter anderem mal richtig gesehen habe. So wie es ehrlich gesagt immer ist, wenn irgendwo dann doch eine Trainerstelle bekannt wird, dann wird einmal in diverse Ligen geguckt und da einmal geguckt, oh, wer war denn dann erfolgreich? Aber ich finde es sowieso sehr interessant. Ja, so viel Chaos, wie rundherum dann doch beim Verein herrscht, können wir sicherlich gleich auch nochmal ganz kurz draufgucken. Aber desto interessanter finde ich, wie lange Christian Eichner da jetzt doch kontinuierlich arbeitet. Sicher sind immer so ein bisschen als Dark Horses bestimmt auch immer, zwar einen, wo man vielleicht immer mal sagt, okay, die könnten doch da oben reinrutschen. Ich finde einen Spieler, der einer der besten Transfers eigentlich war, auch wenn es ein Leihgeschäft war, war Igor Matanovich. Also von Eintracht Frankfurt ja ausgeliehen. Und war natürlich auch davor bei St. Pauli immer ein interessanter Spieler, aber für mich einer so, der nachdem man da Stündel verpflichtet hatte, was natürlich viel vor allem fürs Herz war, einfach ein enorm interessanter Spieler, der ja glaube ich auch mit Teil des Erfolgs ist.
Absolut, vielleicht zu Christian Eichner vorhin nochmal, warum er jetzt, ich meine er ist schon seit vier Jahren dort im Amt. Das geht manchmal fast ein bisschen unter, auch weil er noch ja trotzdem sehr junger Trainer ist. Christian Eichner wirkt unendlich, er ruht sehr in sich, finde ich. Es gibt ja auch immer diese schönen Bilder, wie er beim Anpfiff immer stoisch seine erste Banane während des Spiels ist. Das steht ein bisschen stellvertretend dafür, dass der Mann, der bringt, der lässt sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen. Das muss man wirklich sagen, trotz seines jungen Alters ist er sehr klar. Sehr klar in seiner Kommunikation, sehr klar in seinem Handeln. Und das tut natürlich einer Mannschaft, die in einem manchmal durchaus unruhigen Umfeld arbeitet, total gut. Hinzu kommt, dass diese Mannschaft aber auch recht alt ist. Also das muss man auch sagen. Da wird jetzt auch, du wirst jetzt vor allen Dingen im Sommer, wird man da einen Generationswechsel erleben. Wenn man sich das anschaut, man hat den zweitältesten Kader der Liga in dieser Saison gehabt. Nach Schalke, glaube ich. Wenig verwunderlich beenden mit Lars Stindl, Daniel Brosinski und Jerome Gondow gleich drei Spieler jetzt ihre Profikarrieren. Man wird mit Heise und Thiede, beide Außenverteidiger, zwei Spieler jenseits der 30 ebenfalls verabschieden. Das kommt eben noch dazu, gleichzeitig, um auf Igor Matanowicz zu kommen. Hat Eichner aber auch bewiesen, dass er junge Spiele weiterentwickeln kann. Da ist zum einen Igor Matanowicz zu nennen, aber natürlich auch ganz klar Paul Nebel zu nennen, der sicherlich zu den besten Spielern dieser Saison gehört hat. Fünf Tore, neun Vorlagen. Auf der einen Seite bringt er eben dieses spielerische mit, was aber auch nicht untergehen darf. Er hat die dritthöchste Laufstil-Distanzielliga hingelegt. Er hat die meisten intensiven Läufe hingelegt, aber eben, wie gesagt, das spielerische, gleichzeitig sieht meisten Schlüsselpässe. Also bewegt sich da in einem überaus guten Rahmen. Und Mainz kann sich da auf jeden Fall auf einen gefühlten Neuzugang dann auch freuen. Der hat sich eben unter Eichner sehr gut entwickelt, aber auch so einen Namen wie beispielsweise Marcel Beifuss, der sich in der Innenverteidigung mit der Zeit zum Schrammspieler entwickelt hat. Ganz wichtig, David Herold, der zunächst per Laie kam vom FC Bayern und der mittlerweile festverpflichtet wurde und jetzt Philipp Heiser auf links hinten beerben wird. Also da sieht man, dass Christian Eichner, der hat auch einfach einen alten Kader übernommen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass er die alle selbst verpflichtet hätte. Aber er beweist eben, dass er dann um diese alten Spieler herum gute Gebilde baut, aber diese älteren Spieler auch ans Maximum führt. Ich finde, eine sehr inspirierende Personalien daran geht, ist Sebastian Jung, der eigentlich sich ja gefühlt schon verabschiedet hatte vom Profifußball aufgrund eines dramatischen Verletzungspechs und der dann plötzlich in Karlsruhe nochmal unendlich wichtig wird. Am Ende hatte er, glaube ich, sieben Assists. Philipp Heise sechs. Und da würde ich dann vielleicht nochmal kurz dazu kommen, wie spielte der KSC überhaupt Fußball? Weil ich das eigentlich recht spannend finde. Und da auch nochmal auf Christian Eichner eingehe. Also ich will dem Kader nicht zu nahe treten, aber blickt man jetzt mal auf das Aufgebot, fällt einem vermutlich nicht direkt ein, dass die fast schon um den Aufstieg mitgespielt hätten. Die hatten am Ende auch den drittbesten Angriff der Liga. Das deckt sich auch mit dem drittbesten Expected Goals her. Die hatten die sechs beste Defensive gleichzeitig, was für eine gute Balance spricht. Und all das liegt an Christian Eichner, der das Maximum aus diesem Kader herausholt. Man hat erst mit einer Raute in der Saison gestartet. Mit einer Mittelfeldraute ist dann auf ein flaches 4-4-2 gerückt. Da kommen wir eben zum zweiten Sechser, was dann die Stabilität gebracht hat. Und damit hat er das perfekte System für den Kader gefunden. Der KSC spielt sehr intensiv im Fußball. Auch da sehr hohe Laufdistance, sehr viele intensive Läufe. Aber tatsächlich extrem wenig Sprints. Und das liegt wieder am Kader und wie alt er ist. Ich finde das crazy, ich habe das mal nachgeguckt. Was Tempo angeht, haben die einen einzigen Spieler in der Top 100 der zweiten Liga auf Platz 92. Und danach kommen die nächsten beiden auf Platz 119 und 120. Da kommt der Kader also klar an seine Grenzen. Und trotzdem kann man mithalten. Und ich finde fast das spannendste Element ist auch der Pragmatismus von Christian Eichner, der eben sagt, wir haben im Mittelfeld sehr viele talentierte Fußballer, auch mal wie Vanicek dem Ewigen, der seit vielen Jahren gute Leistungen bringt. Und da spielen wir richtig Fußball. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie der KSC durch die Mitte kombiniert, wie der KSC mit Paul Nebel und Vanicek und Co. Halbräume besetzt, dann ist das richtig modern, richtig gut. Gleichzeitig sagt sich Christian Eichner aber auch, okay, ich hab dich die schnellen außen, ich hab aber zwei starke Flankengeber als links- und rechtsverteidiger mit Heise und Jung. Na dann bin ich das doch auch ein. Und vorne habe ich mit Igor Matanovich und Budo Sivcivace zwei eher klassische Mittelstürmer, die kopfballstark sind. Also habe ich auch gute Abnehmer. Das heißt, der KSC spielt meistens echt sauberen Fußball, bis ins letzte Drittel. Und dann kommt aber gar nicht der flache Ball in die Tiefe, sondern dann werden sehr viele Flanken geschlagen. Der KSC schlägt die drittmeisten Flanken aus dem Spiel heraus. Gleichzeitig kommen aber auch mit 6,2 pro Spiel die meisten aller Zweitligisten an. Das ist eigentlich, Max, liebe Grüße, das ist eigentlich hier dein Segment. Also das ist fast eine Flankenerotik, die die betreiben. Die haben mit zwei Stürmern, einem Zehner und meist einem Achter eine herausragende Strafraumbesetzung. Sodass es meist viele Abnehmer gibt. Und sie gewinnen auch die zweitmeisten Kopfballduelle der Liga. Das interessante dabei ist, es ist fast schon eine Kunst, wie die Flanken schlagen. Weil die Flanken werden nicht einfach blind reingepügelt, sondern es gibt meistens sehr gute Dreiecke, die dazu führen, dass der Flankengeber, also entweder der Außenverteidiger oder der Achter, sehr viel Raum und Zeit für eine Flanke hat. Der kann sich das ganz genau überlegen. Und dann kommen die Flanken sehr variabel. Die DFL macht, was Digitalisierung angeht, nicht viel gut. Aber wenn man auf die Seite der Zweitligisten oder Erstligisten guckt, kann man sich alle Tore angucken. Man kann sie einfach durchklicken. Und wenn man sich da die Tore vom KC anguckt, merkt man, da gibt es Flanken à la couleur, flach, halbhoch, sehr hoch und sie haben für alle Abnehmer. Und das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an den FC Liverpool unter Klopp, der dann plötzlich ja Flanken auf Spieler wie Mo Salah oder Sadio Mane geschlagen hat. Aber die kamen halt so gut, dass kein anderer rankam. Und so verwundert es dann auch nicht, dass mit Bantanovic 14 Tore und Cifcivace 12 Tore, aber auch mit Fabio Schleusener viele Stürmertore gefallen sind in der Saison. Ja, und das ist es vielleicht als Plädoyer dafür, warum Christian Eichner da einfach wirklich fantastische Arbeit geleistet hat. Dass 55 Punkte für den KSC mit dem Kader alles andere selbstverständlich sind. Man sehr ausbalanciert spielt, man ist Platz 5 der Heimtabelle, man ist Platz 5 der Auswärtstabelle. Das hat also alles seine Berechtigung. Dementsprechend glaube ich aber auch, dass Christian Eichner da an den Sieg gestoßen ist. Man beginnt jetzt einen neuen Zyklus, man wird alte Spieler los, fügt neue, jüngere Spieler hinzu. Der Vertrag von Eichner läuft bis 2025. Er soll eine Ausstiegsklausel besitzen. Wie gesagt, Köln war im Gespräch, Hertha war sogar im Gespräch. Dass er nach Höherem strebt, ist wohl auch verbrieft. Dementsprechend ist er jetzt schon, habe ich mal geguckt, auf Platz 5 der ewigen Trainer-Historie beim KSC. Viel geht da nicht mehr, weil dann kommen auch so wirklich ewige Leute. Dementsprechend könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass jetzt fast eigentlich ein guter Zeitpunkt wäre, für ihn zu gehen, aus einer karriereopportunistischen Sicht heraus. Aber vielleicht will er auch noch weiter aufbauen, who knows, ihm liegt ja viel am KSC, aber rundum eine wirklich sehr, sehr gute Saison gewesen.
Ja, würde ich komplett mitgehen. Also ich war dann doch hinten raus überrascht, wie souverän sie es wieder gespielt haben. Also ich finde es immer schwierig, fand es schon immer schwierig, gegen den KSC irgendwie zu bestehen. Ich finde, die haben, also gerade unter Aichner, die haben eben, ja du hast es eben schon gesagt, also eine Balance, auch was generell vielleicht die Statistiken betrifft, aber eben auch im Kader, also dass man eben nicht, wir haben eben bei Fortuna Düsseldorf über Christus Chalice geredet, dass man eben nicht diesen Einspieler hat, wo man sagt, wenn der jetzt weggeht, bricht alles auseinander. Klar, es wird ein schwieriger Sommer und es wird da definitiv eine Aufgabe. Ich bin auch gespannt, ob Aichner am Ende sagt, okay, doch, das ist jetzt noch mal die letzte Herausforderung, die ich beim KSC annehme und je nachdem, wie es mit der Saison läuft, bin ich danach eben weg oder er sagt so, okay, nee, es ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu viel. Wenn es schon neu anfängt, dann kann ich das auch woanders machen, aber generell sehr interessante Personalien. Aber lass uns noch einmal ganz kurz auf einen Teil vom KSC gucken, der ja ein bisschen auch sehr oft die Schlagzeilen zumindest im letzten halben Jahr dominiert hat. Es geht unter anderem ja ums Fanprojekt KS-Ruhe. Ich kann gerne die Fakten aufzählen, du kannst sie gerne aufzählen.
Machst du doch gerne, ich habe lange monologisiert gerade.
Genau, einfach um dann die ZuhörerInnen abzuholen, es geht da explizit um ein Spiel aus dem Jahr 2022 gegen den FC St. Pauli. Da gab es, glaube ich, eine Choreo auch für ein Jubiläum, der einen Ultragruppierung, und damals wurde eben auch Pyrotechnik gezündet und kam zu Verletzten, um das jetzt einmal ganz kurz zu strukturieren. Und im Anschluss daraus hat eben auch die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt und unter anderem die MitarbeiterInnen des Fanprojekts Karlsruhe wurden eben zu Stellungnahmen gebeten. Und die haben eben ganz klar gesagt, dass sie das nicht machen, weil sie damit den Sinn oder den Kern ihres Jobs eben komplett aufs Spiel setzen. Das ist eben nämlich die Schnittstelle, die ein Fanprojekt zwischen Fans und vor allem auch organisierten Fans, dem Verein aber eben auch, wenn es um Anhörungen geht, etc. dazu unterstützen zu wirken, dass man eben dieses Vertrauen aufs Spiel setzt. Ich kann da tatsächlich auch den Teil zu empfehlen, in ZDF ist da eine Doku zu erschienen, Inside Ultras heißt die, glaube ich. Und da geht es auch um einen ganz kurzen Segment, wird eben auch eine Mitarbeiterin des KSC dazu interviewt oder das Fanprojekt des KSC und wo sie eben nochmal betont, nein, wir machen da keine Aussage. Aber es gibt eben ein ganz großes Problem, weil Fanprojektmitarbeitende kein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht haben. Und jetzt kannst du gerne übernehmen, bevor ich mich in Eventualitäten hier verhaspele.
Richtig, also es gab da im vergangenen Oktober schon von Daniel Mälchen, der ist Geschäftsführer des Staatsjugendausschusses in Karlsruhe, deutliche Kritik am Fanprojekt. Er sagte, es gäbe eben Bereiche in der Sozialarbeit, in denen man dauerhafte Gefahrausgesetze erkennt, es von Straftaten zu erlangen. Und das trifft laut ihm beispielsweise auf Drogenberatungen zu, aber eben nicht auf Fanprojekte. Dementsprechend haben sie eben kein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht und das steht ihnen nicht zu. Seit der Gründung habe man zwar schon viele Menschen erreicht und auch persönliche Entwicklung in gewaltfreie Richtungen lenken können, sagt das Fanprojekt, aber das scheint nicht auszureichen. Und nach diesem Eklat wirft die Staatsanwaltschaft mit Mitarbeitern des Karlsruher Fanprojekts eben Strafvereitelung vor. Aufgrund der nicht getätigten Auskünfte. Drei Strafbefehle mit 120 Tagen gesetzten A, 60 Euro wurden laut Amtsgericht Karlsruhe erlassen. Und die Betroffenen hatten damals, und das nämlich stand März, immer noch Zeit dagegen Einspruch einzulegen. Ich muss sagen, meine eigene Recherche hat nicht dazu geführt, dass es dazu irgendwas Neues gab. Weshalb ich erstmal davon ausgehe, dass die Betroffenen das angenommen haben. Ich will aber hier keine Falschmeldung publizieren, aber ich bin mir recht sicher, dass es sonst öffentlich nochmal eine Stellungnahme gegeben hätte. Das ist aber natürlich ein Präzedenzfall, muss man sagen, der natürlich eine immense Bedeutung für die Arbeit von Fanprojekten und für die Legitimation von Fanprojekten hat. Fanprojekte haben einen unendlich wichtigen demokratischen Auftrag, gesellschaftlich mittlerweile, aufgrund der gesellschaftlichen Bedeutung von Fußball. Da geht es um Jugendkultur, da geht es um Vorbeugung von Straftaten, da geht es um Sozialisierung. Und es steht hier eben dann groß im Raum die Frage, können Fanprojekte diese Arbeit in dieser Form weiter fortführen in Zukunft, wenn sie wissen, dass sie eben kein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht besitzen? Das macht die ganze Nummer sehr heikel. Aber wie gesagt, das ist der Stand, und das hat sich eben am Standort Karlsruhe entzündet, ist aber nur eine Geschichte von ein paar anderen neben dem Platz.
Ja, ich finde es da schon sehr interessant. Also erstens sowieso einfach die Solidarität, die es ja nicht nur in Karlsruhe an sich gab, sondern auch in ganz Deutschland. Also ich glaube, jeder, der schon mal im Fußballstadion unterwegs war, etc., hat das irgendwie dann doch durchaus mal gedacht, okay, wenn jetzt irgendwie was passiert, an wen wende ich mich? Weil es ist natürlich schon so, gerade wenn du in großen Gruppen unterwegs bist, kannst du tatsächlich immer mal gerne zur falschen Zeit am falschen Ort sein. Es gibt die ganze KAUSA Gewalttäter-Sportakte, wo man zum Teil wirklich einfach nur mal nach dem Spiel an einer falschen Stelle sein muss. Kontaktdaten werden aufgenommen und du weißt nicht genau, ob du jetzt in so einer Kategorie landest. Und eben da sind Fanprojekte enorm wichtig. Und ich weiß nicht, Olli, gerade du hast die Nähe zu Hansa Rostock. Da gibt es ja eben soweit ich weiß kein Fanprojekt. Auf jeden Fall nicht in dem Sinne oder keine Fanhilfe in der Breite, wo sowas vielleicht auch aufgearbeitet wird oder?
Also meines Wissens gibt es ein Fanprojekt. Es gibt auch eine Fanhilfe von so einem Anwaltsverein, wie es ja bei vielen Vereinen auch im Umfeld üblich ist. Wie genau das jetzt aber strukturiert ist, kann ich dir nicht sagen. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall ein Fanprojekt in Rostock, auch seit vielen Jahren.
Ah ja, es ist auch tatsächlich mein Fehler. Ich habe es verwechselt mit Olli. Entschuldigung. Ich glaube, da ist es nämlich der Fall, dass es tatsächlich kein Fanprojekt ist. Hallo, ich habe Ahnung von Fußball. Nein, aber ich finde Fanprojekte super wichtig. Es ist ein sozialpädagogischer Raum. Gerade, weil man mit so vielen jungen Leuten zusammenarbeitet. Klar, auch ein Fußballstadion ist kein rechtsfreier Raum. Ich glaube, das sagt damit keiner von uns. Aber ich finde schon, dass Fanprojekte elementar wichtig sind. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, ob es diesen Präzedenzfall gibt. Da sagen tatsächlich auch viele Fanprojekte oder viele MitarbeiterInnen. Das kann an manchen Standorten einfach das Ende dieser Fanprojekte bedeuten. Das ist durchaus ein Problem. Marc, willst du dazu noch was sagen? Oder kurz auf das ganze Drumherum, auf das Chaos beim KSC noch mal schauen, was es da sonst noch für Themen gibt?
Ich kann es versuchen. Aber first of all der Disclaimer, ich kenne von Hertha solche internen Querelen und Grabenkämpfe nur zu gut und weiß, dass man da ganz tief drinstecken muss, um alle Details zu können. Ich versuche da jetzt mein Bestes, diesen Führungsstreit beim KSC möglichst kurz aufzuklären. Also vergebt mir, liebe KSCler, wenn ich irgendein Detail oder Ähnliches vergesse. Ich verweise da auch auf ältere Rasenfunk-Schwerpunkte beim KSC, da gibt es ja auch wirklich sehr gute zu. Also Hintergrund war der seit Monaten schwelende Führungsstreit bezüglich der Freistellung von Sportgeschäftsführer Oliver Kreutzer am 1. April 2023 und durch den Beirat. Damals wurden die beiden Vizepräsidenten und Geldgeber Martin Müller und Günter Pulaski von den drei anderen Beiratsmitgliedern Holger, Sigmund Schulze, Thomas Hock und Christian Fischer überstimmt. Damals sei Fischer Müller überrumpelt worden, kritisierte er im Nachhinein die Entscheidung für Fallschild. Und es kam dann zum offenen Bruch. Müller war im Vorfeld unter anderem für die Weitergabe von internen Informationen. Es wurde ihm vorgeworfen, der Abwahlantrag war auch vom KSC-Fan-Dachverband Supporters unterstützt worden und in einer Mitteilung sprach der Verband von einem gestörten Vertrauensverhältnis. Der Mitgliederrat des KSC hatte daraufhin eine außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung und einen Abwahlantrag gegen Müller beschlossen. Das hatte ich eben ausgeführt. Das heißt, diese konstruktive und vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit sei ganz offensichtlich nicht mehr möglich gewesen, weshalb man da Veränderung personell vornehmen müsste. Das war dann Februar der Fall. Im Februar oder März, im März, hatte die Mehrheit der Mitglieder des KSC dann Vizepräsident Martin Müller abgewählt. Rund 61 Prozent der stimmberechtigten Mitglieder des KSC stimmten dann in der virtuellen Versammlung für die Abwahl von Martin Müller. Die Abwahl war dann durch. Von der Abstimmung begründete dann der Vorsitzende des Mitgliederrats Dieter Gläser ausführlich nochmal, warum dieses Gremium diesen Abwahlantrag gestellt hat. Es sei unmittelbar nach der Mitgliederversammlung im Dezember deutlich geworden, dass in den Gremien des KSC es langsam unüberbrückbare Differenzen bestanden hätten. Müller, der in der Kritik stand und rechtfertigte sein Handeln in den vergangenen Monaten bis heute, wären ihm diese Vorwürfe nicht bewiesen worden bezüglich der Weitergabe von Interna. Er habe keine Interna weitergegeben. Und seine Reaktionen der Öffentlichkeit, die teilweise sehr unseriös wirkten, die seien zwar unsachtlich gewesen und überzogen, aber inhaltlich richtig. Die Nummer hat sich dementsprechend erledigt, aber noch nicht ganz, weil der Mann noch Anteile hält, wichtiger Geldgeber ist, er diese Anteile aber noch hält. Das heißt, da gibt es immer noch natürlich ein Verhältnis. Und dementsprechend ist die Nummer noch nicht völlig ruhig. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie zerrüttet weiterhin. Vielleicht gewisse Verhältnisse sind beispielsweise auch zu Günter Pilarz, der damals gegen Oliver Kreuzer gestimmt hat. Da stecke ich, wie gesagt, da nicht drin. Es ging für mich jetzt erst mal darum, ob diese Martin-Müller-Nummer durch ist, ist sie. Und das hat den KSC in den letzten Monaten beschäftigt. Und wie es bei Traditionsvereinen so ist, wird das wahrscheinlich auch noch öfter aufbrechen. Aber da blicken wir dann drauf, soweit es ist.
Danke dir auf jeden Fall fürs Zusammenfassen. Generell glaube ich, interessanter Sommer für den KSC eben auch. Was passiert mit Christian Eichner? Du hast es schon angesprochen, der Umbruch im Kader. Aber ja, also definitiv viel, was da auch rund um den KSC berichtet wird. Von daher auch danke dir Marc, dass du das hier so aufgeschlüsselt hast. Ja, wollen wir zu einem Verein gehen, der ja, da ist hinter den Kulissen immer alles komplett ruhig. Da gibt es überhaupt gar keine Probleme. Da gibt es überhaupt gar keine Streitigkeiten hinter den Kulissen. Natürlich die Rede von Hannover 96. Bevor ich jetzt wütende Nachrichten kriege, ist was, Akasmus. Anna, du wohnst in Hannover und hast natürlich dadurch auch so eine gewisse Nähe. 52 Punkte sind es am Ende der Saison, Platz 6 mit drei Punkte hinter dem KSC. Die zweite Saison von Stefan Leitl als Cheftrainer ist zwar noch nicht im Ausstieg erfolgt. Es war letzte Saison Platz 10, die Saison Platz 6. Also zeigt die Formkurve durchaus nach oben. Wie schaust du auf Hannover 96? Man spricht bei 96 immer ganz viel ums Drumherum. Der Scan spielt ums Sportliche. Aber lasst uns trotzdem mal mit dem Sportlichen anfangen.
Ich kenne ein paar 96-Fans und habe gefragt, wie sie die Saison einschätzen würden mit einem Satz. Der Grundtenor ist ein bisschen solide, aber Luft nach oben. Ich glaube, die sind schon mal positiv gestimmt, dass die Saison besser gelaufen ist als die letzte. Zwischenzeitlich war Hannover sogar mal auf Platz 3 und hat auch mit der Relegation geliebäugelt. Aber ich glaube, im Großen und Ganzen war es ziemlich wechselhaft. Es gab Spiele wie so ein 4 zu 3 gegen den HSV auswärts, wo die komplett überzeugt haben, wo die nächsten drei Spiele auch gewonnen haben. Und dann gab es wieder so ein 1-0 gegen Osnabrück zum Beispiel, wo sie nicht überzeugen konnten. Also ich glaube, der Kader hat sich minimal, also wirklich nur minimal verändert tatsächlich. Ich glaube, die bedeutendste Verpflichtung ist die Rückkehr von Marcel Halzenberg gewesen. Der hat sich ja aktiv dafür entschieden, zu seinem Jugendverein zurückzugehen. Und man hat schon gemerkt, dass der da in der Defensive eine Stabilität reingebracht hat, die er einfach mit seinen Erfahrungswerten auch abgesichert hat. Und ich denke, alle 96 Fans schätzen sich sehr glücklich, dass er wieder in den Verein spielt und sich auch aktiv für Hannover 96 wieder entschieden hat, zurückzukehren.
Ja, 44 Gegentore waren es am Ende nur. Es sind tatsächlich, sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen mehr als drei, als man laut Expected Goals Against eigentlich bekommen sollte. Aber du hast eben schon angesprochen, Halstenberg ist definitiv einer der Hauptcharaktere auch für diese Mannschaft. Cedric Teuchert wäre zumindestens 15 Tore und damit der beste Torschütze von Hannover. Der wechselt in die USA. Also da gibt es durchaus ein Fragezeichen, wer diese Rolle füllen wird. Man hat ja unter anderem auch ein altbekanntes Gesicht aus der 2. Liga geholt, Andreas Vogelsommer. Fand ich tatsächlich einen sehr starken Transfer, weil ich glaube, der durchaus ein flexibel einsetzbarer Spieler ist. Er ist jetzt nicht so der klassische Mittelstürmer, sondern er ist auch einfach durchaus eine bullige Gestalt, ist gut gegen den Ball, kann eben guten Ball abschirmen. Im Zweifel auch für jemand, der mit vorne drin steht. Und ich glaube, generell hat Leitel schon viel richtig gemacht. Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem ist eben, dass man zu viele Unentschieden am Ende der Saison hatte. Weil 13 Unentschieden ist schon durchaus eine Marke am Ende, die reinhaut eben genauso viel, wie man Sieger hatte. Und klar, Unentschieden ist nicht verloren. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass da am Ende vielleicht dann doch der ein oder andere Punkt zu viel verloren ist. Also so viele Spiele verloren hat man ja tatsächlich mit acht Niederlagen nicht. Also da war man durchaus gut dabei und hat es schon geschafft, dann die Spiele nicht zu verlieren. Aber würdest du auch sagen, dass eben so, ja vielleicht dann doch in den ein, zwei Spielen der letzte Prozentpunkt gefehlt hat und da noch das Spiel zu gewinnen und dann vielleicht doch noch weiter oben am Ende mitzuspielen?
Ich glaube, man war dann in einigen Spielen einfach nicht konsequent genug, das so durchzuziehen und dann auch zu sagen, wir wollen hier jetzt unbedingt oder mit dieser Ansage ranzugehen, wir wollen das jetzt unbedingt gewinnen, weil wir noch mehr Ambitionen haben, weiter hoch zu klettern in der Tabelle, was Hannover ja durchaus hat, und glaube ich auch die ausgewiesene Route für die kommende Saison ist, dass man ja dann mal wieder einen Bundesliga-Aufstieg schaffen könnte. Zu Vogelsammer kann man auch sagen, dass der ja, glaube ich, in den letzten Spielen auch ganz schön aufgedreht ist. Also es war tatsächlich eine ganz gute Verpflichtung. Allgemein finde ich, die Verpflichtungen, die Markus Mann seit Antritt getätigt hat, sind schon durchweg positiv zu bewerten. Hannover setzt aber auch relativ häufig auf Jugendspiele, also aus der eigenen Jugend, so ein Tresoli zum Beispiel, oder jetzt die letzten Spiele Lars Gindorf aus der U23, die hochgezogen wurden und auch durchaus mit Toren dazu beigetragen haben. Ich glaube, in der Defensive ist auch zum Beispiel ein Phil Neumann besonders hervorzuheben, der da auch mit Halzenberg gut harmoniert und das gut absichert. Und natürlich, Hannover hat einen Torhüter, der meistens, oder in 95 Prozent der Fälle, eine große Souveränität ausstrahlt mit Ron-Roberts Zieler. Ja, ganz zufällig.
Du wolltest gerade sagen, das ist sehr wichtig, das hier zu erwähnen, der Weltmeister.
Der Weltmeister von 2014, der ja auch schon ganz lange im Verein ist und das immer auch alles so absichert und auch gerade erst seinen Vertrag bei Hannover nochmal um ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre verlängert hat.
Genau. Ja, Marc sagt gerne erst, bevor ich hier reingrete. Du müsstest dich entmuten.
Klassiker. Wo wir gerade bei Transfers sind, was glaube ich sehr kritisch gesehen wurde, war der Winterverkauf von Derek Köhne, der zu knapp 3,3 Millionen, 3,5 Millionen oder so was, was natürlich eine stolze Summe ist für den Zweitligisten, die man dadurch auch nicht ablegen konnte, auch, ich glaube, weil Derek Köhnes Vertrag nicht mehr ewig lief und er unbedingt gehen wollte. Denen hat man im Winter abgegeben, sehr, sehr spät. Und er war natürlich mit seinen Toren, Vorlagen, Standardsituationen immens wichtig für das Spiel als Schienenspieler unter Stefan Leithel. Und für den hat man schlichtweg keinen Ersatz geholt. So ein bisschen die Antra-Frankfurt-Cole-Muhani-Geschichte. Man muss das Geld mitnehmen und verkauft ihn spät und hat aber eigentlich gar keinen Ersatz parat. Also wirtschaftlich irgendwie richtige Entscheidungen, sportlich, sehr fragwürdig. Und das wurde, glaube ich, über den Verantworten sehr kritisch gesehen. Das sieht man ja auch daran. Janik Dem, der eigentlich Rechtsverteidiger ist, musste, der hat es, glaube ich, sogar ganz ordentlich gemacht, aber musste dann wirklich als Verzweiflungslösung da links helfen. Und das hat man sich bestimmt sehr anders vorgestellt. Und das hat, glaube ich, für die Rückrunde definitiv einen Rückschlag bedeutet.
Ja, ich finde tatsächlich die Personale direkt können immer sehr interessant, weil ich habe auch ein paar Freundinnen, die es mit 96 halten. Und ich kann mich schon daran erinnern, gerade letzte Saison war ja ein Spieler, wo man sagen musste, der hat offensiv definitiv immer so seine Impulse gesetzt, aber als Defensivspieler, wo man ja doch dann immer als erstes darauf guckt hat, der immer mal wieder so komplette Aussetzer, wo er glaube ich dann, also ich meine, es gab dann schon mal die Diskussion im Sommer, ob er überhaupt bleibt. Und dann, wie es dann ja meistens bei solchen Spielern ist, spätestens im Winter, weil das vielleicht dann auch im Training dann doch gesehen wird, okay, da wird sie vielleicht nicht mehr 100 Prozent reingehangen. Klar, da wird auch der wirtschaftliche Aspekt eine Rolle spielen. Aber generell, ja, finde ich 96, irgendwie, die haben, die haben ja so Spiele gegen Elbersberg, wo man sagt, okay, eigentlich, wenn sie ein Spiel reingehen, das müssten sie klar gewinnen. Und da sind sie der klare Favorit. Und dann gibt es Spiele gegen HSV, wo man sagt, okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das Spiel, wo man am meisten erwartet. Und wie du schon gesagt hast, so ein absolutes Freak-Spiel am Ende auch. Aber wo sie dann auch als, wie ich finde, verdienter Sieger vom Platz gegangen sind, ist auf jeden Fall durchaus interessant. Und du hast eben schon mal die Jugend angesprochen. Da ist jetzt die zweite Mannschaft heute gegen Würzburg in den Relegationsaufstiegsspielen in die dritte Liga aufgestiegen. Das ist eben möglich, weil es zwei unterschiedliche Ligensysteme sind. In die zweite Liga dürften sie nicht aufsteigen. Das hast du schon mal so gesagt. Aber es zeigt da natürlich auch so viel Kritik, man meiner Meinung nach auch berechtigt über zweite Mannschaften in diesem Ligensystem üben darf. Das ist natürlich auch ein Zeichen dafür, dass da durchaus gute Arbeit geleistet wird. Auch wenn unter anderem einer der Spieler in der Defensive ein Julian Börner ist, der dann irgendwann aussortiert wurde, wo der Vertrag verlängert werden musste, weil er auf eine gewisse Anzahl von Spielen in der zweiten Liga gekommen ist. Aber ja, das unterstreicht auf jeden Fall deinen Punkt. Oliver wollte glaube ich noch was sagen.
Ja, diesen Aufstieg von der zweiten finde ich irgendwie extrem spannend. Also mich als Hansa-Fan betrifft es ja dann auch in der neuen Saison, statt gegen Hannover 96.1, dann gegen Hannover 96.2 zu spielen. Das löst jetzt nicht Jubelstürme mehr aus, aber tatsächlich sind die ja sportlich nicht so weit voneinander weg und im Prinzip musst du jetzt als Hannover 96 irgendwie einen Kader mit 40 Leuten oder 50 Leuten planen, die alle ein eben relativ ähnliches Niveau haben. Und das finde ich sehr interessant. Und auch den Umstand, falls Hannover 96.1 absteigen sollte, was ich jetzt erstmal als nicht sehr wahrscheinlich erachte, dann müsste ja die zweite auch zwingend absteigen, egal wie sie die Saison bestreiten. Und dann sogar gleich zwei liegen, weil 3. Liga und Regionalliga geht nicht mit zweiter Mannschaft.
Ja, ich glaube, vor Hannover liegt ein interessanter Sommer. Im Winter haben die zum Beispiel gar niemanden verpflichtet zur Rückrunde. Und deswegen denke ich jetzt, dass im Sommer auch einiges passieren wird. Und Markus Mann hat da ein bisschen Arbeit vor sich. Und natürlich ist es hier oder in Hannover einfach so, dass neben dem Platz auch immer ganz schön viel Getöse los ist. Ich glaube, alle wissen so oder viele wissen diese Geschichte mit Martin Kind, der ja schon auch sehr lange im Verein da ist und auch nicht auf absehbare Zeit irgendwie den Verein verlassen wird. Also zumindest erweckt das so den Eindruck, obwohl er jetzt irgendwie auch schon 80 Jahre alt geworden ist. Und vielleicht auch mal, ja, aber genau. Ich glaube, in Hannover kochen die Emotionen auch immer relativ schnell hoch. Dann schaltet sich Martin Kind ein, sagt wieder irgendwas zu dem Thema. Also jetzt in der Saison 2024, 2025 wollen wir auf jeden Fall den Bundesliga-Aufstieg schaffen, was dann den Trainer auch zwangsläufig wieder unter Druck setzt. Dann wird der Trainer dazu in irgendwelchen Sky-Interviews befragt. Ja, ich glaube, Hannover ist so ein Standort, da wird nicht so schnell Ruhe einkehren. Und dann ist ja mal noch diese Diskussion mit 50 plus 1. Und dann war das mit den Investoren, dass Herr Kind seine Stimme mit Ja abgegeben hat, aber ihm angewiesen wurde, mit Nein zu stimmen. Ich bin gespannt, was sich da in der nächsten Saison oder in der nächsten Saison, ich gehe davon aus, dass Martin Kind dann immer noch da sein wird, da weiterentwickelt bei 96.
Auf jeden Fall ganze Thematik Hannover-Vertrag und Co. Und eben auch, dass man ja durchaus im Zuge der Investoren Proteste, nicht Prozesse, so weit war es noch nicht, Proteste durchaus ersehen konnte, dass da diese, ich sag mal, die Fede auch zwischen Fans und Kind natürlich auch nochmal enorm hochgekocht ist. Also beziehungsweise wieder, in einer bestimmten Schwelle war es ja immer, aber dass es auf jeden Fall nochmal deutlich in die Höhe gestiegen ist. Und ja, wird natürlich sehr interessant sein. Ich glaube, dass, also auch ehrlich gesagt, die Thematik 50 plus 1 vom Europäischen Gerichtshof beziehungsweise vom Bundeskartellamt, da gab es jetzt zuletzt eigentlich durchaus, ich sag mal, für die 50 plus 1-Regel positive Nachrichten, aber da ist natürlich dann immer die Frage, was passiert denn mit Ausnahmen? Und ja, ich glaube, Martin Kind ist da durchaus polarisierend. Also gab ja auch unter anderem die genug Sendung zu dem Thema, hart aber fair, Stichwort. Aber generell können wir, glaube ich, zu dem Thema auch nochmal die Tribunengespräche mit unter anderem Khaled Nahar empfehlen, die da immer nah dabei waren. Und ich glaube, das würde bei uns jetzt auch den Rahmen sprengen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass, also wenn ich mich richtig dran erinnere, wurde bei Stefan Leithelp in der Antrittspk damals gesagt, es gibt wie so einen 3-Jahres-Plan. Und am Ende dieses 3-Jahres-Plans soll der Aufstieg stehen. Und wir haben nächstes Jahr. Dann ist natürlich auch immer die Frage, natürlich kannst du vor 3 Jahren nicht vorweg sehen, wer kommt in diese Liga? Was kommt von unten mit Ulm, Münster, Regensburg? Sicherlich nicht die klassischen Aufsteiger in dem Sinne. Aber wir haben eben auch gesehen, in den letzten Jahren, zumindest ein Aufsteiger bleibt dann doch drin. Und von oben eben mit Köln und Darmstadt. Ja, gerade mit Köln, glaube ich, schwierig zu bewerten. Bei Darmstadt weiß man noch nicht, wann sie direkt wieder hoch. Aber wird wahrscheinlich schon, jetzt mal vorsichtig gesagt, eine leichtere, oder leichter sind sie diese Saison nicht. Aber es ist natürlich schon, sie werden mit dem HSV und auch Dona Düsseldorf, Marc wird sicherlich auch gleich noch mal was zur Hertha BST sagen. Ja, nee, schüttel den Kopf. Natürlich Vereine, die man per se da oben mitrechnet, natürlich auch Schalke 04, wir wollen das nicht untergraben, aber sind sicherlich Vereine dabei, wo man eben sagt, okay, da wird schon ein Kampf geben, aber da muss Sanofa 96 mit dran beteiligt sein. Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn es da zum Ende der Hinrunde nicht gut läuft, dass dann auch ein Martin Kind da nochmal seinen Arm hebt und eben auch Druck auf einen Markus Mann ausübt, dass man vielleicht dann doch mal einen neuen Trainer verpflichtet.
Genau, ich glaube, im 3-Jahresplan von Martin Kind ist jetzt der Aufstieg eingeplant in der nächsten Saison. Die letzten beiden Saisons waren übergangsmäßig eingerechnet, aber schon, dass man sich in der oberen Tabellenhälfte orientiert. Das hat ja geklappt, wenn letzte Saison Platz 10 war. Jetzt ist Platz 6 auf jeden Fall eine Verbesserung zu sehen. Aber jetzt ist der Aufstieg angepeilt. Und ich glaube, wie du gerade schon gesagt hast, wenn die Hinrunde dann vorbei ist, kann man eine Bilanz ziehen, wenn es dann nicht so gut aussieht. Dann steht auch Stefan Leithilf zwangsläufig unter Druck.
Ja, würde ich tatsächlich mitgehen, wenn sonst zu Hannover tatsächlich keiner mehr was zu ergänzen hat, würde ich zu den nächsten beiden Vereinen überspringen zum SC Paraborn auf Platz 7 und auch zur Spielvereinigung aus Fürth auf Platz 8. Ich gebe mir jetzt mal die Ehre, über die Vereine zu sprechen. Ich muss sagen, natürlich haben sie durchaus unterschiedliche Saisons gespielt, aber ich finde, so ein bisschen kann man sie vergleichen, indem man sagen kann, am Ende weiß man nicht so ganz, wie man die Saison jetzt bewerten soll. Also wenn man auf den SC Paraborn guckt, muss man definitiv eben im Winter eine Zäsur setzen, weil Florian Muslia im Winter zu Freiburg gewechselt ist und war schon einer der spielerisch auffälligsten Spieler und sicherlich auch einer der wichtigsten Spieler im System. Kwasniok ist alles sehr, sehr ausgeglichen. 54 zu 54 Tore, 15 Siege, 7 unentschieden, 12 Niederlagen. Wenn man da tatsächlich auf die X-Golds guckt, hat man durchaus in der Offensive unterperformt, hat aber definitiv wahrscheinlich auch was damit zu tun, dass man eben ein Top-Tor-Schützen mit Grimaldi hat, der eben zwar im hohen Einstellungenbereich ist, aber eben im Einstellungenbereich ist mit 9 Toren. Und es ist jetzt zwar pass zu den Platzierungen der letzten Jahre, also wenn man mal gucken soll, dass sie in der 2. Liga sind Platz 9, Platz 7, Platz 6, Platz 7. Also irgendwie immer in den Top 10 vertreten und sicherlich auch nach den ganzen Jahren, wo man eigentlich immer entweder Platz 2 oder Platz 18 hatte. So eine gewisse Ruhe, die da mit reingekommen ist. Aber ich muss am Ende dieser Saison sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob Pada-Born-Fans wirklich wissen, was sie mit dieser Saison anfangen wollen. Sicherlich zählen sie immer durch den durchaus sehr offensiv attraktiven Fußball, den Lukas Kwasniak ja auch so ein bisschen im Stile auf jeden Fall und auf den Spuren von Steffen Baumgart spielen lässt. Ja, wollen sie schon irgendwie immer mit oben dabei sein, das gelingt ihnen auch, aber eben auch wie in den letzten Jahren. Zum Ende hin fehlt eben vielleicht noch das letzte Prozent. Auch wenn jetzt keiner von euch sich intensiv mit dem Verein beschäftigt hat. Trotzdem, wer möchte einfach gerne mal die Frage in die Runde? Wie sieht ihr beim Paderborn oder beim ST Paderborn so die Entwicklung in den letzten Jahren?
Finanziell muss man sagen, also rein wirtschaftlich wurde da ja wirklich sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Nicht ohne Grund weckt dann so jemand wie Ralf Huschen Interesse und wird jetzt Geschäftsführer Finanzen bei Hertha. Das passiert ja auch eher selten, dass solche Leute dann so den Verein wechseln. Das bedeutet, dass man da gute Arbeit geleistet hat. Paderborn, wir alle wissen, das ist ein Verein, der jetzt außerhalb seiner Stadtgrenzen nicht für so viel Aufmerksamkeit sorgt. Und trotzdem war es ansofern eine spannende Saison. Man hat ja nicht nur Muslia im Winter verloren, sondern man hat auch Ron Scheibenberg und Julian Just im Sommer verloren, die ja auch, zweifelsohne, sehr wichtige Spieler waren. Uwe Hünemeyer hat seine Karriere beendet. Der ist jetzt im Trainerstab Paderborns, aber als Spieler in der Kabine nicht mehr vorhanden. Und man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, da war ja ein gewisser Max Kruse zwischendurch unterwegs in Paderborn. Das hat man fast schon wieder vergessen. Er vielleicht auch. Ich glaube, das war so ein Versuch. Also man muss sagen, bei Paderborn funktioniert es nicht, wenn man große Namen holt. Das war bei Steffen Effenberg so. Das war bei Max Kruse so. Ich glaube, das tut dem Verein in der Regel nicht gut. Und ich glaube, da musste man sich so ein bisschen wieder an seine Wurzeln erinnern. Und ich erinnere mich tatsächlich an eine spannende Aussage oder Phase auch in dieser Saison. Der lief es sportlich nicht gut. Da gab es auch, glaube ich, eine sehr schlimme Niederlage. Eine sehr hohe Gegend. Boah, lasst mich nicht lügen. Die haben ein Spiel wirklich übel ins Gesicht bekommen. Vielleicht war es das Null zu viel.
Ja, führt eventuell direkt am Ende.
Am Anfang, genau. Und es war zwischendurch immer mal wieder so ein 4-1 gegen Elbersbergen. Null zu viel gegen Holstein-Kiel. Solche Geschichten kamen immer wieder vor. Und dann hat Lukas Kwasniok ausgeholt und hat gesagt, es ist okay, wenn sich gewisse Spieler beim SC Paderborn nicht mehr damit identifizieren können, was der SC Paderborn ist und was die tagtägliche Aufgabe ist als Spieler vom SC Paderborn. Aber dann können sie hier nicht bleiben. Und was damit einherging, war, dass man beispielsweise den Torhüter und Kapitän Jannik Huth rasiert hat. Was nicht ohne ist. Ich glaube, das ging ein, zwei andere Spieler auch so. Und da hat Kvassniok wirklich einmal im Kader rasiert, während der Saison eine neue Hierarchie gebaut, um wieder diesen Hunger zu wecken, den Paderborn ja durchaus ausstrahlt in den Saisons, dass die schon was wollen. Und es ist ihm gelungen. Das muss man sagen. Die sportliche Kehrtwende hat durchaus funktioniert. Die stand in der Saison auch schon mal schlechter da. Wie gesagt, mit dem Fußball, den Kvassniok spielt, der mutig ist. Und was eben auch dazu gehört, und das Verein Paderborn ja auch mit Kreuter Fürth, man muss die Vereine nicht spannend finden. Aber was sie leisten jedes Jahr, was Entwicklungsarbeit angeht, ist wirklich beeindruckend. Wie viele Nicht-Profis aus dem Amateurbereich, Jugendspieler und ähnliches, die jedes Jahr hochholen und zu arrivierten Zweitligaspielern machen, die teilweise sogar in die erste Liga wechseln, finde ich wirklich beeindruckend. Bei Paderborn kann man da vielleicht stellvertretend Kevin Brackelmann nennen in der Innenverteidigung, der vor kurzem noch bei Rödinghausen gespielt hat und in kürzester Zeit plötzlich dann wichtiger Spieler bei Paderborn geworden ist in der Innenverteidigung. Das sind so Personalien, die finde ich für sich als singuläre Phänomene sehr, sehr spannend. Und dadurch, dass sie eben nicht so ganz singulär sind bei diesem Verein, muss man schon sagen, wird da gut gearbeitet. Ob das jetzt attraktiv ist für die Konferenz oder so, dass Leute sagen, Paderborn gegen Fürth, da schalte ich ein. Das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber das muss man schon anerkennen, was die da leisten.
Ja, definitiv. Und gerade auch da ist die Jugend, glaube ich, ganz gut in der Regionalliga vertreten, also auch im oberen Bereich, glaube ich, unterwegs. Auf jeden Fall haben da auch eine ganz gute Runde gespielt. Olli wollte auch noch was dazu beitragen.
Du hast ja diesen Umstand angesprochen, dass Paderborn ja dann auch zeitweise sehr wild Fahrstuhl gefahren ist in den Ligen von der dritten in die erste und wieder zurück. Und ich glaube, vor dem Hintergrund ist man vielleicht auch ganz froh, dass man da jetzt einfach so eine Kontinuität hat. Und da muss man wirklich auch sagen, das ist ja seit Steffen Baumgart und dann war Markus Gröscher da, ich sage jetzt mal der Sportdirektor, vielleicht war er auch Sportvorstand, aber auf jeden Fall der Verantwortliche. Und die es ja dann tatsächlich geschafft haben, da auch aus einem Beinahe schon Viertligisten zwischendurch eine Bundesligamannschaft zu machen, aber dann auch irgendwas hinterlassen haben, was jetzt stabil ist. Und dann hatte man ja auch mit Wilfried Klose, langen Jahren Präsidenten, der sei mal ähnlich.
Finke, Wilfried Finke.
Finke, Entschuldigung. Ja, so ein bisschen wie Martin Kind in klein, da auch für sehr wilde Sachen teilweise stand. So und der ist jetzt vor fünf Jahren gestorben und auch da hat man es aber geschafft, glaube ich, diese Abhängigkeit auch von seinem Unternehmen zu lösen. Zumindest so aus der Ferne mein Eindruck. Und sich einfach zu einem stabilen Standort entwickelt. Und ich glaube, das ist schon auch eine Leistung, die man irgendwo wertschätzen kann. Und was dann vielleicht auch die Fans so sehen, wenn sie auf die Saison blicken.
Ja, definitiv. Also, dass da gute Arbeit und nachhaltige Arbeit geleistet wird, gerade was vielleicht nicht nur eigene Jugendspieler, aber generell Spielerentwicklung betrifft. Ich glaube, damals auch bitterer Abgang, definitiv Julian Lustwahn. Spielt bei Hoffenheim jetzt, glaube ich, nicht so. Die übergeordnete Rolle ist natürlich noch bitterer, wenn du als Zweitligist einen Spieler verlierst, der bei dir einer der Herausragenden ist. Ein absoluter Unterschiedspieler, der wechselt zu einem Bundesligisten, wo er dann Ergänzungsspieler ist. Und vielleicht das Jahr darauf auch wieder verlieren wird. Also, man muss ja schon sagen, dass das auch ein Schema ist, was einen Hoffenheim fährt, was einen Eintracht Frankfurt fährt. Zum Teil auch durchaus erfolgreich, wenn man auch auf einen Maxi Bayer guckt, der bei Hannover ausgeliehen war, etc. Also, hat definitiv alles einen Sinn. Aber es ist natürlich gerade, wenn du selber als Zweitligist weißt, okay, wir brauchen die finanziellen Mittel, die daraus kreieren. Aber irgendwann bildet sich immer wieder ein Loch, was du füllen musst. Da muss man schon sagen, das ist schon bemerkenswert, wie Pada Born es immer wieder schafft, durchaus Spieler zu entwickeln, die einen Unterschied machen, die sich gut entwickeln beim Verein, aber sich nicht komplett so abhängig von diesen Spielern macht, dass man sagt, okay, wenn die weg sind, kann man davon ausgehen, dass in nächster Saison der Abstieg folgt. Und eben auch, Marc, was du angesprochen hattest, dieser Cut kann man, glaube ich, auch in einer der Rasenfunk-Folgen nachholen. Als Kevin Bublitz hier zu Gast war, von Parder Karst, der das auch nochmal ganz gut aufgedröselt hat. Von daher, ja, definitiv auch eine spannende Geschichte immer wieder. Und ja, gerade in der Liga eine Konstanz in den Top 10 hinzulegen, ist durchaus auch bemerkenswert. Ich meine, wir sehen es beim FC Heidenheim, was passieren kann, wenn du eben Jahr für Jahr da einen Grundkurist hast, eine Spielidee hast. Und Lukas Kwasniaks Spielweise ist ansehnlich, weil sie eben zwar eigene Tore produziert, aber eben auch Gegentore produziert, weil sehr kuriose Sachen zum Teil entstehen. Aber das muss man ja schon sagen für den neutralen Zuschauenden. Auf jeden Fall natürlich ein absoluter Punkt, auch was dann in Zukunft passiert, weil man ganz oft Spieler aus der Regionalliga verpflichtet, die man vielleicht durchs Nahab- und Obachten der Nachwuchsmannschaft sieht. Ich denke, das ist ein Weg, mit dem Paderborn richtig fährt und mit dem sie auch in Zukunft richtig fahren kann. Deshalb damals auch dieser Max-Guse-Transfer. Sehr merkwürdig. Lisa, hack gerne ein. Ich finde, ganz viele Sachen, die du gerade schon über Paderborn gesagt hast, passen auch ganz gut zu Fürth. Ich finde, das sind zwei Vereine, die nicht nur tabellarisch sehr nahe sind, sondern auch, was das Hochziehen von Jungspielern angeht, von Spielerentwickeln angeht. Was ein bisschen ein Vorteil ist, glaube ich, bei beiden Clubs, ihr habt es gerade gesagt, da schaltet man vielleicht nicht aktiv die Konferenz ein und es freut sich, wenn die gegeneinander spielen oder wenn die dabei sind, weil das jetzt keine Clubs sind, die eine große Reichweite haben, die eine riesige Strahlkraft haben. Dass einfach das gesamte Konstrukt, was dann vielleicht einen Verein mit sich bringt, bei den Clubs einfach ein bisschen angenehmer ist, als wenn wir jetzt nach Berlin gucken oder wenn wir zum HSV gucken, wo einfach die Erwartungshaltung eine ganz andere ist. Deswegen war es vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, dachte ich gerade, Eva, dass du beide Clubs auch hast, weil viele Sachen decken sich für mich da sehr. Ich glaube, ein Hauptunterschied zwischen den beiden Vereinen. Ich habe eben davon gesprochen, dass man sich eben nicht komplett abhängig macht von einem Spieler. Ich würde bei Fürth da eine Ausnahme machen, weil es bleibt weiterhin, dass Fürth natürlich enorm abhängig von Brandy Miocota ist. Also seit Jahren eigentlich, es ist ein super Spieler, aber ist definitiv einer der Kernspieler und einer der Schlüsselspieler in diesem Konzept der Spielvereinigung. Ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, 50 Punkte sind es. Auch da relativ ausgeglichen, was auch Siegeniederlagen betrifft, was auch die geschossenen Tore und kassierten Tore betrifft. Also das balanciert sich da auch alles aus. Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem bei Fürth war die Auswärtsschwäche. Also das ist auch etwas, was man unter Alex Thorniger in der letzten Saison nicht komplett in den Griff bekommen hat, obwohl man letzte Saison natürlich sowieso so ein bisschen abgekapselt sehen muss. Man hat mehr Punkte geholt als in der letzten Saison. Da hatte man ja auch einen sehr, sehr schwierigen Start als Bundesligabsteiger. Aber man hat eben nur vier Sieger außerhalb geholt des eigenen Stadions. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Alex Thorniger wahnsinnig gut gefällt. Er ist ja auch ein Trainer, der durchaus eine klare Struktur hat, eine klare Vorstellung, wie bei ihm Fußball gespielt werden soll. Und der dahingehend auch die Spieler so ein bisschen formt. Also ich glaube, wenn du auf Jungspieler, Lisa, du hast es eben angesprochen, definitiv einen Tim Lempeler, der vom FC Köln ausgeliehen war, der da jetzt auch wieder hin zurückgeht, kommt sicherlich ein Spieler, der unter Zorniger enorm gereift ist, dann eine große Rolle gespielt hat, da auch einen richtigen Sprung nach vorne gemacht hat, aber eben auch einen Jonas Urwig. Zehn Spieler ohne Gegentor, der hat mir bei Regensburg letztes Jahr schon richtig gut gefallen. Das ist ein junger Torhüter mit richtig Potenzial. Also, es würde mich ehrlich gesagt nicht wundern, wenn irgendwann mal doch diese Garde an älteren Nationaltorhütern rausrutscht, weil irgendwo ist dann auch mal Ende für Manuel Neuer und Co. Ist definitiv ein Torhüter, ohne da jetzt zu viel Druck aufbauen zu wollen, den man in Zukunft beobachten kann. Also, ich finde, was der für seinen Alter auf der Linie zeigt, ist bemerkenswert. Und auch, was er eben noch mal für einen Sprung gemacht hat, von der letzten zu dieser Saison, ist durchaus nach vorne. Ich möchte einmal kurz Grüße an die beiden Jungs von 4. Flachpass senden. Wenn ihr eine richtig detaillierte Saisonanalyse haben wollt, hört da rein, die haben, glaube ich, wirklich mehr oder weniger von Testspiel zu Testspiel bis über die einzelnen Spiele eine Saisonanalyse rausgehauen. Da liebe Grüße an Michi und Christa gerne mal reinhören. Die haben das Ganze als eine ganz ordentliche Saison bezeichnet. Ich glaube, da ist Spiegelplatz auch ganz gut wieder.
Zwei Spieler, die man vielleicht auch noch mal herausheben kann. Zum einen Robert Wagner, der wichtige Schritte gemacht hat, der von Freiburg aus geliehen war und der jetzt wohl zum FC St. Pauli wechselt. Ich weiß aber nicht genau, ob fest oder per Leihe. Ich kann mir fast nicht vorstellen, dass Freiburg den fest abgibt, weil er aufgrund seiner 20 Jahre auch noch sehr viel Potenzial hat. Aber wird wohl nächstes Jahr auf jeden Fall in der ersten Liga zu sehen sein. Und wer dort auch vielleicht auftrumpfen wird, ist Armindo Sieb. Der wird zum FC Bayern zurückkehren. Die haben die Option gezogen, glaube ich, die Rückkaufoption. Das bringt Fird also auch gar nicht so wenig Geld. Auch das macht Fird gerne. Das haben sie auch beispielsweise mit Jessica Nankham und Hertha vor ein paar Jahren mal gemacht. Das ging insofern nicht ganz gut, weil er sich das Kreuzband gerissen hat. Und so Hertha hat das Ding trotzdem am Ende gezogen, weil er sich noch ganz gut gezeigt hat. Und bei Armindo Sieb, der ist auch erst 21, da kann man auch davon ausgehen, dass Bayern den dann wohl auch wieder verleihen wird, aber dann wohl eher in Erstliga gefilgen, wo er sich weiterentwickeln kann. Spannender Spieler, weil eher so hängende Spitze, wendig, gar nicht, defensiv gar nicht, äh, defensiv sage ich schon, technisch gar nicht so schlecht. Also kann auch was am Ball schwer zugreifen. Und die beiden wird man dann vielleicht auch in der Bundesliga-Saison, nächste Saison sehen können, bei welchen Feimen, dann auch immer.
Ja, ich glaube, das Hauptproblem von Fürth war am Ende der Saison tatsächlich der Sturm. Also man hatte da ja tatsächlich auch relativ hohe Fluktuation, würde ich sagen. Ragnar Ache, der zu Kaiserslautern gewechselt ist, Dixen Abiyama ist im Winter zu Kaiserslautern gewechselt, der aber ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich, am Anfang der Saison gar nicht mehr so als Stürmer Nummer 1 eingeplant war. Das war, glaube ich, unter anderem Dennis Rebeni, der vom SC Paderborn kam. Verletzt sich ausgerechnet im ersten Liga-Spiel gegen Paderborn. Das war, glaube ich, damals Muslio mit einem durchaus, ja, Rüden einsteigen. Ist im Endeffekt, glaube ich, nur ein Spiel. Also auf jeden Fall nicht lange ausgefallen. Aber hat in der ganzen Saison nur ein Tor geschossen. Das war auch erst in der Rückrunde. Also ich glaube, 50 Tore, die da am Ende geschossen stehen, das ist, wenn man da mal ein bisschen drumherum guckt, definitiv zu wenig. Und ist sogar, aber ja, lustigerweise, wie auch immer man das deuten will, immer noch mehr als die Expected Goals gezeigt haben. Also das haben sie sogar noch überperformed am Ende, zwar nur knapp. Also ich glaube, das ist definitiv ein Punkt, was eine ganz große Sache wird bei Fürth. Und das zeigt auch noch mal, wie man ja auch ehrlich gesagt Testspielergebnisse misinterpretieren kann. Da haben wir glaube ich vor Anfang der Saison irgendwie so ein 4-4 gegen Liverpool oder so gehabt oder so was Ähnliches. Also komplett wild.
Ich habe ja nun auch zwei Spiele von Fürth mindestens diese Saison gesehen gegen Hertha. Und was dazu passt, ist, dass sie zwar viele Tore haben, aber den Ex-Wekker-Goals-Wert dann sogar halten. Ich finde, Fürth, da merkt man glaube ich die Unerfahrenheit der Spieler. Fürth nimmt Schüsse aus absurden Situationen. Die schießen und schießen und schießen. Und die Chancen sind einfach wirklich mies. Weil sie nicht die Geduld aufbringen, diese jungen Spieler dort vorne, bis auf den Brandenburg-Hörgotha, das mal durchzuspielen. Ich finde Tim Lamperle ist das beste Beispiel. Immer wenn ich ihn sehe, frustriert er mich. Weil ich denke behalt doch die Ruhe, spiel das doch aus. Und das kriegen die Jungs noch nicht hin. Das gehört glaube ich zum Ausbildungsweg in Fürth dazu. Da würde es natürlich gut tun, wenn die so einen verlässlichen Mittelstürmer da vorne hätten. Das würde Fürth glaube ich in andere Tabellenregionen katapultieren. Weil vieles davor stimmt schon durchaus im Spiel. Aber die müssen eigentlich permanent Expected Goals, Schüsse von 0,1 aneinander rein. Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, weil die echt wenig ausspielen und ganz oft aus eigenartigen Winkeln Schüsse abschießen. Das ist, weiß ich nicht. Das ist glaube ich etwas, woran dann auch in der kommenden Saison sicherlich gearbeitet wird, wie man Chancen auch sauber zu Ende spielt, um am Ende einen klaren Torschuss zu haben.
Ja, bin ich komplett bei dir. Ich habe ja den Weg von Fürth auch ein bisschen verfolgt, weil man ja zusammen aus der Bundesliga abgestiegen ist und es dann erst aussah, als würde es sowohl für Bielefeld auch als für Fürth direkt weiter runtergehen. Ich glaube, es waren damals die schlechtesten Bundesliga-Absteiger entweder in der Geschichte oder seit langer Zeit. Die Statistiken holt man sich immer gerne ab. Aber ich muss schon sagen, damals Alex Zorniger dann ja doch relativ früh in der Saison zu holen, war definitiv ein guter Schritt. Ich war am Anfang, wusste ich nicht so ganz, was man von ihm da jetzt erwarten konnte, aber er hat auf jeden Fall Stabilität reingebracht. Aber ich glaube eben auch, dass ja, auf Azusi kommt da durchaus auch ein bisschen Arbeit im Sommer zu. Also auch ein Petkoff vorne im Sturm hat definitiv nicht so performt, wie sie sich es vorgestellt haben. Fand ich aber durchaus auch nicht komplett unwahrscheinlich, so wie man ihn auch in der Saison davor gesehen hat. Aber ja, ich würde tatsächlich sagen, die Offensive ist eins der Hauptbaustellen, die für jetzt zu bekämpfen hat. Weil es kann auf Dauer nicht immer alles an Brandy Milgutte abhängig gemacht werden. Irgendwann geht das nämlich nicht mehr gut, glaube ich. Gut, wollen wir weiter gucken auf Platz 9. Und da steht Hertha BSC. 48 Punkte, 13 Siege, 9 Unentschieden, 12 Niederlagen. Und ja, ich würde sagen, so ein bisschen Abhängigkeit von Spielern, das kennt Hertha BSC auch.
Eventuell ja, wenn man einen der drei Torschützenkönige stellt. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob Fabi Reze dann, wahrscheinlich war Fabi Reze am Ende der Topscorer dieser Liga. Ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher, nicht dass ich da Quark erzähle. Er wird auf jeden Fall sehr weit vorne mit dabei gewesen sein. Und die beiden waren, glaube ich, insgesamt über 50 Toren direkt beteiligt. Hertha hat immer wieder, bzw. Paldada hat immer wieder darauf verwiesen, dass Hertha ja kein Offensivproblem habe, weil man ja 69 Tore geschossen hat. Ist dann halt nur doof, wenn das quasi von zwei Spielern kommt. Und wenig Systematik beinhaltet, kommen wir noch, glaube ich, zu, wenn wir auf die Arbeit von Paldada blicken. Sondern eben, wie gesagt, von zwei Spielern abhängig ist. Und wenn die beiden keinen guten Tag erwischt haben, hat Hertha in der Regel auch keinen guten Tag erwischt, nein.
Ja, ich fand es tatsächlich sehr interessant, weil ich kann mich dran erinnern, ich war vor der Saison tatsächlich bei euch im HerthaBase Podcast zu Gast. Und da sollte ich damit so ein paar Survival-Kids 2. Liga geben. Und ich weiß, dass ich damals auf einen Punkt kritisch bei Hertha geguckt habe, vor allem, oder einer, der war damals so ein bisschen bei mir. Und das war der große Kader, ich glaube, Hertha stellt unter anderem zusammen mit Braunschweig und Osnabrück, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, den größten Kader mit 31 Spielern am Ende. Und dann wird es auf jeden Fall laut Transfermarkt festgehalten. Wenn du jetzt auf die Saison guckst, hast du das Gefühl, das war zwischendurch ein Problem, dass der Kader zu breit war? Oder sagst du, dann haben am Ende die gleichen gespielt und die Ersatzspieler mussten sich damit arrangieren?
Nee, im Vergleich große Kader hat keine Rolle in irgendeiner Debatte gespielt. Ich glaube, das liegt auch daran, dass die Zahlen natürlich auch immer verfälschen, je nachdem, wie diese Kader strukturiert. Bei Hertha hast du wahnsinnig viele Eigengewächse im Profikader, die teilweise aber gar nicht immer permanent dort spielen. Nehmen wir beispielsweise Gustav Christensen, Benz Darday, Bradley Ibrahim, Mesut Kesik. Das sind alles Spieler, die Profiverträger haben und deswegen im Profikader aufgeführt sind, aber in der Regel für die zweite Mannschaft oder U19 zum Einsatz kamen und deswegen gar nicht die große Rolle gespielt haben. Viel eher hatte man das Gefühl, dass Paldarday eben nicht das ganze Potenzial des Kaders genutzt hat. Und Spieler, die eigentlich mehr Spielzeit verdient gehabt hätten bzw. einfach mehr Vertrauen verdient gehabt hätten, unterm Radar geblieben sind. Bilal Hussein ist da vor allen Dingen zu nennen, der im Sommer aus Schweden kam. Immerhin hat man für Bilal Hussein, ich glaube, 750.000 Euro oder so ausgegeben, was jetzt im Vergleich gar nicht so wenig Geld war bei Hertha, gar nicht so viel Transfers ausgegeben hat im Sommer. Wenn jemand Ablöse gekostet hat, hat man dreimal hingeguckt, wenn man sich schon dachte, von dem verspricht man sich dann wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr, wie bei einem Karbovnik, der der Königstransfer war. Aber da sind Spieler unter Paldare weniger zum Einsatz gekommen, weil sie vermeintlich nicht zu seiner Spielidee gepasst haben. Gleichzeitig mussten sie sich dann fragen, warum sie dann... Da hat man an solchen Personalien schon gespürt, dass auch Kader oder die Vorstellungen, die die Verantwortlichen haben, wie man Erfolg haben kann mit diesen Kader, nicht damit zusammengepasst haben, wie Trainer Paldare dann damit zusammenarbeiten wollte. Und da sind einige Spieler leider ihrem Potenzial hinterhergelaufen, weil sie gar nicht die Chance bekommen haben.
Ja, aber dann lass uns doch tatsächlich mal auf Paldare schauen, auf seine Rolle, seine Spielidee. Ich finde Platz 9 am Ende ist immer super schwierig, von außen zu bewerten, weil es ist halt literal das Mittelmaß der Liga. Du guckst da irgendwie auf die Mitte. Und keine Ahnung bei dem, was natürlich bei Hertha auch in dieser Saison vor der Saison passiert ist, also auch generell dieser Abstieg an sich. Aber dann natürlich auch mit dem Tod von Kai Bernstein passiert ist, war natürlich, muss man ja einfach sagen, sowas kann man einfach nie aus einer Rechnung rausbeziehen. Aber generell, wenn du jetzt auf die Saison guckst und mit Pardal Dadai wird es ja nicht weitergehen, wie siehst du von Anfang an die Entscheidung, mit ihm weiterzumachen in der Rückperspektive, aber generell auch, ja, so wie die Mannschaft am Ende performt hat?
Pardal Dadai kam in den letzten Spielen der vergangenen, also mittlerweile vorletzter Saison, muss man ja sagen, nachdem die 23. oder 24. Runde ja auch beendet ist, kam halt zum Ende hin, um noch das Himmelfahrtskommando anzutreten und Hertha irgendwie noch in dieser Liga zu halten. Das hat nicht geklappt, konnte man ihm aber in keinem Fall anlasten, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeiten unendlich gering waren. Und dann war klar, dass Hertha in der 2. Liga einen unglaublichen Neuaufbau betreiben muss. Ich lese jetzt mal ein paar Namen vor, die vielleicht signalisieren, wo Hertha herkommt. Dodi Luka Bakio, Marco Richter, Luka Tousard, Santi Ascassiba, Maximilian Mittelstedt, Piontek, Oremovic, Jovovic, Suat Serdar. Und ich könnte die Liste ewig weiterführen, denn Hertha hatte einen unendlich wuseligen Transfersommer. Es gab über 30 Kaderbewegungen am Ende, und das war auch so abzusehen. Unendlich viele Spieler haben den Verein verlassen. Sehr viele sind neu dazugekommen. Es wurden Talente hochgezogen. Und es war vollkommen klar, dass es ein Neuaufbau braucht und dass es ein erstes Jahr in dieser Liga geben wird, wo man eventuell mit ganz viel Glück vielleicht auch oben anklopfen kann, wie sich die Dinge in einer so engen zweiten Liga oft entwickeln können. Das gab es ja schon. Und gleichzeitig war das aber auch nie das erklärte Saisonziel, direkt aufsteigen zu müssen. Dann ging es erstmal um Stabilisierung. Und Stabilisierung verbindet man mit einem Trainer, und das ist Paldadai. Paldadai holt ihr in der Regel in der ersten Liga Platz 9, aber auch in der zweiten Liga Platz 9, wie es sich jetzt herausstellt. Du weißt sehr genau, was du von ihm bekommst, weißt aber auch, was du nicht von ihm bekommst. Ich war jemand, der im Vorhinein gesagt hat, gebt ihm gerne diese Chance, vielleicht überrascht uns Paldadai sogar, denn bislang war er ja auch derjenige, der immer mit geringeren Mitteln einen Verein wie Hertha in der Liga halten musste. Und deswegen gab es auch immer am Schließkampf Fußball. Ich dachte mir, ich habe Paldadai eher als pragmatischen Menschen kennengelernt. Und dachte mir, vielleicht hat er ja in der zweiten Liga auch die Lust und auch die Ideen dafür, einen eher überdurchschnittlich talentierten Kader für mehr aufzubauen und bessere Dinge zeigen zu können. Und mindestens die Stabilisierung hinzubekommen. Zweiteres hat er hinbekommen, das kann man so sagen. Wenn man guckt, die ersten Spiele liefen mir auch überhaupt nicht gut. Man erinnere sich an die schwarze Serie zu Beginn. Drei Spiele, drei Niederlagen, null Tore. Da stand aber beispielsweise auch noch Marco Richter auf dem Feld. Auch das andere Zeiten eigentlich. Und ab da hat man aber es hinbekommen mit Stützen, mit Achsenspielern wie Toni Leisner in der Innenverteidigung, Thiak Ernst im Tor, John Joe Kenny auf rechts hinten, der Anna ja noch was sagen dürfte, aber auch so Leuten wie dann im Mittelfeld, einem jungen Pascal Clemens, aber vor allen Dingen dann natürlich Fabi Reese. Und Harris Tabakovic hat man es geschafft, eine Aktie zu bauen, die nie anders als beispielsweise Schalke in die Nähe des Abschließkampfes in der Zweitliga gerutscht ist. Und da, muss man sagen, hat Paldada geliefert. Und das hätte eventuell auch niemand in diesem so unruhigen Umfeld wie bei Hertha BSC so schnell und so sauber hinbekommen. Das steht fest. Wie gesagt, wenn man zurückblickt, Hertha hätte beinahe nicht die Zweitliga-Dizenz erhalten. Wie gesagt, 30-Kader-Bewegungen, ein völlig neues Gesicht, insgesamt neue Verantwortliche, die dieses Projekt Zweitliga auch noch nie selber betreut haben. Ob das jetzt Sportdirektor Benny Weber ist oder eben Trainer Paldardai. Deswegen wusste man noch nicht genau, worauf man sich einlässt. Man hat darauf gehofft, sich auf der einen Seite sportlich zu stabilisieren. Nach diesen Jahren des Investor-Chaos und so weiter sich auch so ein bisschen wieder, dass sich Vereine und Fans auch wieder annähern. Und dass es wieder ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl gibt. Das war natürlich ganz eng verbunden mit der Personalie. Aber bevor ich da überall zu weit gehe, das erstmal vielleicht auch zu der Erwartungshaltung, die es unter Paldare gab, was er geliefert hat. Und jetzt könnte ich auch dazu kommen, was er nicht geliefert hat und was vielleicht dazu geführt hat, warum es dann eben nicht mit ihm weiterging. Du nix, dann mach ich weiter.
Er gänzt gern. Ich hör dir einfach gerne weiter hinzu.
Denn die Erwartungshaltung war, wie gesagt, eigentlich keine allzu hohe. Man wollte gucken, was geht in dieser Liga. Und am Ende muss man schon sagen, blickt man auf die Hinrunde, auf gewisse Spiele in der 2. Saisonhälfte, dann ist das auch eine Saison der verpassten Chancen. Sowohl in der Liga als auch im Pokal. Im Pokal ist es sehr schnell abgefriestückt. Man hätte den Weg von Kaiserslautern gehen können, hätte man sie im Viertelfinale geschlagen. Dann wären wir im Halbfinale gegen... Also vermeintlich, das weiß man nie so genau, gegen den Saarbrücken gezogen worden und hätten im Finale stehen können. Und das ist natürlich der Sehnsuchtsort, das Olympiastadion, das Finale zu Hause, das irgendwann mal zu erreichen. Bis dahin hatte man seinen Weg gemacht. Und dann hat man dieses Spiel gegen Casaslautern. Und das muss man bald darin ankreiden. Wirklich historisch in den Sand gesetzt, in dem plötzlich ein Systemwechsel von Vierer auf Dreierkette kam. Und man Marius Gersbeck plötzlich in Zerror gestellt hat, nachdem Thiago Ernst die gesamte Saison im Tor stand. Das hat man also in den Sand gesetzt. Und in der Saison muss man sagen, die Hinrunde wurde in Ordnung beendet. Man hat gesehen, durch gewisse Spiele, wie beispielsweise das 5-0 gegen Fürth, das 3-0 gegen Braunschweig und ähnliche Spiele, ey, es geht was. Es haben sich Gesichter herausgebildet, es hat sich eine Achse herausgebildet. Die Mannschaft, das ist eine gesunde Kabine, das ist eine gesunde Mannschaft, das hatte man seit Jahren nicht mehr. Aufstrebende Talente streben nach oben. Und man hat ja noch gar nicht alles gesehen, weil ein Paco Dada hatte sich früh verletzt, ein Ibo Masa hatte sich früh verletzt. Neuzugänge wie Bukhalakis, Hussein mussten ja auch erst mal überhaupt ankommen. Und Paco Dada sagte, dass er die Hinrunde auf Platz 4 bis 5 beenden wolle, um noch von etwas zu träumen in der Rückrunde. So. Platz 4 bis 5 ist es in der Hinrunde nicht geworden. Und am Ende konnte man auch von nichts mehr träumen. Und das hat eben auch sehr, sehr stark mit der Rückrunde zu tun, die sicherlich natürlich der Anfang der Rückrunde, da brauchen wir überhaupt nicht überreden. Das war selbstverständlich von dem unglaublich tragischen Tod von Karl Bernstein eingefärbt. Wenn man sich an die Bilder zum Rückrundenauftakt gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf erinnert, wenn man sich dann anschaut, wie träge die Auftritte danach gingen, beispielsweise in Wiesbaden waren, die sportlich sehr enttäuschend waren, menschlich sehr verständlich, dann weiß man, dass es da schon Knick gegeben hat. Aber irgendwann hat man auch gespürt, dass das nicht mehr die Erklärung ist für gewisse Leistungen. Und was eben unter Paldare nicht passiert ist, ist die spielerische, taktische Weiterentwicklung. Man hat gesehen, was sich die Verantwortlichen mit diesem Kader gedacht haben. Spieler wie Bilal Hussein, Jeremy Dudziak, wie andere wie Ibrahim Masa beispielsweise, stehen eigentlich für einen Fußball, der dominant auftreten soll. Positionswechsel, man möchte in kleinen Räumen viele technische Lösungen haben, gleichzeitig aber auch, das erinnert dann so ein bisschen an KSC, gleichzeitig auch mit Flanken agieren können, weil man hat ja Reze, man hat ja Tabakovic, man wäre ja blöd, sich dem nicht zu bedienen, und das hat man ja auch zu genüge getan. Das zweite Element hat aber gefehlt. Paldadai hat es nicht geschafft, die Mannschaft spielerisch weiterzuentwickeln. Es war sehr biederer Fußball, ideenarm, immer abhängig von dem Geistesitz von Fabi Reze oder dass Tabakovic sich doch gegen zwei bis drei Innenverteidiger durchsetzt. Ansonsten gab es keine Systematik zu erkennen, keine Muster, weder im Spielaufbau noch dazu, wie man ins letzte Trippel kommt. Stattdessen hat man Sätze gehört wie Fußball in den letzten 30 Metern des Feldes, das kann man nicht trainieren. Und wenn es doch ein Journalist gewagt hat zu sagen, es gäbe eine gewisse Konzeptlosigkeit, dann ist Paldada auch gerne wütend von der PK gestürmt, was sicherlich auch kein gutes Bild abgegeben hat zu der Geschichte, die haben sicherlich alle mitbekommen. Damals muss man aber auch sagen, dieses Wort Konzeptlosigkeit von Kicker-Kollege Steffen Rohr ist in dem Artikel, dem Paldada meinte übrigens, nie gefallen. Das gehört zu der ganzen Geschichte noch dazu. Der Mann hat also offensichtlich sogar den Artikel nicht richtig verstanden, der ihn dazu weisgut gebracht hat. Und die Mischung aus teilweise dann auch bockigen öffentlichen Auftritten als auch der spielerischen Nicht-Weiterentwicklung mussten dann dazu führen, dass man gesagt hat, es ist sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass Hertha unter Paldada in der zweiten Saison den Schritt gehen wird, den es braucht, um wirklich um den Aufstieg mitspielen zu können. Und blicken wir auf die wirtschaftliche Komponente bei Hertha BSC, dann ist man in ein bis aller, aller spätestens zwei Jahren zum Aufstieg absolut verdammt. Denn Hertha hat hohe Schulden. Hertha hat eine Nordic Bond-Anleihe in Höhe von 40 Millionen Euro, die im Herbst 2025 zurückgezahlt werden muss. Das schaffst du nicht mit den TV-Geldern in der zweiten Liga. Das ist die Wahrheit. Du wirst also aufsteigen müssen. Dafür musst du die Wahrscheinlichkeiten erhöhen. Und ich kann sehr gut verstehen, dass die Verantwortlichen am Ende gesagt haben, die Stellschraube, die uns das am ehesten wahrscheinlich macht, ist die Trainerposition. Und da haben wir bei aller Identifikation und bei aller Dankbarkeit, die man gegenüber Pallada ja empfinden kann, dass er diese Aufgabe im Sommer übernommen hat, da haben wir den Glauben nicht. Und da brauchst du einen neuen Impuls, wie der aussehen wird. Wissen wir zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch nicht, ist Geister, Namen und Herr, das wird man abwarten müssen. Und auch dann wird man die Arbeit abwarten müssen, die der Trainer leistet. Aber das ist die Saison im Schnelldurchlauf.
Tatsächlich da die Frage, hast du einen Wunschkandidaten? Ich muss ja immer gestehen, ich finde das Trainerkarussell im deutschen Profifußball durchaus anstrengend irgendwann, weil immer die gleichen Namen rumgeistern. Und klar, muss nicht Trainer A bei den gleichen Vereinen oder bei unterschiedlichen Vereinen den gleichen Output haben. Aber ich finde es tatsächlich ein bisschen ermüdend, wenn man auf den Trainermarkt guckt. Hast du was, wo du sagst, okay, einfach allein spielerisch, gar nicht mehr vom Namen her an sich, aber spielerisch ist der Schlag Trainer das, was ich mir zum Kader bei Hertha, aber auch einfach zum Gesamtkonzept gut vorstellen könnte.
Ihr habt mich vorhin ja schon schwärm gehört. Ich glaube, dass Christian Eichner ein Coup wäre, der sowohl diesen Flankenfokus, den Hertha aus sehr nachvollziehbaren Gründen hat, versteht und auch mitgehen würde, der aber gleichzeitig völlig andere, modernere Ansätze in der Spieleröffnung und im Übergangsspiel ins letzte Drittel bietet. Ich finde, dass Hertha eigentlich sogar, also sollte Fabi Reese den Verein im Sommer verlassen, wonach es ja durchaus aussieht, dann hat man gar nicht mehr die klassischen Flügelstürmer, die wirklich flankenstark sind. Dann könnte man tatsächlich sogar mit dem Material, was gerade da ist, und was mit einem beispielsweise ja Kevin Sesser, der aus Heidenheim kommen soll, auch anbieten könnte, könnte man sogar diese KSC-Route spielen. Also da würde viel zusammenpassen. Es wäre insofern ein sanfter Schritt für Christian Eichner, als dass er sich nicht sofort in der ersten Liga beweisen müsste. Das wäre vielleicht auch nicht so verkehrt. Ob er das macht, ob das realistisch ist, das weiß ich nicht. Aber rein spielerisch würde das Sinn ergeben. Trotzdem vielleicht auch ein Wort zu Christian Fjell, der sehr heiß auch gehandelt wird bei Hertha. Ich weiß, dass viele da extrem skeptisch drauf gucken, teilweise sogar hämisch. Ich finde, dass Christian Fjell eigentlich spannende Arbeit bei Nürnberg leistet. Ich muss sagen, wenn man auch da auf den Kader guckt, weckt außer Can Ozu keiner meine Fantasie. Und ich finde auch da dann fast verständlich, dass es in der Rückrunde nicht so weitergegangen ist, wie es zwischenzeitlich aussah. Ich glaube, dass Christian Fjell an sich erst mal spannenden Fußball spielen lässt. Fußball mit dem 4-3-3, mit diesem offensiven Fußball spielen lässt, der zu Hertha auch passen würde, dem entspricht, was die Verantwortlichen in dem Kader sehen möchten. Der ja auch aus dem Jugendbereich kommt, der Jugend auch fördert, das hat man bei Usun gesehen, das hat man bei Nathaniel Brown gesehen, zuletzt auch bei Finn Yelch in Nürnberg. Deswegen, du hast es eben schon gesagt, Eva, Trainer A muss nicht auch Output A haben bei Verein B. Das kann auch einfach, die Schablonen können auch einfach zusammenpassen. Und das halte ich bei einem Christian Fjell nicht für ausgeschlossen. Er ist jetzt nicht mein Plädoyer, dass das sein muss, aber auch da, ich habe es ja eben gesagt, kann man ja einfach mal abwarten, wie ein Trainer funktioniert. Und das im Vorhinein irgendwie schlecht zu reden, finde ich immer ein bisschen kurzsichtig. Denn dann hätten viele Personalien im Fußball nicht geklappt, die man skeptisch gesehen hat. Das soll es ja auch geben. Ich glaube nicht, dass die beim VfB die Entwicklung unter Sebastian Hoeneß direkt so gesehen haben. Das kann alles passieren. Das muss eben nur fußballrisch passen.
Ja, finde ich tatsächlich sehr interessant, weil auch wie du es einfach begründet hast. Ich finde, es gibt ja wirklich immer den Unterschied zwischen, ach ja, den könnte ich mir ja auch vorstellen. Ja, klar, kann ich mir ja auch ein Pep Guardiola vorstellen. So ungefähr. Aber realistisch ist es halt nun mal nicht. Und das muss natürlich, also gerade die Ansätze, die du eben genannt hast, finde ich interessant. Ich bin generell dann, weil gerade eben auch für Spieler wie Tabakowitsch Reese ist natürlich auch die Frage, bleiben sie überhaupt eine volle Saison nächstes Jahr? Oder es steht eben schon im Winter, muss im Raum stehen, dass verkauft wird. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie sehr Lust du hast, das komplette 777-Drama hier auch noch aufzudröseln. Aber auch das ist ja was, was einfach über dem Verein schwebt am Ende, muss man ja auch einfach so sagen. Und dass da einfach so ein Damokleschwert definitiv immer dabei hängt von Saison zu Saison.
Was tut es bei Hertha nun schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren? Und auch Hertha, glaube ich, also mittlerweile hat Hertha den HSV in manchen Momenten sogar abgelöst als größte Drama-Queen des deutschen Fußballs. Das ist schon, und auch in dieser Saison muss man eben sagen, dass viele Dinge außerhalb des Platzes wieder eine Rolle gespielt haben, sei es der Crazy-Buzzer-Deal im Sommer, als Hauptsponsorenwetteranbieter zu haben. Gut, das kennen mittlerweile auch viele andere Vereine und die Debatte geht ja immer weiter. Hat aber eben auch nicht zu dem Weg gepasst, den Hertha haben wollte, hin zu, wie gesagt, dem tragischen Tod von Karl Bernstein. Darüber weiß ich gar nicht, ob wir gleich noch mal darüber sprechen wollen, wenn ich verweise auf jeden Fall auf die ausführliche Folge im Rasenfunk, der ich auch beiwohnen wollte und die, glaube ich, auch viel über dessen Wirken sagt. Es ist die erste Saison gewesen, die die erste vollständige Saison gewesen, die diesen neu formulierten Berliner Weg gegangen ist mit Demut, Bodenständigkeit, Nahbarkeit und der Fokussierung auf junge Spieler, vor allem aus der Akademie, aber eben auch Verantwortlichen, die für diese Aufgabe brennen. Das bedeutet nicht, dass die in Hertha Bettwäsche geschlafen haben müssen als Kind. Die können gerne von außerhalb kommen, aber sie müssen sich eben mit der Aufgabe identifizieren, die Hertha hat. Und das merkt man der gesamten Geschäftsstelle an. Das merkt man Sportdirektor Benny Weber, Geschäftsführer Tom Herrich und weiteren Leuten, dass das der Fall ist. Und gleichzeitig hast du natürlich nach wie vor Dinge wie eben Triple Seven, die an die Vergangenheit erinnern und vor der Zukunft Angst machen. Hertha war dazu gezwungen, nachdem es zum Bruch mit Last Ventures kam, einen neuen Investor an Land zu ziehen. Man hatte ein Veto-Recht, sodass diese Anteile nicht an Saudi-Arabien oder Ähnliches gehen. Mit Triple Seven hatte man damals jemanden an Land gezogen, der gerade frisch in den Fußballmarkt kam, der aber auch schon seine anderthalb Jahre, zwei Jahre darin verbracht hatte, Anteile an FC Sevilla und so weiter gewonnen hatte und ein globales Netzwerk aus Vereinen spinnen wollte, ohne jetzt quasi den MinCity-Weg zu gehen, dass alle dasselbe Logo am Ende haben, sondern dass am Ende so eine Art Habwissen entsteht und die Vereine voneinander profitieren, weil man besser Bescheid über Scouting und so weiter. Gleichzeitig hat irgendwann auch Josh Wander, der damalige Fußballchef von Triple Seven, gesagt, wir wollen den Fußball schonen, dafür nutzen, irgendwann auch Versicherungen und Ähnliches und Schalke zu verkaufen. Also Kapitalismus 2.0 dann. Kommen wir zu den Problemen, die bei Triple Seven aufgetaucht sind. Es ging vor einiger Zeit los, dass vor allem die norwegische Zeitung Josima, die muss man hier wirklich nennen, weil sie federführend waren in der Recherche über die Interna bei Triple Seven, die seit jeher eine sehr fragwürdige, undurchsichtige Historie verfolgt in verschiedenen Finanzsektoren, ob es Flugverkehr oder Gerichtsprozesse oder ähnliches angeht, und die dann in den Fußball geströmt sind. Und auch der Fußball zieht ja meistens nicht die seriösesten Finanzpartner an, das muss man eben auch klar sagen. Und das hat sich hier bewahrheitet. Viel ist auch insofern rausgekommen, als Triple Seven anfangen wollte, in die Premier League zu kommen, über den FC Everton, den sie übernehmen wollten. Und was sich dann ja auch zu einer monatelangen Odyssee entwickelt hat. Und in Kurzform ist der Weg von Triple Seven eigentlich relativ kurz gemacht. Fake it till you make it. Und irgendwann bist du dann too big to fail. Das war die Idee. Man überschwemmt Märkte mit Geld, baut sich Partner auf und so weiter, verschiebt die ganze Zeit Geld, Konten und so weiter, bis es nicht mehr durchsichtbar ist, was da eigentlich passiert. Und irgendwann ist man aber so mächtig, weil man in so vielen Märkten unterwegs ist und so viele Abhängigkeiten aufbaut und so weiter, dass dieses Konstrukt nicht mehr auseinanderfallen kann. Und den Schritt hat Triple Seven offensichtlich nicht hinbekommen. Man hat sich komplett verschluckt am Fußball. Man hat völlig fehl investiert. Das sieht man auch bei Hertha. Also am Ende würde bei Hertha ein... Also, man hat ja erstmal die Anteile von Last Winters übernommen. Da weiß man nicht, wie viele das sind, aber es wird sich im hohen zweistelligen Millionenbereich bewegen, überhaupt Last Winters die Anteile abgekauft zu haben. Und dann hat man sich ja auf eine Aufschockung der Anteile bei Hertha geeinigt, was eine Investition von insgesamt 100 Millionen bedeutet hätte, die zu drei Vierteln, also zu 75 Millionen, in den Branchen schon ausgezahlt ist. Und das hat Triple Seven tatsächlich laut den Hertha-Verantwortlichen pünktlich teilweise sogar überpünktlich getan. 25 Millionen stehen aus. Man hat sich, wie gesagt, völlig verschluckt am Fußball. Und am Ende des Tages steht jetzt die Schlagzeile, dass Triple Seven sich komplett aus dem Fußball zurückziehen will. Man hat eigentlich alle Fußball-Verantwortlichen aus den teilweise Aussichtsräten der Vereine zurückgezogen. Es begann damit, dass man ja Standard-Littich verkaufen wollte. Jetzt heißt es, man will, wie gesagt, seine gesamten Anteile im Fußball verkaufen. Das bedeutet eben auch die Anteile an Hertha BSC. Für Hertha steht natürlich einiges auf dem Spiel. Zum einen das Thema der fehlenden 25, der ausstehenden 25 Millionen. Da heißt es seitens des Vereins, dass man schon länger mit diesem Szenario sich auseinandersetzt und einen Stab dafür etabliert hätte, um Möglichkeiten zu ergründen, wie man ohne diese 25 Millionen über die Runden kommt. Das andere ist natürlich das Thema, was passiert mit diesen Anteilen. Da würde ich mal kurz den Interimspräsidenten Fabi Drescher zitieren, der jetzt auf der Mitgliederversammlung dazu Stellung bezogen hat, weil von den Mitgliedern natürlich aufgrund der Berichterstattung zu Triple Seven Fragen dazu kam. Da würde ich mal kurz zitieren, weil das gibt am Ende einfach sehr viel Auskunft darüber, wie gedacht wird. Wir sind schon intensiv dran, alle Eventualitäten auf den Prüfstand zu stellen. Wenn der Investor veräußern möchte, haben wir ein Vorkaufsrecht und ein Veto-Recht. So könnten die Anteile nicht an, Zitat, verbrecherische Drittstaaten oder Investoren, die uns vielleicht noch unlieber wären, gehen. Man hat dafür ja auch schon einen Stab etabliert im Verein. Wenn es dazu kommt, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt, wieder Anteile heranzukommen, dann ist es doch unsere verdammte Aufgabe, intern zu prüfen, wie Hertha BSC wieder in den Mehrheitsbesitz oder im Idealfall in den 100-prozentigen Besitz der Anteile kommen kann. Wie weit das finanziell realisierbar ist, ich habe gerade über die Probleme bei Hertha geredet, steht wieder auf dem anderen Blatt Papier. Ich finde es aber nur seriös, dass man sich damit auseinandersetzt. Entweder über Kredite oder vielleicht wird auch das Thema Fan-Anleihe eins, dass man sagt, liebe Vereinsmitglieder und Fans, wir haben die Chance, hier wieder Herr im eigenen Haus zu werden. Habt ihr Interesse daran? Vielleicht wird da ja so eine Art Genossenschaft raus. Und Hertha sagt sich am Ende wirklich von diesem großen Investorentum los. Das ist natürlich eine sehr Fußballromantische Sicht. Ob sie realistisch ist, weiß ich stand jetzt nicht. Aber wie du richtig gesagt hast, Eva, das ist das Damoklass-Schwert, das aktuell über diesem Verein schwebt.
Ja, ich würde tatsächlich auch anbetreut der Zeit sagen, dass wir Zurkhauser Kai Bernstein wirklich auf das Tribüne-Gespräch gemeinsam mit Max und Harald Lange verweisen. Also ich kann es als Hörerin wirklich sehr empfehlen. Ich glaube, das war sehr intensiv, aber auch wirklich sehr gut. Und ich habe es schon sehr, sehr vielen Leuten auch weiterempfohlen. Und daher würde ich tatsächlich einfach, weil ich glaube, es würde es auch irgendwie nicht wirklich den Rahmen geben, wenn wir da jetzt einfach zwei Sätze zu verlieren. Von daher würde ich tatsächlich in dem Fall einmal auf das Tribüne-Gespräch verweisen. Ich hoffe, damit sind auch alle fein. Und würde sonst tatsächlich auf Schalke 04 blicken wollen, gemeinsam mit Anna, Platz 10 ist es da am Ende, 43 Punkte. Ja, durchaus, ich glaube, nervensträumende oder nervenzehrende Saison am Ende. Am Ende war der Klassenerhalt am 32. Spieltag mit dem viel zu null Sieg über Osnabrück, klar, am Millantor. Dann endgültig da, eben weil man damals nicht an der Bremer Brücke spielen durfte, aufgrund eines defekten Dachs. Ich kann da sehr mal die Bilder vom, ich glaube, letzten Spieltag gegen Hertha empfehlen. Es hatte wirklich so ein bisschen, hätt ich nicht, Regionalliga-Vibes, als da dann doch das Dach von der Bremer Brücke weg war. Anna, lass uns auf Schalke 04 schauen. Ich weiß, dass du ja eine durchaus anstrengende Saison hinter dir hast und auch sehr, sehr viel gelitten hast. Aber ich muss einfach sagen, ich glaube, das, was Schalke 04 am Ende definitiv gerettet hat, war Platz 6 in der Heimtabelle, damit unter anderem stärker als Holstein-Kiel. Ich glaube, da in den Heimspielen, da wurde das Fundament am Ende für den Klassenerhalt gesetzt. Würdest du mir dazu stimmen?
Ja, ich glaube, dass Schalke zu Hause ein ganz anderes Gesicht gezeigt hat als auswärts. Ich glaube, alle sind diese Auswärtsspiele, zum Beispiel in Kaiserslautern gegen Magdeburg, in Kiel, in Düsseldorf in Erinnerung. Da fällt mir gar kein Wort ein, um das zu beschreiben, weil es einfach schlecht war. Ich kann auch diesen Spielen nichts Positives abgewinnen. Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, warum können sie denn nicht das, was sie zu Hause zeigen, auch auswärts zeigen? Ich glaube, Schalke war das schlechteste Auswärtsteam der 2. Liga. Und im Großen und Ganzen muss man einfach sagen, dass die Saison super enttäuschend war. Weil ich glaube, dieser Verein ist mit anderen Erwartungshaltungen an die Saison gegangen. Und auch von außen werden ja immer viele Erwartungshaltungen herangetragen. Und gleichzeitig war es ja zeitweise so, dass man richtig Angst um die Existenz des Vereins haben musste. Weil ich glaube, jeder weiß um die finanzielle Schieflage von Schalke Bescheid. Also sie sind hoch verschuldet immer noch, obwohl man schon Schulden abbauen konnte. Und ein Abstieg, ein erneuter Abstieg, hätte nicht die 3. Liga bedeutet, sondern eine andere Liga weiter unten. Und die Stadt Gelsenkirchen ist extrem eng mit Schalke verbunden und auch als Stadt nicht besonders gut finanziell aufgestellt. Und das wäre nicht nur für den Verein eine Tragödie gewesen, sondern auch für die Stadt Gelsenkirchen. Und ich glaube, am Ende waren alle schon relativ erleichtert, dass es dann noch nicht so weit gekommen ist. Vor der Saison hätte ich gesagt, dass der Kader tatsächlich eigentlich ganz gut aufgestellt war, aber der Kader hat nicht so performt, wie man es vielleicht erwartet hätte von so einem Verein. Muss aber auch dazu sagen, nach dem erneuten Abstieg, also Schalke war ja ein Jahr in der Bundesliga und ist dann am letzten Spieltag tatsächlich erst abgestiegen, hat sich der Kader da nochmal ganz groß verändert, weil so Spieler wie Tom Kraus, Moritz Jens, Marius Bülter, Salazar den Verein verlassen haben, die man einfach finanziell nicht halten konnte. Und so ein Umbruch steht auch jetzt wieder bevor. Das kann ich schon mal hier so andeuten.
Ja, ich habe da tatsächlich eine Frage, weil du hast gesagt, man ist mit einer gewissen Erwartungshaltung reingestartet, aber ich hatte von Anfang an das Gefühl, dass es eben nicht so wird, als man zuletzt mit Werder Bremen abgestiegen war. Also dass die Voraussetzungen von Anfang an durchaus andere waren. Also ich meine, der Vergleich zu Bielefeld wurde ja nicht nur von Schalkan und Bielefeld angezogen, sondern gefühlt von auch einmal allen Sportredaktionen, weil eben gesagt wurde, okay, da läuft so viel falsch auf und neben dem Platz. Da scheint zum Teil eben auch die Ernsthaftigkeit der Lage nicht komplett richtig eingeschätzt zu werden. Also ob man jetzt von den Spielern spricht, aber auch zu Beginn sicherlich auch des Trainers. Da gab es dann ja mit Karel Gerrads glaube ich schon den richtigen Wechsel am Ende, auch wenn man glaube ich sagen musste, da gab es schon eine Stagnation, aber man hat da am Ende den sicherlich richtigen Weg eingeschlagen. Aber klar, Erwartungshaltung kannst du als Verein nicht immer ganz viel tun von außen. Mich hat schon verwundert, dass man da doch durchaus überrascht ins offene Messer gelaufen ist, möchte ich was sagen. Klar, am Ende steht Platz 10, das sieht erst mal relativ deutlich aus, aber wenn man sich die Liga mal enger anguckt, ist es dann eben doch nicht immer so deutlich gewesen. Hat dich das auch überrascht, dass da vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu optimistisch auf die Saison geblickt wurde.
Ja, also ich glaube, einige Verantwortliche im Verein, ich möchte jetzt keine Namen oder so nennen, auch niemanden ankreiden, sind so in diese Zweitligasaison gegangen. Wir haben schon mal Zweitligasaison gespielt und sind direkt wieder aufgestiegen. Das können wir ja nochmal genauso machen. Aber nein, das geht nicht. Also die Zweitligasaison ist halt anders als die Bundesliga. Ja, wie gesagt, weil halt auch viele Spieler den Verein verlassen haben letzten Sommer, gab es nur noch wenige Spieler, die so auch so dieses, was es braucht, in der zweiten Liga mitbringen. So Simon Therault hat dann nochmal doch überraschenderweise verlängert, obwohl er vielleicht jetzt so spielerisch und körperlich nicht mehr auf dem Top-Niveau war. Mit Mitte 30 muss man das aber vielleicht auch nicht mehr sein. Ich glaube, das war dann eher so eine emotionale Verlängerung im Nachhinein betrachtet. Und dann hat man ja im Winter Mark Wilmots als Sportdirektor verpflichtet und Mark Wilmots ist ja ein ehemaliger Spieler und auch UEFA-Cup-Sieger von 1997. Und ich glaube, im Nachhinein betrachtet war das auch so ein bisschen so ein Nostalgietransfer. Auf Schalke ist es immer gern gesehen, wenn verantwortlich so, ja, dieses hat schon als Kind in Schalke Bettwäsche geschlafen. Aber das bringt einen vielleicht auch nicht immer weiter, wie man sieht. So Mark Wilmots hatte dann auch ein paar sehr unglückliche Auftritte in der Kommunikation. Wir standen zwei Punkte vor einem direkten Abstiegsrang, und es wurde irgendwie gesagt, die Lage ist nicht so dramatisch. Wir müssen nur aufpassen, dass es nicht noch schlimmer wird. Und dann kam das nächste Spiel, wo man, weiß ich nicht, vier Gegentore kassiert hat. Ja, also die Saison war emotional nicht so einfach. Und dann waren wieder so Siege wie zu Hause gegen St. Pauli in der Rückrunde, wo ich immer noch nicht weiß, wie wir da gewonnen haben. Weil St. Pauli war zu dem Zeitpunkt Tabellenführer. Und ich dachte, na ja, das wird schon, das wird nicht so gut ausgehen. Aber ja, Schalke überrascht dann doch immer ab und zu nochmal. Ich denke aber, dass, ich weiß nicht, wie es in der nächsten Saison weitergeht, ob man dann wieder, vielleicht täte man auch mal gut daran, nicht zu sagen, wir wollen aufsteigen, sondern es einfach erst mal laufen zu lassen. Hoffentlich weiterhin mit Karel Gerrads, der jetzt erst mal gesagt hat, er bleibt. Aber wir wissen, ich glaube, ihr wisst alle, Schalke ist ein extrem unruhiges Umfeld. Die Emotionen kochen ganz schnell hoch und dann schlagen die auch ganz schnell in eine sehr gefährliche Richtung. Ich glaube, alle wissen, dass noch als Schalke 2021 abgestiegen ist gegen Bielefeld. Was da passiert ist im Nachhinein dieses Spiels, da war ja auch Corona und keine Fans im Stadion. Ja, also diese Erwartungshaltung, den Verein und das Umfeld, wenn man da arbeitet, ist, glaube ich, jeden Tag eine Herausforderung.
Ich würde einfach ganz gerne Thomas da nochmal reinhauen, reinholen, einfach nur ohne, dass du jetzt bei Schalke drin bist. Aber ich finde halt schon, dass so ein paar Parallelen zwischen Schalke, vielleicht auch die Erwartungshaltung, was dahin teilt, hängt man durchaus mit dem HSV vergleichen können. Also, beides sind Vereine, die in der internationalen Geschichte ja eine große Rolle gespielt haben. Und wo es dann irgendwann wirklich Stück für Stück so ein bisschen den, ja, nichts auf Fall, aber einfach diesen Abstieg mit beobachten konnte, auch wenn es für Schalke zwischendurch nochmal hochging, würdest du da auch Parallelen sehen?
Ein paar vielleicht schon. Auf meine Traditionsklubs habe ich natürlich immer ein großes Auge. Schalke ist tiefer gefallen als der HSV, muss man natürlich sagen. Also der HSV, das war ein langsamer, irgendwie zährender Abstieg. Und dann hat man sich aber in der zweiten Liga sicher nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert oder so, indem man halt immer wieder nicht aufgestiegen ist. Aber Schalke ist natürlich schon sehr tief gefallen und hat natürlich jetzt auch andere finanzielle Probleme als der HSV, der mit dem kritisch zu betrachtenden, beziehungsweise kritisch betrachteten von vielen Fans, Investor Klaus-Michel Kühne, aber natürlich immer so ein Fallnetz, so ein Schutzschirm hat, der immer wieder auch, ja, die notwendigen Finanzmittel zur Verfügung stellt. Die Schalke jetzt zum Beispiel seit Clemens Tönnies weg ist, einfach so nicht mehr hat. Das ist natürlich auch eine Grundsatzfrage, die man da getroffen hat, wo ja, wie man auch hört, immer wieder zumindest noch, ja, wie soll man sagen, Evaluierungen stattfinden. Also, ob man nicht vielleicht doch irgendwie auf eine Art und Weise da eine Zusammenkunft findet. Wie Schalke aus dieser Situation rauskommt, ist tatsächlich relativ schwer. Aber ich finde, in Ben Manga hat man jetzt wirklich einen, der einen guten Blick für das hat, was Schalke braucht. Und zwar irgendwie auch Werte schaffen, Talent entdecken. Das ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen dieser Innovationsgeist, für den sich der HSV jetzt mutmaßlich zumindest nicht entschieden hat. Und deswegen bin ich mal gespannt, wie Schalke das nächste Jahr machen wird.
Ja, also wie gesagt, es wird wieder einige Veränderungen im Kader geben. Natürlich haben jetzt so Spieler wie Simon Terodde seine Karriere beendet, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass er noch weiter gespielt hätte tatsächlich. Dann natürlich die Personalie um Ui Draogu, der sicherlich nicht über den Sommer jetzt hinaus bei Schalke bleiben wird oder zumindest nicht als Stammverein Schalke hat, sondern woanders und dann vielleicht verliehen wird. Keke Top ist auch eine spannende Personalie, der ist auch noch sehr jung, 20 Jahre alt.
Da gräte ich kurz rein, Keke Top. Der ist bei Bremen ausgebildet worden, also eine lange Zeit. Und dort wird er jetzt wohl auch hin zurückkehren. Den behält man im Zweifelsfall nämlich gar nicht.
Ja, richtig. Ich denke mal, dass alle das jetzt auch mitbekommen haben, dass natürlich Marius Müller war auch so eine Konstante jetzt im Tor. Der hat auch viele Siege oder auch Unentschieden festgehalten. Der wird den Verein auch ziemlich sicher verlassen und nach Wolfsburg gehen. Aber Schalke hat sich schon um einen Ersatz bemüht und Ron Turmhoffmann von Eintracht Braunschweig verpflichtet, der auch noch relativ jung ist. Ja, und ansonsten hoffe ich natürlich auch, dass jemand wie Kenan Karaman, den man schon so als Spieler der Saison bezeichnen kann, mit 13 Toren insgesamt dem Verein noch erhalten bleibt und Spieler, die sich auch über die Saison entwickelt haben, wie Ron Schallenberg, wie Paul Seguin, die dann auch gezeigt haben, warum sie verpflichtet wurden für Schalke, auch einfach dem Verein noch erhalten bleiben. Im Winter wurde dann Scholinov geholt, der schon mal für Schalke gespielt, in der ersten Aufstiegssaison sozusagen. Und Sopie, der dann leider verletzungsbedingt relativ selten gespielt hat, Scholinov hat auch nicht so überzeugt. Die sind jetzt auch wieder zu ihren Leifereien zurückgekehrt. Ja, und Eva, ich glaube, über Brian Laspe haben wir schon mal gesprochen. Ich sehe da durchaus noch Potenzial, sagen wir es so. Ich habe mich in der vergangenen Saison das eine oder andere Mal dann doch schon sehr aufgeregt über die vergebenden Chancen, die er so hatte.
Ja, Brian Laspe ist forever in der Hort. Marc, ganz gerne, was du sagen möchtest.
Ich finde es schon krass, es wurde ja glaube ich schon ausgeführt, mit was für einem Selbstverständnis man in dieser Saison gegangen ist, ein klarer Aufstiegsfavorit zu sein. Dabei finde ich, romantisiert man auch sehr, wie man damals aufgestiegen ist, denn das war ja ein absolutes Freak-Momentum, was man da unter Mike Biskins völlig überraschend aufgeboten hat. Das hat ja gar keine Systematik gehabt, auf die man auch im zweiten Anlauf nochmal wieder aufzusteigen hätte, zurückgreifen können. Und was für mich da eben auch so eine Rolle spielt, und ich hab's vorhin ja schon im KSC-Segment gesagt, der KSC hatte den zweitältesten Kader der Liga, nur Schalke ist älter. Und ja, jetzt werden mit Simon Terode und Danny Latza auch ältere Spieler gehen, aber da bleiben ja auch noch so viele alte Spieler. Also Kenan Karaman ist 30, Paul Seguin ist 29, du hast Kaminsky, du hast einen Baumgartel, der dir echt schwer, glaube ich, auf der Gehaltstasche liegt, da hinten ist ein Thomas Kalasch, der 31 ist. Du hast eigentlich, also es wäre deutlich kürzer, die Spieler aufzuzählen, die unter 23 sind. Und das finde ich besonders im Fall Schalke wirklich fatal und bitter, denn Schalke hat nachweislich einer der besten Jugendakademien dieses Landes. Und wie es in den letzten Jahren wirklich fast schon systematisch geschafft wurde, genau diese Talente zu vergraulen, die es bei anderen Vereinen wirklich durchaus bewiesen haben. Und man hat auch gar kein Auge mehr dafür gehabt. Ich glaube, ein aktueller Fall, als wir auch über Paderborn gesprochen haben, zum Beispiel ist Mathes Hansen. Der ist bei Schalke ausgebildet worden, wurde dort nicht für anscheinend tüchtig genug betrachtet, ist zu Paderborn gegangen, ist und ist jetzt mit 20 Jahren dort absolut gereift und hat jetzt schon einen Marktwert von 1,8 Millionen. Transfermarktwerte kann man immer kritisch sehen, ich weiß, aber ein ungefährer Indikator dafür, wie interessant sie für den Markt sind, ist es schon. Und das kann man mit ganz vielen Talenten machen. Mit Uri Draogu wird man sicherlich sein Geld machen, aber Keke Top beispielsweise wird man jetzt direkt wieder verlieren, darüber haben wir gerade geredet. Und ich frage mich wirklich, auf welcher gesunden Basis rein alterstechnisch Schalke das nächste Jahr aufbauen will, denn nach diesem Jahr ist es überhaupt nicht realistisch, dass man in dem Aufstieg mitspielt. Da müsste man extrem viele gute Entscheidungen im Sommer treffen. Wir haben über Marc Wilmots und seine Entscheidung gesprochen. Das kann man auch kritisch sehen, ob das was wird. Das hat er beispielsweise auch bei Brandon Sopie bewiesen, der erst als Soforthilfe verkauft wurde, dann doch plötzlich hat er nie gesagt, dass es eine Soforthilfe gewesen wäre. Da liegt auch viel im Argen. Mir fehlt wirklich die Fantasie. Eigentlich bräuchte es jetzt einen Komplettumbruch im Sommer. Du müsstest sehr viele alte Spieler mit sehr vielen jungen austauschen. Ich frage mich, ob da die Bereitschaft da ist, ob man bereit ist, so weit von dem Traumaufstieg abzutreten, um zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt langfristig. Bei Schalke spielt auch immer das finanzielle eine Rolle. Wie steht man da unter Druck, wieder hoch zu müssen? Das sind für mich alles Faktoren, die die kommende Schalke-Saison, aber vor allen Dingen diesen Transfer-Sommer, extrem spannend machen.
Ja, genau. Ich finde, da wurde was sehr Richtiges gesagt, und zwar, wie sehr der letzte Aufstieg über grundlegende Probleme hinwegetäuscht hat. Und da ist ja tatsächlich, es war ja diese Saison mit Werder Bremen gemeinsam. Und da finde ich den Kontrast halt schon sehr spannend, weil sich Werder im Moment der Krise darauf verständigt hat, okay, wir wollen diese Art von Fußball spielen. Dahin wollen wir unsere Mannschaft entwickeln. Das hat dann mit Markus Anfang alles nicht so super geklappt. Und es braucht einen gefälschten Impfpass, bis man dann beim richtigen Trainer Oli Werner gelandet ist. Aber die grundsätzliche Haltung hat man einfach definiert in diesem Sommer. Und nach und nach darauf aufgebaut, auf diesem Fundament, auf einem fußballideologischen Fundament, kann man fast schon sagen. Bei Schalke wird einfach alles total improvisiert. Also da ist man von einem Malocha-Trainer zum nächsten, aber irgendwie standen die auch nicht für so eine richtige Art des Fußballs, die irgendwie so vom Verein auch vorgegeben wird. Und ich finde, das ist bei so einem Club wie Schalke tatsächlich auch wichtig, dass so die Fußball-DNA auch irgendwie so im ganzen Umfeld und im ganzen Club klar definiert ist. Und ja, vielleicht, ich habe vorhin den Namen Ben Manga gesagt, dem würde es jetzt obliegen, so den Umbruch voranzutreiben, aber ich glaube auch, dass er gerade in der Hinsicht auch jemand sein kann, der das in den Club einbringt, dass man einfach sich klar verständigt. Okay, in diesem ein-, zwei-Jahresplan wollen wir die Mannschaft dorthin entwickeln. Genau, ausgelöst wurde der Aufstieg von Schalke vor zwei Jahren, übrigens nach einer 4 zu 3 Heimniederlage gegen Hansa Oztock, die dann zum Rauswurf von Graumotzes führte und dann erst den Weg freigemacht hat für diesen Aufstieg. Aber Thema Fantasie und ein Aufstieg strukturell angehen, ich meine, ich habe jetzt Yannick Bachmann verpflichtet, der zuvor mit Hansa und mit Sandhausen abgestiegen ist. Ich hätte gerne die Fantasie des Boulevard-Kollegen, der Bachmann als Zweitligamonster in seinem Artikel verkaufte. Da haben wir uns alle angeschaut und gefragt, woher das kommt. Aber wenn das jetzt natürlich die Qualität der Spieler ist, mit denen Schalke nach oben möchte, dann fehlt mir ehrlicherweise die Fantasie.
Richtiger Malocha. Ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt, im Vorgespräch, dass ich dieses Wort gar nicht mehr hören kann, weil ich auch nicht finde, dass man kämpft. Nein, das ist keine Einstellung, mit der man Spiele in der 2. Liga oder auch in der Bundesliga angeht. Da muss einfach mehr kommen von Schalke. Da muss eigentlich mal was Vernünftiges kommen. Malocha ist diese Marschroute, die zieht einfach nicht mehr. Auf Schalke ist man manchmal ganz gut darin, über Sachen hinwegzuschauen, die eigentlich dringend mal behoben werden müssen. Dass der ganze Verein mal auf links gedreht werden müsste, wissen glaube ich auch alle. Das passiert auch gerade zumindest. In Thailand wurde ja auch einigen Profi-Spielern jetzt schon mitgeteilt, dass sie keine Zukunft im Verein haben. Auch wohl nicht so nette Art und Weise, dass sie sich doch bitte einen neuen Arbeitgeber suchen sollen. Aber ja, auf Schalke muss man wegkommen von diesem ständigen, wir müssen mal lochen und die Werte des Ruhepots nach vorne bringen. Ja, es ist wichtig, nicht zu vergessen, wo man herkommt. Aber man muss auch mal an die Zukunft denken und dringend den Kader verjüngen, auf jeden Fall.
Auf Mitabsteiger, Hertha BSC gucken. Beide sind gleichzeitig abgestiegen. Aber wie wurde danach gehandelt? Schalke hat mit alten, vermeintlich verdienten Spielern verlängert. Sie hat andere vermeintliche Soforthilfen geholt und steht jetzt vor dem absoluten Neuaufbau. Bei Hertha war diese Saison, wie gesagt, ich habe es ja schon ausgeführt, da wurde viel liegen gelassen und Ähnliches. Und trotzdem ist da zum Beispiel eben gesagt worden, ok, Berliner Weg, das bedeutet, wir gehen damit Demo dran, wir bündeln unsere Kräfte und wir haben ein Konzept, sowohl wirtschaftlich als auch sportlich. Und sportlich ist es eben, was ich schon erklärt habe, was für Spielertypen man geholt hat, die eine klare Spielidee verfolgen und dass man mit dem 4-3 ein System auch etablieren wollte. Das hat mal mehr, mal weniger unter Pallada geklappt. Deshalb grundsätzlich die Idee, dass auch das System ist, dass alle Jugendmannschaften spielen bei Hertha. Das heißt, dass auch da die Durchlässigkeit aus der Jugend gefördert werden soll, dadurch, dass sie sich gar nicht groß umgewöhnen müssen. Und das hat man ja bei gewissen Spielern gesehen. Pascal Clemens ist ein Name, Ibrahim Masa ist ein Name, Bence Dader wäre einer gewesen, wenn er sich jetzt nicht verletzt und dann für den Wechsel zum VfL Wolfsburg entschieden hätte. Aber da kommen auch andere nach, wie beispielsweise Julius Gottschalken, Tom Hoffmann, Linus Gechter, aber auch Martin Dader, der aktuell sowieso schon Stammspieler ist. Das bedeutet, da hat man dann vielleicht im Vergleich gesehen, ja, die beiden Vereine, und jetzt auch da kann man in einem Jahr vorspülen, und Schalke steht vor Hertha, dann ist das schlecht gealtert. Aber Stand jetzt trennen die beiden einen Tabellenplatz. Aber sie haben in dieser Saison ein völlig anderes Fundament für die kommende Saison gegossen. Und das finde ich an sich erstmal einen spannenden Vergleich.
Ist, glaube ich, definitiv so. Und ja, bei Schalke, also auch da, das waren halt Parallelen, die eben viele Bielefeld-Fans gezogen haben. Also dieses, man guckt von außen drauf und man hat schon das Gefühl, da steht jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Mannschaft auf dem Platz, die einfach intakt ist. Also, dass sie spielerisch individuell Sachen mitbringt, das hat keiner bezweifelt. Aber das war auch am Anfang der Saison, wo man Transfers getätigt hat, wo ich dachte, okay, wird jetzt wirklich nach, das passt zum Kader, oder wird er erstmal geschaut? Ach, mir kummer, 2. Liga-Statistiken sind gut, den holen wir jetzt mal. So, ohne da den einzelnen Spieler zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber ich hatte nicht so das Gefühl, dass da jetzt wirklich was nach System verpflichtet wird. Und das wird eben eben die große Rolle sein. Aber auch da würde, ja auch Thomas zustimmen, da wird ein Bang Manga, Ben Manga, so rum, eine große Rolle spielen. Und da bin ich ja einfach gespannt, was bei Schalke passiert. Weil ich glaube, klar ist auch, die Erwartungshaltung muss da ganz, ganz schnell angenommen werden und angepasst werden. Und wie du schon sagst, Anna, also ja klar, kann man tausendmal über Malocha und so reden. Aber ich glaube, es ist schon wichtig, dass Neuverpflichtungen verstehen, dass sie jetzt beim FC Schalke 04 stehen. Und dass da vielleicht drei Niederlagen in Folge anders bei einem Respekt aufgenommen werden als zum Beispiel bei einem SC Paderborn. Und das sage ich wirklich aus Respekt auch vor Paderborn. Aber ich glaube, da hat man manchmal das Gefühl, das kommt vielleicht noch nicht so ganz an bei allen.
Ja, also ich bin auch schon auch gespannt, was jetzt so passiert. Ich glaube aber auch, dass Ben Manga tendenziell wieder mehr auf die Jugend aus der knappen Schmiede, die ja wirklich mit zu den besten Ausbildungsstätten gehört, setzen wird und da auch wieder eine engere Verzahnung anschreibt. Denn die haben auch sehr gute Trainer an der U23, in der U19. Und ja, ich glaube, es ist halt auch wichtig für Schalke endlich mal so die ganzen Störgeräuche, die rund um den Verein auch so sind, so ein bisschen abzustellen. Es kommt immer wieder irgendwas mit Tönnies auf. Und dann ist auf Social Media wieder dieser Teil der Kabine ist für den Trainer und die sind gegen den Trainer. Und ja, das wird dann natürlich auch auf dem Platz irgendwie so transportiert. Und ja, kann man sich dann auch manchmal nicht erklären, warum die Auswärtsfahrer in den Statistiken bei Schalke so krass waren wieder diese Saison, obwohl sie auswärts gespielt haben. Ich möchte jetzt nicht so ausfällig werden über meinen eigenen Verein, aber ich bin tatsächlich eigentlich ganz froh, dass diese Saison jetzt erst mal geschafft ist, weil das war schon sehr emotional teilweise.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Und vielleicht blicken wir dann mal, ja ich würde fast sagen, auf die positive Überraschung dieser Zweitliga-Saison. Und das ist die SV Elbersberg. Am Ende ist es Platz 11, 43 Punkte, 12 Siege, auch 7 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen. Man hat damit die gleiche Bilanz wie Schalke tatsächlich. Torerverhältnis sieht ein bisschen anders aus. 49 erzielt, 63 kassiert. Lisa, du hast dich der SV eben ein bisschen angenommen. Man kann schon sagen, man war der einzige Aussteiger, der in der Liga bleibt. Richtig großer Erfolg, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, da kann es gar keine zwei Meinungen geben. Ich glaube, wenn man vor der Saison gefragt hätte, zumindest war es in unserem Tippspiel so, wen siehst du als sicheren Absteiger, dann haben ganz viele, glaube ich, aus Reflex-Changen, sagt ja Elbersberg, kleiner Dorfklub, durchmarschgeschafft in die 2. Liga. Aber man kennt erst mal wenig Spieler, glaube ich. Das ist so das, was vorherrscht, wenn man nicht Regionalliga, 3. Liga verfolgt. Man kennt vielleicht auch den Trainer, Horst Steffen, nicht unbedingt. Man weiß vielleicht gar nicht so viel über den Verein. Und ist ja dann schnell dabei zu sagen, okay, es ist ein Dorfklub, der eine Saison mal in die 2. Liga vielleicht reinschnuppern darf, aber der auch ganz schnell wieder weg ist. Es gibt ja den einen oder anderen kleineren Klub, der sich da mal hochkämpft, der aber dann auch nach 1, 2 Jahren wieder weg ist. Und ja, also ich glaube, das hat viele überrascht. Mich hat es ein Stück weit ehrlicherweise auch überrascht. Klar, wenn man sich das ein bisschen genauer anguckt, dann sieht man, dass es Gründe gibt. Und das fängt bei ganz einfachen Sachen an, wo ich auch sage, okay, das klingt so banal, aber du hast irgendwie einen eingeschworenen Haufen, wo zwölf Spieler aus der 3. Liga mit hochgegangen sind. Du hast einen Trainer, der da schon ein paar Jahre in Ruhe arbeiten kann, der guten Offensivfußball spielen lässt, viel Ballbesitz, viele lange Bälle, die aber dann auch ins Ziel finden. Und ja, wenn man, glaube ich, so diesen ersten Klischee-Moment überwindet, dann sieht man schon ganz, ganz viel, was Sinn macht und dass es auf den ersten Blick vielleicht eine Überraschung ist, aber auf den zweiten und dritten schon auch Gründe gibt.
Ja, ich finde es tatsächlich auch sehr interessant. Wir hatten hier zum, glaube ich, Start der Rückrunde hatten wir tatsächlich auch einen Schwerpunkt mit Jonas, der SVI-Fan ist und der uns auch so ein bisschen erklärt hat, wo kommt die SVI eigentlich her, was sind da so ein bisschen die Ziele. Und ich meine, wenn man mal auf das Klischee-Dorfverein guckt, einer dieser Dorfvereine spielt jetzt in der Bundesliga und hat da auch den Klassenerhalt geschafft, nachdem man sehr lange Zeit sehr solide Arbeit einfach in der 2. Liga auch unter dem Radar leisten konnte. Was ich wirklich herausragend bei der SVI fand, waren ja einfach die Zweikampfstärke. Also wenn man da auf Robin Fellhauer schaut, ist das, glaube ich, der drittstärkste Zweikampfspieler der Liga. Und ja, also klar, Thomas hatte eben schon mal das Wort Mentalität und wie verpönt es im deutschen Fußball irgendwie ist. Aber eigentlich ist ja das, wenn du so ein kleiner Club bist, den sowieso erstmal die Hälfte der Liga nicht ernst nimmt, sind wir mal ehrlich. Also die kommen in jede Stadion, in die sie kommen, sind sie erstmal der Underdog. Aber dann kommen sie halt zum HSV, zu Hertha, auch zum 1. FCK und Co. Und werden alle erstmal nur belächelt. Und das ist eben die Stärke, die sie auch daraus ziehen können. Und ich glaube, die können mit der Saison komplett zufrieden sein. Also klar gab es immer positive, aber auch negative Ausreißer. Und klar war es bestimmt am Ende dann auch noch spannend. Ja, die mit den 43 Punkten so.
Aber es war ja schon vor Schluss schon. Also sie mussten nicht so lange zittern wie mein Club. Also wenn einem das jemand vorher erzählt hätte, hätte man glaube ich auch gedacht, okay, wow, entweder Eversberg überragend oder Nürnberg dann doch eher durchwachsen, um es mal so anzuteasen. Aber ja, du hast, finde ich, viele Sachen schon gesagt. Also wenn man sich alleine das Pressing anguckt, wie die in die Zweikämpfe auch reingehen, wie viele Tore aus Kontern entstanden sind. Also da lügt dann auch die Statistik am Ende des Tages nicht. Und das sind alles so Faktoren, wo ich auch sagen würde, das hat dann was mit Mentalität zu tun. Und dann hat das auch einen Faktor, dass das ein eingeschworener Haufen ist, dass die sich gut kennen, dass die vielleicht den Extrameter gehen, dass die auch wissen, bei was für einem Club sie spielen, nämlich bei einem kleinen Club, der, wie du auch sagst, erstmal belächelt wird und wo, glaube ich, jeder im Vorfeld denkt, da ist was zu holen. Oder da muss man ja auf jeden Fall gewinnen. Man ist halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, der HSV oder man ist Hertha oder man ist der Club. Und dann ist es aber halt kein Selbstläufer. Und ich glaube, das hat man in der Saison ganz gut gemerkt. Und man sieht ja jetzt auch an einzelnen Beispielen, selbst wenn man den Club nicht so intensiv verfolgt. Und ich glaube, wir das machen wie wenigen, ehrlicherweise, ohne jetzt den Elbersberg-Fans zu nahe treten zu wollen. Dann ist das ja doch für viele eher so eine Randnotiz, aber eben doch so eine große, dass du dann auch auf so Spieler wie Paul Wanner jetzt natürlich ganz anders guckst, wenn du siehst, was der Junge aus Glien von den Bayern mit 18 da auch für eine starke Saison gespielt hat. Und dann redet man eben auch über Elbersberg. Stark.
Aber ab und vor Entwicklung. Wenn du es nicht gerade gesagt hättest, Lisa, hätte ich das nochmal angesprochen. Ich finde, dass sich Elbersberg in dieser Saison eben auch als Ausbildungsverein echt Namen gemacht hat, wo Bundesligisten ihre Spieler parken können. Paul Wander ist natürlich da das prominenteste Beispiel. Auch Mbaye Fagge hatte seine Momente, der von VfB aus geliehen war. Hugo Wandermeersch waren echt richtig starke Rechtsverteidiger in der Liga und dann hast du noch hinten Frederik Järkel in der Innenverteidigung. All die Spieler waren von Erstliga-Vereinen innen oder ausgeliehen und haben alle definitiv ihre Spuren hinterlassen. Aber ich muss wirklich nochmal sagen, ich finde es wahnsinnig imponierend, die Arbeit von Horst Steffen, dem Trainer, der zum einen auch menschlich einfach wirklich sehr schwer in Ordnung wirkt, wenn man ihn auf PKs und so hört. Ich fand es nicht schlecht, was für einen Auswärtssupport Elvis Bergkin gestellt hat. Da kam teilweise ein Zehntel des Dorfes nach Berlin oder so, das fand ich durchaus bemerkenswert und rein fußballerisch. Ich habe jetzt nur die, also über 90 Minuten, die Spiele gegen Hertha gesehen, teilweise sonst Ausschnitte und gegen Hertha haben sie in anderthalb Spielen Hertha hergespielt und das meine ich so. Im Hinspiel war man in der ersten Halbzeit die fußballerisch deutlich reifere, besser veranlagte Mannschaft und ist dann einfach mit 5 zu 1 aber noch überrollt worden in der zweiten Halbzeit, da kamen viele Freak-Momente dazu. Und im Rückspiel Richtung Saison, Ende, war man auch klar, die bessere Mannschaft. Und das musst du erstmal schaffen und wenn wir beim Thema Mentalität sind, ich glaube, was da einfach mental am wichtigsten ist, ist ein unglaublicher Mut. Also vor kurzem war man noch Regionaligist und jetzt den Mut aufzubringen, diese Art von Fußball gegen Schalke, Hannover, Hertha, den HSV usw. durchzuziehen, das wurde am Ende belohnt, dass es manchen Spielen vielleicht doch den pragmatischeren Ansatz gegeben hätte, der vielleicht ein paar Gegentore erspart hätte und so vielleicht einen Unentschieden bekommen wäre möglich. Aber dass man das so durchgezogen hat, finde ich echt imponierend. Wenn die so unbeirrt weitermachen, sehe ich nicht, warum die nicht einen Weg wie Paderborn oder Ähnliches gehen sollten und sich plötzlich so eine Nische in dieser Liga erspielen, aus der sie erst mal nicht rauszubekommen sind. Ich bin jetzt aber auch eben gespannt, wie sie die Abgänge von so Leihspielern erst mal wieder kompensieren.
Was man da bestimmt schon mal einatmen kann, ist, dass ja wohl Conny Favre vom Aussteiger Regensburg wohl zur SWE wechseln soll und das tatsächlich einer der absoluten Topspieler, absoluten Leistungsträger bei Regensburg. Und ich meine, muss ja sagen, klar ist Regensburg Aussteigerin, es war lange noch nicht klar, ob sie, klar, Relegation ist da immer, eben eine absolute 50-50-Chance, ob du es dann am Ende machst. Aber das finde ich schon ein Transfer, dass also gerade das dann wahrscheinlich eine klare Spielidee, jetzt mal blöd gesagt. Klar ist, wenn man jetzt um die Plätze drum herum guckt, eine Nürnberg, ein Schalke, vielleicht der größere Name, aber Horst Steffen hat halt eine klare Spielidee und ich sehe das schon, dass immer mehr Spieler auch sagen, naja, ich entwickle mich am Ende des Tages mehr weiter unter einem Trainer, der eine klare Spielidee hat, der ein klares Konzept hat, als dass ich mich weiter, also niemand interessiert am Ende, ob ich ein dreiviertel Jahr für Schalke gekickt habe und nichts gerissen habe. Aber wenn ich zwei Jahre bei der SVE Stammspieler war und geholfen habe, dass die in der 2. Liga bleiben, dann kriege ich vielleicht doch eher nochmal bei einem höheren Zweitligisten oder sogar einem Bundesligisten den Job. Und das finde ich auch schon eine durchaus interessante Entwicklung und das hat nicht zu gering. Ihr habt schon angesprochen, mit Horst Steffen zu tun. Oli, du wolltest gerne was sagen.
Also ich habe jetzt kein Elbersberg-Spiel gesehen in dieser Saison, aber erinnere mich daran, der hat vor, es müsste vor zehn Jahren gewesen sein mit den Stuttgarter Kickers, hat er das auch schon mal gemacht und das war eine Mannschaft, die zu der Zeit in der dritten Liga auch, fand ich, den taktisch klarsten Fußball gespielt hat oder auf ein Niveau agiert hat, was sonst in der dritten Liga jetzt nicht zu sehen war. Und dann haben sie den Aufstieg knapp verpasst und dann in der Saison drauf ist es so ein bisschen zusammengebrochen und die Mannschaft dann auseinandergefallen. Aber da sieht man, glaube ich, auch, dass sich Horst Steffen aber so ein bisschen treu geblieben ist und vielleicht dann auch aus dieser Zeit in Stuttgart oder seinen Station dazwischen noch gelernt hat und dass eben seine Linie, sein Weg irgendwie weitergegangen ist, sich weiterentwickelt hat und deswegen jetzt auch eine Mannschaft geformt hat, wo er das dann auch nochmal zeigen konnte, was eben in der dritten Liga auch vor zehn Jahren schon mal zu sehen war.
Ja, ich finde, ihr habt ganz, ganz viele Sachen schon irgendwie gut zusammengefasst, ehrlicherweise. Und was für mich, ehrlicherweise, wenn man über Elbersberg auch spricht oder auch, was du gerade gesagt hast, Eva, wenn man sich verleihen lässt, vielleicht von einem größeren Club überlegt, geht man dann zu Nürnberg oder geht man zu Schalke oder geht man vielleicht zu Elbersberg, dann war die letzte Saison definitiv auch eine Bewerbung von Elbersberg, um als Spieler zu sagen, ich entscheide mich vielleicht ganz bewusst auch für den kleineren Club, weil ganz andere Erwartungen irgendwie herrschen, weil man auch gesehen hat, da kann man auch Fußball spielen, da kann man dann auch mit 18, 19, 20 Jahren so eine Säule werden und ist vielleicht auch nochmal ganz anders gesettelt für die Zukunft. Und wie du sagst, ob man dann ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr Schalke in seinem Lebenslauf stehen hat oder Elbersberg, wo man dann aber deutlich mehr vielleicht Zeit auf den Platz bekommen hat, eine deutlich andere Entwicklung auch ins Persönliche irgendwie nehmen konnte, ohne diesen Druck drum herum. Warum auch nicht? Also ich glaube, da war jetzt gerade die letzte Saison und wenn man eben auf Spieler wie Paul Wanner guckt, eine Bewerbung, um sich zu überlegen, zur SV E zu wechseln.
Ja, ich würde da einmal ergänzend noch reinhaken, dass da glaube ich die nächste Saison sehr spannend wird, weil wir haben mit Preußen Münster und SSV Ulm zwei weitere Mannschaften, die außer Regionalliga in die 2. Liga durchmarschiert sind. Sowieso auch sehr interessant. Ich war vereinsgebunden, sehr viel mit der 3. Liga involviert und die es eben da vor Dynamo Dresden unter anderem erneut geschafft haben, sich da durchzusetzen, aber auch mit Theser Brücken und Co. Und ich glaube, das wird schon interessant, weil das meinte ich eben mit keine zwei klassischen Aufsteiger, also nicht eben die Big Names aus der 3. Liga, sondern zwei, die halt wirklich von Anfang an wussten, okay, wir können das hier schaffen, weil die SVE hat es vor uns geschafft und wird sicherlich ein absolutes Vorbild sein für die beiden Clubs. Also da wird, ich würde Regensbutter ein bisschen rausnehmen, einfach weil sie ja doch durchaus schon gerade erst als Zweitligist abgestiegen waren und jetzt wieder hoch sind. Also es wird durchaus auch da eine interessante Konstellation, auch wenn vielleicht nicht jeder auf SVE gegen, weiß ich nicht, SSV Ulm oder ja Regensburg auf einen Samstag 2030 wartet. Aber denk mal, ehrlich gesagt, da auch nochmal Bewerbung, warum die zweite Liga ja auch interessant ist, weil du eben diese Durchlässigkeit hast mit den Vereinen von oben und eben auch immer wieder von neuen Vereinen von unten. Und das eben auch ein Unterschied ist. Und ich glaube, das macht die Liga von Jahr zu Jahr auch einfach so interessant.
Absolute Zustimmung.
Ja, gut. Sollte noch jemand ein Wort zur SVE zu verlieren sein, dann jetzt oder für immer schreigen oder so ähnlich. Sonst, Lisa, gehen wir mal weiter. Dein Dreierpack vor uns. Wir hätten das Ganze natürlich auch verbetisch machen können, aber dann wären auch die ganzen ersten FCs am Anfang gewesen. Von daher, am Ende kommt es gleich hinaus. Wir schauen auf den ersten FCN. Zwölfter Platz, 40 Punkte sind es, die magischen 40 Punkte. 11 Siege, 7 Unentschieden, 16 Niederlagen. Schon eine deutliche Nummer, wenn man da auf die geschossenen Tore guckt und das, was sie hätten performen können, das bewegt sich irgendwie auf einen Grund. Aber am Ende steht eben Platz 16 in der Rückrunde. Und am Ende eben auch die Trennung von Dieter Hecking, Joti Schatzi-Aleksu ist der neue Sportvorstand. Das Wort Corona als richtig verwendende war auch zuletzt Thema schon in der Ligatur mit Fadi. Aber Lisa, du als FCN-Expertin, wie war die Saison mit dem Club?
Also ich kann ja eigentlich sagen, seitdem ich das erste Mal hier im Podcast war, das war so Ende Oktober, Anfang November und wirklich optimistisch war, ab da ging es bergab. Das ist wirklich kein Zufall. Ich habe mir das nochmal angeguckt, auch zeitlich, da war die Länderspielpause und dann kam der Knick. Es ist ein Zufall, es kann nicht da mit zu tun haben, dass ich so optimistisch war, wie ich es eigentlich gefühlt immer erstmal bin. Aber letzte Saison dachte ich wirklich, so nach den ersten Wochen könnte ein gutes Jahr, eine gute Saison irgendwie werden. Ich glaube, über Can-Usun ist schon ganz, ganz viel gesprochen worden. Selbst wenn man sich nicht so sehr mit der 2. Liga beschäftigt, hat man den Namen schon gehört. Hat mir total viel Mut gemacht, Spaß gemacht. Viele andere junge Spieler, die wir bestimmt an der einen oder anderen Stelle gleich noch erwähnen, auch. Und dann kann man wirklich so richtig einen Knick feststellen. Die Winterpause war so ein bisschen der Killer. Die Hinrunde lief ja wirklich gut. Ich habe auch nochmal geguckt, 24 Punkte. Da dachte man, okay, solide dabei. Es gab das ein oder andere Spiel mit hohen Platschen. Klar, das war dann zum Beispiel gegen St. Pauli, wo man auch wusste, die spielen gut. Das ist ein Aufstiegskandidat. Als Aufstiegskandidat hat man als realistischer Clubfan den Club jetzt auch nicht gesehen, auch wenn das ja immer mal wieder herbeigeredet wurde, wenn es mal ein, zwei Siege gab. Aber ganz generell sind es sehr viele verschiedene Baustellen, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich glaube, wenn man sich den Kader der vergangenen Saison anguckt und wenn man dann im Sommer, wenn es wieder neu losgeht, auf den Kader guckt, wird man feststellen, die Hälfte der Spieler ist weg oder ist eben ausgetauscht, neu, aus positiven Gründen. Weil man eben einen Gian Uson oder auch einen Nene Brown leider realistisch gesehen halt nicht halten konnte. Da aber irgendwie bei mir dann ehrlicherweise das Positive auch herrscht, dass man solche Spieler irgendwie ausgebildet hat, dass man solche aus dem Nachwuchsbereich hochziehen konnte und dann einfach Bundesligaspieler hat, die für gutes Geld verkauft werden. Das ist ja leider auch immer ein Faktor, den man als FC Nürnberg mitbedenken muss. Es geht auch immer noch ums Geld. Die letzten Jahre da sich schon ein bisschen besser aufgestellt. Es gibt immer noch den einen oder anderen Euro, den man zu wenig hat. Deshalb, klar, aus der sportlichen Sicht, aber auch aus der finanziellen Sicht, ist klar, dass man solche Spieler nicht halten kann. Es gibt aber auch Spieler, die echt ein Stück weit enttäuscht haben, wo ich auch sage, okay, verstehe ich, wenn man vielleicht nicht zusammen weitermacht. Ganz ehrlich, als Club-Fan weiß man nicht, wo man anfangen soll vor lauter Baustellen. Man hat die vielen Abgänge von den guten Spielern, wie einen Can Usun, der die 16 Tore gemacht hat, der gefühlt unsere Garantie war, dass wir nicht abgestiegen sind. Ich glaube, ohne Can Usuns Tore und ohne diese Punkte, ohne die guten Momente, die der Junge immer wieder gebracht hat, wäre es ganz, ganz düster geworden. Das macht natürlich ein Stück weit Angst. Auf der anderen Seite hast du gerade auch angesprochen, Dieter Hecken weg, neuer Sportvorstand da, Gerüchte um einen Trainer. Das hatten wir auch gerade schon gehört. Christian Fiel vielleicht zu Hertha. Das ist auch so eine Sache, die kriegt jetzt nicht dazu bei, als Fan, aber ich glaube, im Club auch nicht, dass man da jetzt entspannt in den Sommer geht. Einfach weil das eine ganz komische Situation ist, wenn man so von außen draufguckt und das verfolgt, was aus medialer Berichterstattung rund um der Hauptstadt-Bubble entsteht, was man dann so vom Club hört, nämlich nichts und alles ist gut. Ein bisschen schwierig einzuordnen, hinterlässt aber auch kein allzu gutes Gefühl. Einfach rein sportlich auf den Kader geguckt. Zu wenig Tore gemacht, zu viele Tore bekommen. Teilweise die Basics, die da gefehlt haben. Viel Arbeit, glaube ich, die da jetzt ansteht. Ich war tatsächlich sehr froh, dass die Saison jetzt einfach vorbei war. Auch wenn ich noch nicht so richtig weiß, ob sich ein bisschen Vorfreude einstellt, wenn es dann wieder losgeht, weil ich das Gefühl habe, wir sind gut aufgestellt. Im Moment finde ich es ganz, ganz schwer, an vielen Stellen zu beurteilen, wo die Reise hingeht. Das fängt auch beim neuen Vorstandssport an, bei Joti Schatzi Alexiou, lange Zeit im DFB gewesen, da gute Arbeit gemacht. Im Verein kann man jetzt ehrlicherweise nicht so richtig viel über ihn sagen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er da Gutes mitbringt, was Netzwerk angeht, was Kontakt zu Jugendspielern, Nachwuchsarbeit etc. angeht, was in Nürnberg auch immer eine große Säule ist. Aber es sind ganz, ganz viele Faktoren, wo ich sage, okay, schauen wir mal und versuchen, optimistisch zu sein. Aber als Clubfan kennt man das zum Glück auch, dass es jetzt auch nicht schlimmer ist als die letzten Jahre.
Ich muss einfach sagen, wenn wir einmal kurz unterstreichen, warum du vielleicht froh bist, dass die Saison vorbei ist, in den letzten fünf Spielen haben... Eine, ich schwöre. In den letzten fünf Spielen haben nur Wiesbaden und Hansa Rostock weniger Punkte geholt. Also der FCN 3, Wien 1, Rostock 0. Das war zum Ende, sage ich jetzt mal vorsichtig, könnte man doch durchaus froh sein, dass es vielleicht den einen oder anderen Verein gab, der sich noch ein bisschen dusseliger angestellt hat. Und wenn wir einfach noch mal auf die Personalien, die da hergucken, ich weiß, es war eben auch schon Thema der letzten Ligatur mit Fadi. Aber ich will trotzdem noch mal draufgucken, weil für mich war Dieter Hecking zu lang im Amt. Für mich hätte es den Cut geben müssen, als er letzte Saison in der Personalunion dann auch noch Trainer war. Danach hätte man für, also ich verstehe, dass sowieso ein Umbruch anstand und es vielleicht auch das Geld gefehlt hat. Weshalb eventuell eben auch damals die Wahl auf Christian Vell gefallen ist, der definitiv eine Idee hatte. Das möchte ich gar nicht kritisieren. Klar, dass man sich solche Umbrüche auch immer überlegen muss. Aber für mich war es eine Saison zu viel. Dieter Hecking, wird sie mir dazu stimmen?
Ja, also ich glaube, wenn man noch ein Stück zurückgeht, ist es gefühlt eine Reihe von Fehlentscheidungen, die da so aneinander gereiht wurden. Wenn ich überlege, ich vermisse tatsächlich Robert Klaus immer noch ein bisschen. Ja, der hatte am Ende auch keine guten Statistiken mehr. Es gab Gründe, warum man es getrennt hat. Aber das war gefühlt der letzte Trainer, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, der hat eine gute Idee, der passt zum Verein, der hat vieles verstanden, der macht vieles richtig. Dieses kurze Kapitel, Markus Weinziel, da fing leider, hatte man schon fast verdrängt, ich war kräg. Da fing gefühlt für mich so ein bisschen die Situation mit Wiederhacking an, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, okay, das macht jetzt wenig Sinn und das passt gar nicht mehr eigentlich zusammen, was da gerade passiert. Dass man sich dann auch von Weinziel wieder getrennt hat, dass dann quasi der Feuerwehrmann Hacking selber den Feuerwehrmann gemacht hat, konnte man auf der einen Seite, glaube ich, zu dem Zeitpunkt verstehen. Wie du sagst, noch einen Trainer zu installieren für ein paar Spieltage, was macht das für einen Sinn? Ich fand da dann ein Stück weit auch gut, dass er irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, er will da selber jetzt den Karren aus dem Dreck ziehen. Aber was seitdem passiert ist, das hat den Feiern halt nicht vorangebracht. Ich glaube, die Situation mit Christian Fjell, dass man ihn dann da installiert hat als Co-Trainer, der ja zuerst war unter Hacking dann in den letzten Spielen, jetzt zum Chef-Trainer, das hat einen gewissen Sinn. Das hat auch viel Positives netzig gebracht. Das sehe ich jetzt nicht ganz so kritisch, auch wenn man schon vieles kritisch sehen kann. Gerade du hast die Statistiken angesprochen, die die letzten Spiele irgendwie sieben Pleiten aus, ich glaube neun Spielen, dann am Ende und keine Punkte mehr gemacht. Und man hatte Glück, dass sie im Tabellenkeller noch gegeneinander gespielt haben, sonst hätte es nochmal ganz, ganz böse aussehen können. Aber ja, also Dieter Hacking, wie du sagst, war es, glaube ich, schon ganz gut formuliert, hätte man wahrscheinlich einfach früher einen klaren Zart machen müssen, der jetzt gekommen ist. Wie gesagt, jetzt ist so ein bisschen die Frage, was passiert vielleicht noch an Umbrüchen, sei es auf der Trainerposition, im Kader, wie gesagt, passiert sehr, sehr viel aus guten Gründen, aus nicht so guten Gründen. Und das sind jetzt einfach Weichen, wo man als Fan natürlich hinguckt, die da gestellt werden und hofft, dass mit dem Geld, das man einnimmt, durch Jan Uzon verkauft, Nene Brown verkauft, das sind 12, 13 Millionen, für einen Zweitligaklub und gerade auch für den Club, ist das, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel Bedeutung man dem zumessen kann. Also das ist wirklich ein Segen, dass man da jetzt finanziell so ein Plus machen wird. Aber klar, die zweite Frage ist, was macht man draus? Und da, finde ich, wird es jetzt sehr, sehr spannend zu sehen, was die Verantwortlichen, was ein Trainer, der vielleicht hoffentlich nur Christian Vielle heißt, da auch draus machen. Und das sind jetzt so ganz viele unwegbare Faktoren, ehrlicherweise, wo man als Fan ein bisschen unruhig ist. Aber wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite kennt man das irgendwie auch, wenn man schon Club-Fan ist sein Leben lang, dass einen auch nichts mehr so richtig erschüttert.
Ja, da muss ich tatsächlich aber wirklich noch mal die Entscheidung mit Schatzi Aleksou loben. Ich finde das eine sehr interessante Wahl. Klar, es ist ein gewisses Risiko, weil man ihn zwar aus 20 Jahren DFB kennt. Er hat zuletzt viel die Koordination Nationalmannschaften gemacht. Ich habe ihn gefühlt öfter als meine Eltern letztes Jahr im Sommer gesehen, als er bei jedem Spiel der Nationalmannschaft der Frauen in... in der Halbzeitanalyse irgendwie da Rede und Antwort stellen musste. Aber ich finde einfach, wenn man eben gerade auf die Nachwuchsarbeit guckt, auch da war er eben für Scouting und eben auch nachwuchszuständig. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, Respekt. Also wie gesagt, hat ein gewisses Risiko, aber finde ich in diesem Trainerkarussell, was es ja gibt, gibt es genauso einen Sportvorstand, Sportdirektor und Co. Karussell. Und da finde ich das tatsächlich eine sehr frische Wahl. Marc würde gerne noch was ergänzen dazu, eventuell.
Eher eine Frage an Lisa und zwar, wie die Arbeit von Sportdirektor Olaf Rebbe wahrgenommen wird. Denn Dieter Hecking ist ja nicht der einzige Sportliche Verantwortliche in den letzten Jahren gewesen. Olaf Rebbe ist jetzt auch schon wieder seit 2021 da. Ich persönlich habe das Gefühl, nicht das Gefühl, dass der Kader vom 1. FC Nürnberg seitdem besser geworden ist. Natürlich kann auch er nicht verhindern, dass jedes Zweitliga-Jahr auch ansetzt, dass der Etat sicherlich geringer wird und man auf Transfer-Einnahmen angewiesen ist. Trotzdem blicke ich auf beispielsweise die Transfers der aktuellen oder der letzten Saison, wenn man so will, mit einem Florian Flick, einem Hukunuki, Hangbo, Horn, Marquez, Gyllen, Hayashi, Sebastian Andersson. Auch da stechen eigentlich immer wieder nur die Spieler durch, die aus der eigenen Jugend hochgezogen werden, mit Jan Usun und Co. Da würde mich mal interessieren, wie du seine Arbeit betrachtest und was es vielleicht auch in der kommenden Saison für Transfers braucht. Ich blicke da vor allen Dingen auf die Mittelstimmerposition.
Ja, also Mittelstimmerposition auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, Offensive ist ein mindestens genauso großes Thema wie Defensive. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die Zahl von 64 Gegentoren schon gedroppt haben. Also man sieht, dass das ein sehr, sehr großes Problem, eine sehr, sehr große Baustelle ist, aber genauso wenig Tore haben wir dann vorne im Endeffekt gemacht. Also ich finde, das sind zwei parallele Baustellen, wenn man es so nennen will. Ja, zu Olaf Rebbe, ich glaube, was man auf jeden Fall festhalten kann, das ist jemand, der sehr, sehr gut wirtschaftet. Und das ist leider, wenn du der erste FC Nürnberg bist, ja doch ein Stück weit der überwiegende Faktor. Also du musst dann auf der einen Seite so Spieler wie Uson jetzt verkaufen. Klar, da führt kein Weg dran vorbei. Ich glaube, da gibt es auch keine zwei Meinungen. So schade, dass es irgendwie sportlich ist. Und so gerne man als Club-Fans sich denkt, okay, bleib doch bitte noch ein Jahr, du bist doch erst 18. Und Eintracht Frankfurt und die Euro League und die Champions League. Und das läuft alles nicht weg, aber das ist einfach nicht realistisch. Den Schritt muss man dann machen. Ich glaube auch bei Nene Brown ist es eine ähnliche Geschichte. Ich bin gespannt, wie lange wir einen finden. Ich bin jähisch, U17-Weltmeister halten können, der sich da jetzt auch das letzte halbe Jahr krass in Fokus gespielt hat. Und das sind natürlich Zwänge, sage ich mal, mit denen dann auch ein Olaf Rebbe konfrontiert wird. Man kann aber, glaube ich, schon auch da festhalten, dass er nicht die Person ist, die jetzt sportlich die großen Entscheidungen trifft, was z.B. Scouting angeht, was Neuverpflichtungen angeht. Ich glaube, da ist schon ganz klar zu sehen gewesen, dass das der Job hauptsächlich von einem Dieter Hecking war, der da einfach ein ganz anderes Auge mitbringt, während Rebbe der Wirtschafter, der Verhandler, der mit guten Drähten auf dieser Ebene ist, der natürlich dann, wenn du beim 1. FC Nürnberg bist, bestimmte Zwänge auch zu erfüllen hat, der das in meinen Augen gut macht, der sich da auch in vielen Situationen gut positioniert. Ich finde, der ganze Verein, jetzt rein vom Sportlichen, mal weg positioniert sich in vielen Situationen im Moment gut. Aber das Sportliche und das Fußballerische und die Spieler, die auf dem Platz stehen, die sind halt leider auch nicht unwichtig. Du hast es gerade, Marc, gesagt, die ganze Liste an Spielern, die du da aufgezählt hast. Ja, ich glaube, von vielen hat man sich mehr erhofft, gerade wenn man auf die Defensive guckt. Ich finde, wenn man sieht, wer da zuletzt gespielt hat, wurde ja auch viel ausprobiert von Christian Fiel. Es hat sich dann so ein bisschen eine Stammformation gefunden. Aber da war dann ein Teil eben ein O17-Weltmeister mit 17, 18, Finn Yeltsch, der einen Ivan Marquez, der so ein bisschen als Abwehrboss geholt wurde, 30-jähriger Spanier aus Holland gekommen. Das ist natürlich dann auf der einen Seite schön, wenn du dir die Arbeit des LZ anguckst. Aber wenn du eigentlich einen gestandenen Abwehrboss dir da einkaufst, der jetzt wahrscheinlich nach einem Jahr auch schon wieder geht, dann zeigt das natürlich auch so ein Stück weit ein Missverhältnis, Missmanagement auf der Ebene irgendwie auf. Das ist genau so ein bisschen das, wo ich dann auch immer sage, auf der einen Seite freue ich mich total, dass man da so gute, junge Spieler hochzieht und dass das funktioniert und dass man da auch ein Stück weit was aufbaut. Und da glaube ich, ist ein Christian Fjell dann genau der Richtige an der Position, kennt viele Spieler, kennt die Arbeit aus dem NLZ, setzt da auch ganz bewusst drauf. Aber dann musst du halt die Spieler, die du noch von außen verpflichtest, in einer anderen Qualität verpflichten oder musst ein bisschen besseres Händchen haben, als das jetzt zuletzt war. Weil, wie gesagt, von den von dir genannten, da wird die Hälfte jetzt wieder weg sein. Und das nach einem Jahr. Und das ist halt nicht zielführend auf Dauer.
Ja, definitiv, definitiv, definitiv. Ich lasse es hier einfach mit dem Sprechen. Ich glaube auch einfach, ja, sehr spannende Punkte. Und ja, ich glaube, für Nürnberg wird es definitiv Zeit, jetzt aber auch trotz Umbruch mal ein bisschen nach oben zu schauen. Weil ich glaube, die letzten Saisons waren alle dann doch unter dem, was man sich als Club-Fan im Endeffekt bestimmt auch vorstellt. Also klar, wir wollen alle immer, dass es unser Verein ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, genau, ich glaube, wenn man den Club-Fan fragt, natürlich wollen wir gerne wieder in die erste Liga. Und man sieht sich nicht als zweitiger Club. Aber die Realität ist natürlich auch, es ist nicht allzu lange her. Ich weiß nicht, wer sich an die 96. Minute Relegation gegen Ingolstadt noch erinnert. Also es geht halt dann sehr schnell in alle Richtungen. Deshalb ist so dieses Niemandsland, sage ich mal, jemand da jetzt rumdimpelt die letzten Jahre, nicht das, was man sich wünscht. Am Ende war die Realität gerade nach den letzten acht, neun Spieltagen bei mir auch so, dass ich einfach heilfroh war, dass ich am letzten Bundesligaspieltag entspannt gucken konnte, was sich da tut in Sachen Abstieg und Relegation und dass man halt damit nichts zu tun hatte. Das ist dann irgendwie so ein bisschen Anspruch, wobei man ein großer Traditionsclub ist und wenn man so viele deutsche Meistertitel hatte, Bukalsieger. Das ist glaube ich das, was uns irgendwie mit vielen Clubs, über die wir heute schon gesprochen haben, irgendwie vereint. Aber die Realität und wo man sich erstmal hinarbeiten muss, ist halt einfach eine andere. Und ja, auf der einen Seite gibt es vieles, was eine Hoffnung machen kann. Gerade wenn man aufs NLZ guckt oder wenn man da auf die jungen Spieler guckt. Aber es gibt auch die Realität, dass sie dann halt auch schneller wieder weg sind, als man da nachhaltig was aufbauen kann. Und das ist so ein bisschen dieses Spannungsfeld, glaube ich, das viele Clubs haben und es jetzt spannend wird zu sehen, was der neue Sportvorstand, der neue Trainer, der alte Trainer schon mal da draus machen.
Ja, definitiv. Lasst uns weiter springen zum ersten FC Kaiserslautern auf Platz 13. Und ich würde schon mal ankündigen, ich glaube Kaiserslautern war eins der Saisonkinder. Diese Saison, es wurde sehr viel im Rasenfunk drüber gesprochen. Deshalb brauchen wir, glaube ich, die komplette Trainer-Historie mit Schuster, Gramozis, Funkel nicht noch mal komplett zu bewerten und hinterher DFB-Pokalfinale und alles Mögliche. Aber wir wollen natürlich trotzdem so ein bisschen auf den Endspurt gucken, Lisa. Am Ende sind es 39 Punkte. Man musste nicht überlegen, ob es eine Wiederauflage des Pokalsiegs und Abstiegs geben könnte. Man musste hinterher nicht die Relegation umlegen, weil man DFB-Pokalfinale spielt, weil man es sich vorher schon sichern konnte. Ich finde es eine sehr weirde Saison. Wenn man von Abhängigkeiten von Spielern spricht, muss man bei Kaiserslautern sehr schnell den Namen Ragnar Ache nennen, der definitiv einer der Zielspieler ist, aber auch ein Marlon Ritter, der schon eine Vereinslegende ist, kann man sagen. Auch mit John Zimmer. Da gibt es durchaus Spieler, die schon länger da sind. Ich glaube, was einem hinterher auch gerettet hat, waren die Standards. Da war man das beste Team der Liga, 22 Tore von 59, also die Offensive. Die war gar nicht mal das Problem. Aber Lisa, woran lag es denn, dass der FCK am Ende doch relativ lange um den Liga verbleibt und auch zittern musste?
Ja, du sagtest, also viele Tore gemacht, aber das Schlimme ist ja dann auch viele Gegentore bekommen. Und wenn man sich die Statistik, und ich bin Wirklichkeit-Statistik-Nerd, ich muss wirklich, ich merke mir Sachen ganz, ganz schlecht. Ich muss mir alles aufschreiben. Aber wie ich mich jetzt zum Wissen auf diese Folge vorbereitet habe heute und auch auf Lautern, fiel mir ein, ich hatte vor Wochen mal ein Instagram-Posting gesehen, wie viele Punkte Lautern in der zweiten Halbzeit verspielt hat. Und das ist halt, finde ich, wir haben ja schon so oft über Mentalität geredet, aber das ist für mich der Inbegriff von, wie kann man so oft führen und wie oft kann man in der zweiten Halbzeit einbrechen und die haben halt wirklich, und wenn man sich das auf der Zunge zergehen lässt, über 30 Punkte in der zweiten Halbzeit verspielt. Und das ist halt, wenn du darüber sprichst, dass die 39 Punkte gemacht haben am Ende des Jahres. Die haben 30 Punkte verspielt. Jetzt lass die nur die 15 oder 20, die vielleicht realistisch, weil man verliert auch mal ein Spiel noch, lass die nur die paar Punkte mehr haben. Dann bist du in einer ganz anderen Sphäre der 2. Liga. Und das ist halt schon wirklich, wirklich krass gewesen. Also ich glaube, Trainergeschichte hast du angesprochen, dass am Ende dann ein Friedhelm Funkel genau der Richtige war, der da zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort wieder als Retter in Erscheinung getreten ist, der da eine gewisse Ruhe irgendwie reingebracht hat. Auch so eine gewisse, wir machen das jetzt und wird schon. Und Unaufgeregtheit, die man ihnen dann auch einfach abnimmt als Legende dieses Clubs. Aber ja, also wenn man sich da alleine die Zahl anguckt, was an Punkten drin gewesen wäre, hätte man die zweite Halbzeit nicht gespielt oder einfach nur ein bisschen besser gespielt, dann wird da schon, finde ich, sehr, sehr deutlich, woran es am Ende so ein bisschen gehapert hat. Wobei, ich glaube, ganz negativ kann man es irgendwie gar nicht jetzt, zumindest ist das auch das, was ich von ganz vielen Lauternfans irgendwie höre, ganz negativ sieht man es ja dann irgendwie doch aufs Jahr gemacht. Nicht, weil die Pokalsaison halt alles wieder irgendwie ein bisschen übertüncht hat, was vielleicht nicht so gut lief, weil am Ende warst du in Berlin, ja, hast den Pott nicht geholt, hast aber auch nicht erwartet gegen Leverkusen, aber hattest irgendwie ein spannendes Spiel, hattest eine geile Atmosphäre, hattest ein mega Choreo und selbst davon zehrt man ja irgendwie als Zweitliga-Club so ein bisschen, dass man dieses Highlight des Pokalfinales hatte, selbst wenn es am Ende nichts mit Titeln geworden ist.
Dann lass doch aber einmal schauen. Der neue Trainer für die kommende Saison steht fest und der Name fiel ja heute schon mal im Laufe des Abends. Markus Anfang ist der neue Trainer beim FCK. Also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch bzw. auch dir ging, Lisa. Ich habe einmal ganz tief durchgeatmet, als ich das gelesen habe, weil Markus Anfang zuletzt zweimal den Aufstieg mit Dynamo Dresden verpasst. Als mit absoluter Favorit auf die 2. Liga Rückkehr wurde dann auch im Laufe des Frühjahrs bei Dynamo Dresden entlassen. Also für mich schreit das jetzt nicht nach der perfekten Besetzung, muss ich gestehen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich war ehrlicherweise auch ein Stück weit verwundert. Ich muss aber auch gestehen, dass sich die Personalien bis Anfang des Marktes anfangen und die ganze Situation, die wir auch schon rund um Corona passen, etc. Das ist tatsächlich was, das habe ich noch nicht vergessen. Und das ist auch was, was bei mir immer noch ein sehr ungutes Gefühl irgendwie so auslöst. Das ist ein bisschen so, weiß ich nicht, ob man jetzt sportlich immer nur darauf gucken kann, wenn man weiß, was für Verfehlungen es irgendwie gab. Also das schwingt bei mir ehrlicherweise immer noch so ein bisschen mit. Das muss ich schon auch gestehen, wie bei vielen. Vielleicht gerade auch irgendwie die Debatte. Jérôme Boateng hat einen neuen Club und ist das jetzt okay, das zu hypen oder nicht? Wo es für mich auch eigentlich keine zwei Meinungen gibt, wo es aber in der Realität diverse Meinungen gibt. Im ersten Moment hat mich das aus sportlichen Gründen überrascht. Da ist das gerade schon so ein bisschen angerissen. Für mich war dann ehrlicherweise der zweite Gedanke auch so, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er so als Person zu diesem Verein und zu dem, was der Verein ist und sein möchte, passt. Habe aber dann auch das Gefühl, ich bin vielleicht nicht neutral genug oder nicht nah genug dran. Ich habe auch durchaus weniger Kritisches, sage ich mal, gelesen, im Sinne von, jetzt lasse ich ihn erst mal ankommen, lasse ich ihn mal machen, wenn es gut läuft. Dann ist das vielleicht auch eine Situation, die die Passung pannen. Also ich glaube, man versucht da jetzt gerade auch so ein bisschen ehrlicherweise, nicht so eine gramotze Situation schon heraufzubeschwören, wo gefühlt schon die ganze Fanbubble gegen ihn war, als irgendwie noch nicht mal ein Spiel gespielt war mit ihm als Trainer. Ja, finde ich aber ganz schwierig zu bewerten, ehrlicherweise, was man davon jetzt hält, ob das funktioniert, funktionieren kann. Ich war ähnlich verwundert wie du, um es einfach mal so auszudrücken.
Olli, du möchtest was dazu sagen.
Genau, mit dem Corona-Thema, das wird ja dann immer wieder mit ihm auch erzählt, auch zurecht, finde ich, aber da bin ich irgendwie an einem Punkt, wo ich mich mittlerweile ganz oft wundere, weil auch wenn man noch so liest, dass noch irgendwelche Verfahren aus der Zeit abgeschlossen werden und so, wenn man sich dann nochmal diese ganze Hitzigkeit damals auch in Erinnerung ruft, wo ich aber an einem Punkt bin, er hat da einen Fehler gemacht, hat das dann im Nachgang auch erklärt. Ich fand es nicht cool, aber irgendwie plausibel, wie er es erklärt hat. Insofern bin ich da so ein bisschen bereit, ihm zu verzeihen, ohne dass ich das jetzt müsste. Und habe jetzt aber auch bei Dynamo, wurde er vom Carblog dann mit einem großen Spruchband verabschiedet, was jetzt, glaube ich, nicht üblich ist, wenn du bei Dynamo Dresden zweimal den Aufstieg nicht geschafft hast. Und ich glaube, dass er da irgendwo auf menschliche Art und Weise gearbeitet hat. Und Dynamo ist jetzt ein ähnlich emotionales und aufgeregtes Umfeld wie der SFZ Kassus-Lautern, denke ich. Klar, Lautern ist noch ein bisschen größeres Stadion, aber ansonsten glaube ich schon ganz gut vergleichbar. Und dass er es da irgendwie geschafft hat, die Leute auch mitzunehmen und dass das vielleicht auch dann für ihn in Kassus-Lautern sprechen könnte, in einem ähnlichen Umfeld. Dass er da dann sozusagen da auch die Fan-Massen eint oder so ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl schafft und dass das ja auch ein Wert sein könnte, der Kassus-Lautern dann hilft.
Ja, Lisa hat da einmal kurz die Anschlussfrage, weil Thomas Hengen ist da ja durchaus dann auch wieder im Fokus. Und ich meine, das ist jetzt der vierte Trainer. Ich kann mir immer noch vorstellen, dass der ein oder andere Fan kritisch auf die Entlastung von Dirk Schuster schaut. Weil du hast es eben genannt, zum Schluss war es so, dass man eben die Punkte in der zweiten Halbzeit verloren hat. Ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass unter Schuster letzte Saison es waren auch absolute Freakspiele dabei, aber man hat eben ganz oft, selbst wenn man 2-3-0 zurückgelegen hat, das Spiel eben noch auf seine Seite ziehen können. Und ich glaube, für Thomas Hengen wird da die Luft langsam, aber sicher auch ein bisschen dünn.
Ja, ich glaube, das kann man schon so sagen. Also wir haben jetzt auch ein paar Mal schon über nicht so leichtes Umfeld bei großen Clubs, bei Traditionsclubs und so gesprochen, gefühlt sagt man es bei so vielen Vereinen. Aber ich glaube, das ist, wenn man auf Kaiserslautern guckt, schon auch eine Situation, die man mit einschließen muss, dass es eben schnell Unruhe gibt, dass es immer wieder Unruhe gibt bei verschiedenen Themen. Ich muss sagen, ich bin nicht so tief drin, weil es nicht mein Verein ist, verfolge aber relativ viel beim Kollegen Florian Reiß, den der eine oder andere vielleicht auch kennt, Betze Brennt ist auch eine gute Seite, die da immer wieder berichtet, was an so vielen Baustellen auch im Verein selber gerade los ist. Ich glaube, das würde jetzt an der Stelle hier ein bisschen zu weit führen, kann ich da aber den Kollegen und auch den Blog ans Herz legen. Ich bin da komplett bei dir. Wenn das jetzt keinen guten Start nimmt mit Markus Anfang, wenn da dann ein negatives Momentum vielleicht entsteht, wenn es sowieso vielleicht an der einen oder anderen Stelle schon Vorbehalte gibt, wenn man Nebenkriegsschauplätze hat, Sponsoren-Diskussionen hatten wir bei Hertha, glaube ich, auch vorhin schon kurz angesprochen. Ein ähnliches Thema gab es jetzt oder gibt es aktuell bei Kaiserslautern ja auch mit einem neuen Wettglücksspiel-Sponsor, was da auch gerade wieder ein bisschen Diskussionen ausgelöst hat. Also ich glaube, das sind alles so kleine Baustellen. Ja, wird nicht leichter, sage ich mal, wenn man da in der Verantwortung ist. Und wenn es dann nicht so läuft, wie man sich das als Traditionsverein irgendwie automatisch immer erwartet, glaube ich, ein Stück weit.
Ja, hast du, glaube ich, definitiv gute Punkte. Du hast Betsy Brent empfohlen. Aber auch da gab es in der Vergangenheit die eine oder andere Folge mit Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker, der das, glaube ich, auch nochmal gut aufgedröselt hat. Was beim FCK los war, das sei an der Stelle dann auch nochmal empfohlen. Ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich, aber ich glaube, angesichts der Zeit springen wir zum nächsten Club. Und das ist der 1. FC Magdeburg. Der steht auf dem 14. Platz, 98 Punkte. Ich glaube, eine schwierige Saison für den 1. Man holte zuletzt nur ein Sieg aus den letzten 10 Spielen. Am Ende hat man eben den Klassenerhalt geholt. Aber Olli, ich glaube, das war mit so einer der schwierigsten Saisons unter Christian Titz. Würdest du mir dazu stimmen?
Bin ich gar nicht so sicher. Wir haben heute schon über Vereine mit großer Europapokal-Historie gesprochen, Schalke und den HSV. Da müssen wir den 1. FC Magdeburg natürlich auch mit reinnehmen. Einziger Europapokalsieger der DDR. Das hat sich in dieser Saison zum 50. Mal gejährt. Und ist dann auch groß gefeiert worden. Und war dann auch natürlich ein begleitendes Element über die ganze Spielzeit. Aber du hast es gesagt, sie war jetzt nicht ganz so glamourös diese Saison. Aber die schwierigste, wir müssen uns erinnern, Christian Tietz ist gekommen vor drei Jahren. Da war der FCM Letzter oder Vorletzter in der 3. Liga. War schon mit anderthalb Beinen in der Regionalliga. Dann haben sie die ersten drei oder vier Spiele unter ihm auch verloren. Und dann mit einem nach einer 0-4-Klatsche gegen Ferl dann das Ruder rumgerissen und hatten dann irgendwie noch zehn Spiele Zeit, um sich zu retten und sind dann Achter geworden. Also das war auch eine schwierige Situation. Der Aufstieg war dann relativ leicht. Aber da der FCM ja vor der letzten Saison erst einen Zweitligier hatte, glaube ich, war es letztes Jahr auch schwierig. Da standen sie auch lange unten drin. Deswegen würde ich sagen, der FCM hat nie leicht in der 2. Liga, aber dieses Jahr hat er es auch nicht leicht gehabt.
Ich glaube, einer der Schlüsselspieler, die im Vergleich zur letzten Saison durchaus einen leichten Rückschritt hatte in seiner Leistung, war Baris Atik. Letzte Saison sicherlich einer der auffälligsten Spieler bei Magdeburg, 8 Tore in 28 Spielen. Die Saisonmanns dann doch nur 4. Es hat doch gerade vorne am Ende so ein bisschen die Durchschlagskraft gefehlt, könnte man glaube ich schon sagen. Oder dass im Sturm vielleicht die Spieler, die in der letzten Saison auffällig waren, da vielleicht ein bisschen Feder gelassen haben.
Das definitiv, aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, Baris Atek hat trotzdem auch noch 10 Assists, wenn ich richtig gesehen habe, gemacht. Er war in 14 Toren beteiligt, das ist jetzt keine ganz schlechte Quote. Aber klar, er war nicht mehr der krasse Unterschiedspieler, der in den beiden Saisons davor war. Und insgesamt, naja, in der Hinrunde ging es ja schon gut ab nach vorne beim FCM. Also dann standen 30 Tore am Ende der Hinrunde und in Erinnerung geblieben ist sicherlich das 6 zu 4 gegen Hertha. Und da waren ja ein paar Spiele dabei, die irgendwie so in die Richtung gingen. So, da hat man aber auch relativ viele Gegentore bekommen. Man hat sich dann für eine etwas defensivere Variante entschieden, was dann dazu führte, dass man fast genauso viele Gegentore, nämlich 26, in der Hinrunde waren es 28, bekommen hat, aber nur noch 16 Tore geschossen hat. Und ja, das führt dann sicherlich dazu da, dass man da eben jetzt auch nicht so ganz zufrieden ist. Oder glaube ich schon, dass da Leute auch insgesamt mehr erwartet haben. So Toni Kroos, der Champions League-Sieger, der hatte in seinem Podcast Magdeburg als Aufsteiger getippt, irgendwann relativ zu Saisonbeginn. So, und das ist von den FCM-Fans natürlich auch sehr wohlwollend wahrgenommen worden. Und ich denke, dass der Aufstieg realistisch ist, das hat keiner geglaubt. Aber man hat schon gedacht, dass man jetzt nicht bis zwei Spieltage pro Saisonende zittern muss, sondern irgendwo im gesicherten Mittelfeld mit fünf, sechs Punkten mehr mal locker abschließen würde. Und ja, neben Bayerische Atik waren jetzt auch andere Spieler, die nach vorne dann eben nicht mehr so gefährlich waren. Lukas Schuhler, der jetzt zu Hertha wechselt, sechs Tore gemacht, Lukas Tainos vier, das waren dann so die beiden Mittelstürmer. Ja, das ist dann sicherlich schon ausbaufähig, aber das ist jetzt, also die beiden Spieler haben den FCM auch verlassen. Insofern da im Sturmzentrum, das ist sicherlich eine der größten Baustellen für die kommende Saison.
Ja, generell kann man wahrscheinlich auch sagen, dass irgendwann sich natürlich immer mehr Teams auf die Art und Weise, wie Christian Tietz Fußball spielen lässt, eingestellt haben. Also ich glaube, es war schon so gerade im ersten Zweitliga-Jahr, dass genug Vereine überrascht hat, wie dominant man eben auch in die Spiele gegangen ist und ja auch viel Ballbesitz hatte etc. Also eben Christian Tietz Fußball, ehrlich gesagt, die in Kantenwitz wenig gewundert haben, wie er Fußball spielen lässt. Aber es ist natürlich immer so, dass natürlich die Gegner sich irgendwann auf die Spielweise auch einstellen, vielleicht sagen, okay, unser Gegner hat mehr Ballbesitz, wir gehen jetzt mal aufs Konterspiel. Es wird im Endeffekt sicherlich auch eine Rolle gespielt haben, aber generell kann man glaube ich schon sagen, dass der 1. FCM auf einem guten Weg ist, sich weiterhin als Zweitligist zu etablieren, auch wenn es vielleicht nach oben hin jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viele Ausreißer geben wird. Ich glaube, die Bundesliga ist dann doch noch eine Spur zu weit weg. Aber ich korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege, Olli, aber da steht der Klassenerhalt schon in jedem Jahr im Vordergrund.
In der jetzigen Phase absolut. Das war jetzt das insgesamt 3. Zweitliga-Jahr vom FCM. So gibt es diesen alten Spruch, das 2. Jahr ist immer das Schwerste. Das hat man jetzt erst mal überstanden. Das denke ich auch. Ich glaube schon, dass der FCM das Potenzial hat, sich eben noch irgendwo etwas höher in der 2. Liga zu etablieren. Dass es jetzt absehbar irgendwann die Bundesliga wird, das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen. Zum Thema, die Mannschaften haben sich darauf eingestellt. Da hat der Sportdirektor, der Geschäftsführer Sport, Ogmar Schork, auf der Saisonabschlusspressekonferenz auch gesagt, da können wir naja, aber wir spielen seit Jahren so. Das ist eben unser Ansatz. Wir stellen ja natürlich ein paar Dinge um. Aber es war ja letzte Saison auch lange so, dass sie eben wirklich da sehr hoch diesen Ballbesitzfußball gespielt haben und dann so zwei Drittel der Saison einfach den aber in letzter Position immer verloren haben und dann durch sehr einfache Konter immer die Spiele verloren haben. Dann hatten sie in der letzten Saison schon irgendwas geändert, dass das dann besser funktioniert hat. Jetzt haben sie sich eben auch einen neuen Ansatz überlegt, haben ein bisschen defensiver gespielt. Ich vermute, dass sie jetzt wieder eher zurück auch zu einer etwas offensiveren Spielweise oder werden da nach wegen suchen. Und glaube aber, dass Christian Thietz jetzt nicht grundsätzlich von seinem Fußball abrücken wird. Und dann bin ich so ein bisschen gespannt, was passiert, weil Baris Atek ist jetzt dreieinhalb Jahre da. Es sind einige Spieler da, wo ich glaube, dass so der Zyklus dieser Mannschaft irgendwann dann zu Ende sein dürfte. Und da muss man natürlich gucken, wie baut man dann eben die nächste Generation auch mit diesem Thietz-Fußball oder vielleicht auch mit einer anderen Idee, dass wir die Zeit zeigen. Aber ich glaube, da ist es dann bald tatsächlich Zeit für ein neues Element.
Ja, ja, definitiv spannend. Thomas, einmal ganz kurz noch die Rückfrage. Du kennst eventuell Christian Thietz auch noch aus HSV-Zeiten. Wie siehst du so seine Entwicklung, die er auch bei Magdeburg genommen hat?
Aus HSV-Zeiten tatsächlich nicht. Aber ich habe ihn mal gesucht, um den ersten FC Magdeburg als Aussteiger damals vorzustellen. Das ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr sympathischer, eloquenter und warmherziger Typ, der eine sehr spezielle Art von Fußball hat. Ich muss sagen, er hat nicht jedes Magdeburg-Spiel geschaut. Er ist natürlich schon auch ein bisschen dogmatisch, in dem er das Spiel denkt. Ich habe aber nichtsdestotrotz immer ganz großen Respekt davor, wenn man so die Linie dann auch irgendwo durchzieht. Und auch mit einem kleineren Verein probiert, einen mutigen Fußball zu spielen. Deswegen glaube ich, dass Christian Titz dem 1. FC Magdeburg da auf jeden Fall schon gut tut, weil er natürlich so eine Art Selbstbehauptung in diesem Club etabliert hat, den man jetzt jahrelang gut gekannt hat.
Ein Thema, was man bei Magdeburg natürlich noch ansprechen muss, auch mit Blick auf die nächste Saison, ist die Transfer-Historie. Da war es in dieser Saison einfach so, dass quasi alle Neuzugänge nicht funktioniert haben. Oder dass es ein, zwei Spieler gab, die hinten raus ganz hilfreich waren. Aber dass du tatsächlich einen großen Teil der Saison mit den Spielern auch bestritten hast, die schon da waren, was jetzt nicht schlimm ist. Aber was dann eben auch dazu führt, dass es da wahrscheinlich dann ein bisschen Erneuerungsbedarf gibt.
Gut, ich würde was sagen. Wir springen dann zu Platz 15. Außer du möchtest auch gerne was ergänzen, Oli.
Nur ein Hinweis, also wir haben ja bei unserem MDR-Podcast Neues vom Krügelplatz haben wir auch sehr ausführlich diese Dogen versprochen.
Und dann springen wir auf Platz 15. Und ich glaube, da steht ein Verein, da wussten viele Fans oder hätten das schon bereits nach gefühlt vier Spieltagen mit Kusshand genommen, wenn man ihnen sagt. Und ich glaube, 33 dieser 38 Punkte wurden mit Daniel Scherning als Trainer geholt, der, ich glaube, am 11.11. dann sein erstes Spiel hatte, nach der Derby-Niederlage gegen Hannover. Auch Braunschweig war immer wieder ein großer Teil dieses Podcasts. Liebe Grüße da an Anna Lautenbach. Aber zumindest ein Teil deiner Sechs-Seiten-Vorbereitung, Marc, sollst du jetzt über Eintracht Braunschweig loswerden. Das war für dich am Ende der Grund, warum Braunschweig in der Liga geblieben ist.
Ja, ich hab mich irgendwie ein bisschen in dieser Saison verloren. Weil sie aber auch eine Geschichte erzählt, muss man sagen. Und die Geschichte beginnt ja eher damit, dass die Hinrunde wirklich katastrophal anfing. Allein diese ganze Nummer rund um Michael Schiele, mit dem er nicht mehr in die Saison gegangen ist, nachdem er in der Rückrunde zuvor noch mit ihm verlängert hatte. Und plötzlich hatte man doch kein Vertrauen mehr. Nachdem die Rückrunde dann doch nicht so lief, wie man es sich vielleicht gewünscht hätte. Geil war damals, fand ich tatsächlich, die Kommunikation auch von Peter Vollmann, dem damals noch sportlichen Verantwortlichen, der beispielsweise Dinge sagte wie Michael, also Schiele, hat durch die Vertragsverlängerung die Ruhe bekommen, die man als Trainer braucht, um den Klassenhalt sichern zu können. Das war sicherlich auch ein Grund dafür, dass er es geschafft hat. Da haben wir schon das eine oder andere richtig gemacht. Im Nachhinein wurde diese ganze Personale dann trotzdem als Erfolg verklärt. Das war spannend. Das übernahm Jens Hertel, der recht erfolgreich bei Hansa war. Ein Grund, warum man damals von Schiele auf Hertel gegangen ist, war, dass man gesagt hat, wir waren durchaus zufrieden mit diesem temporeichen Umschaltspiel, was sich unter Michael Schiele etabliert hat und was ja auch für den Aufstieg gesorgt hat. Was gefehlt hat, war aber wohl die defensive Stabilität. Man wollte die Gegentore reduzieren. Das war der Hauptauftrag von Jens Hertel. Und man kann sagen, dass es nicht gelungen. In den ersten zwölf Spielen unter ihm gab es einen Sieg, zwei Unentschieden, neun Niederlagen. Also einen Sieg in der gesamten Zeit. Klarersichtlich waren auch damals die Neuzugänge noch Zeit gebraucht. Man hat es nicht hinbekommen, vor allen Dingen offensiv, aber auch eine Idee zu entwickeln. Zwischendurch gab es Systemwechseln und so weiter. Was aber auch dazu kommt, ist, dass man viel Pech zum Saisonstart hatte. Dadurch, dass es sich hier vor allen Dingen um die Rückrunde drehen soll, mache ich es kurz. Oft in der letzten Minute verloren. Teilweise Expected Goals, werte deutlich über den des Gegners gehabt und dazu auch immer mal wieder Platzverweise, nach denen es dann dahin ging. Das hat also auch zur Jens-Hertel-Misere dazugehört. Aber um es runterzubrechen, dieses Ziel, die Gegentore runterzuschrauben, gelang keinesfalls. Man hat 18 Gegentore in den ersten zehn Ligaspielen kassiert, dazu drei Gegentore im Pokal aus gegen Schalke, was ja dann auch als Herbepleite für die sportliche Führung, glaube ich, dann klar verbucht werden kann. Nach nur etwa vier Monaten im Amt musste Härtel dann ja gehen. Und dann kam erst Marc Fitzner als Interim-Trainer für zwei Spiele und dann eben sind wir bei Scherning. Und was unter Scherning passiert, ist es viel. Nicht nur, dass man da eine Scherning verpflichtet hat, man hat sich damals auch von Peter Vollmann als sportlichen Verantwortlichen getrennt. Das ging quasi zusammen einher. Der hat zwar noch die Scherning-Verpflichtung mit eingefädelt, aber nach den letzten Jahren, und ich glaube, da kann man auch viel bei Anna Lautenbach nachhören, liebe Grüße. Es gab nicht mehr so viel Vertrauen in Peter Vollmann nach den letzten Jahren. Und wer übernommen hat, es kam kringere als Benjamin Kessel, der ja wirklich lange Zeit, der von 2010 bis 2015 und dann noch mal 19 bis 21 bei Braunschweig gespielt und ist dann verpflichtet worden, um auch in Peter Vollmanns Rolle zu wachsen. Langfristig, das musste dann doch aber eher kurzfristig angedacht werden. Und es kam Daniel Scherning. Und Daniel Scherning, mit ihm kam eine Zeitenwende. Alles andere kann man nicht sagen. Sein erstes Spiel war das, was letztendlich auch, glaube ich, den Umschwung sorgen sollte. Und zwar das Spiel gegen seinen Ex-Verein Osnabrück. Ein unglaublich wichtiges Spiel, zwei abschiefsgefährdete Clubs, das dann auch für ein Momentum sorgen sollte. Und dementsprechend dramatisch war ja auch damals der Spielverlauf, wenn man sich erinnert. Braunschweig kam damals gut ins Spiel, ging früh in Führung, kassierte dann aber kurz vor der Halbzeitpause das 1 zu 1. Dann, man sah damals auch schon viel, was unter Daniel Scherning dann auch wichtig werden sollte. Umschaltspiel, gute Mentalität, da haben wir das Wort wieder. Und in der 60. Minute sah Osnabrück's Cuisance dann auch die gelb-rote Karte, nach einer eher fragwürdigen Entscheidung. Und in der 71. Minute viel erneut an der Führungstreffer. Man dachte, man hätte es geschafft, aber in der 87. Minute fiel der Ausgleich wieder durch einen verwandelten Handelfmeter. Es gab sieben Minuten Nachspielzeit. Und als die schon durch war, in der 98. Minute, gab es einen letzten Angriff der Braunschweiger. Und ein abgefälschter Schuss landete damals bei B. Cakčić, der aus kurzer Distanz dann ins Tor stocherte. Braunschweig gewann dieses Spiel. Das war eine Definition eines Kampenspiels und so eines egal-wie-Sieges. Und das hat dann den Glauben zurückgegeben und ein wahnsinniges Momentum unter Scherning geschaffen. Also nach dem Spiel sollte dann die große Aufholjagd beginnen. Daran änderte auch nichts, dass man dann erst mal gegen den HSV und 4. knapp verloren hat, weil die Art und Weise des Auftritts gestimmt hat. Und dann gab es nämlich diese vier Siege in Folge. Selbst Holstein Kiel hat man damals geschlagen. Offensiv hat Scherning in der Phase, wie sein Vorgänger auch, auf dieses Umschaltspiel gesetzt. Das wirkte unter ihm aber deutlich zielstrebiger. Und vor allen Dingen ein armer Muster genannt werden. Und zwar Raja Philipp, der in der Hinrunde noch überhaupt kein Faktor war. Und allein in den ersten drei Spielen unter Scherning drei Tore und drei Vorlagen gezaubert hat. Ich glaube, am Ende stand dabei irgendwie neun Toren und fünf Vorlagen oder so was. Also absoluter Unterschiedspieler. Er füllte damit auch die Lücke, die ja Anthony Uja hinterließ, meiner innere Sicht. Die sportliche Lage war ohnehin schon katastrophal. Und dann fehlte er auch noch von Spieltag 8 bis 17 mit einer Schulter Eckgelenks-Sprengung und fand danach auch nicht mehr in die Saison rein. Also, da kam eigentlich nichts mehr. Defensiv gelang dann Scherning das, was Härtel eigentlich erreichen sollte, die Reduzierung der Gegentore. Er ist zur Dreierkette zurückgekehrt und das gab der Mannschaft offensichtlich Stabilität, auch weil einige Sommerneuzugänge bisher eingebunden wurden. Unter Härtel, ich hab's mal ausgerechnet, gab's 1,9 Gegentore pro Spiel und unter Scherning 1,3, wobei man auch da sagen muss, allein 12 der 29 Gegentore unter Scherning hat man in den letzten vier Spielen kassiert. Da war man fast schon gerettet. Also es waren Spiele gegen HSV, Fürth und Lautern und damals waren man entweder nahezu oder schon am letzten Spieltag offiziell gerettet, weshalb dieser Gegentorschritt eigentlich noch besser aussieht, wenn man ihn auf die wirklich relevanten Spiele runterrechnet. Und ein entscheidender Faktor bei der Stabilisierung der Defensive, auf den kommen wir dann natürlich zurück, ist dann Ermi B. Der 34-jährige Regalverschäft, der ist im Oktober dann noch relativ kurzfristig gekommen aus Hoffenheim, hat vorher ja auch jahrelang bei Braunschweig gespielt, sich da einen Namen gemacht, hatte echt schwierige Jahre selbst bei Hoffenheim aufgrund von Verletzungen. Also ich hatte nicht mehr damit gerechnet, ich persönlich, dass er nochmal in den Profivusball zurückkehrt, weil er wirklich ewig raus war. Aber mit dieser robusten Kompromissen-Zweikampfart, wie man ihn ja kennt, und dieser Lufthoheit, hat er super viel geleistet. Und am Ende hatten lediglich fünf Zweitligisten weniger Gegentore kassiert als Braunschweig. Und mit den 33 Punkten, Eva, die du schon erwähnt hast, in den 21 Spielen unter Scherning, hat Braunschweig übrigens mehr Punkte geholt in dem gleichen Zeitraum als der HSV. Das ist auch eine Statistik, die man sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen kann. Scherning sprach im Nachhinein vom größten Erfolg seiner Karriere als Cheftrainer. Er sagte selber, er glaubt, dass ihm das damals niemand zugetraut hätte. Das weiß er auch. Und genau das hat ihn auch immer motiviert. Find ich auch mal ganz nett, wenn das Leute zugeben, weil oft heißt es ja, ja, ich guck ja nicht nach außen. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz sympathisch im Nachhinein. Und ja, ich glaube, Scherning hat der Mannschaft sehr, sehr viel gegeben durch sehr klare, nachvollziehbare Entscheidungen, durch eine gute Komplikation. Und er hat ihm auch wieder diesen Willen und diese Zweikampfhärte und diese kämpferischen Werte wieder vermittelt. Und das hat man zum Beispiel beim Spiel gesehen, als man hat zum Beispiel 4 zu 0 gegen HSV verloren, im nächsten Spiel dann in Unterzahl und nach einem gehaltenen Elfmeter noch 3 zu 3 gegen Viert gespielt. Oder man hat noch Spiele in Unterzahl über die Zeit gebracht. Das waren ja genau diese Big Points, die man vorher nicht geholt hat. Und spannend dürfte es jetzt eben sein, wie es dann für Braunschweig weitergeht. Auch da findet so ein leichter Zykluswechsel statt. Leichte, ja, Umbrüche im Kader. Schanning hat ja schon frühzeitig bis 25 verlängert. Und er sagt selbst, dass es zwar keine Kampfeinsage sei, aber man wolle in dieser Liga eine Rolle spielen. Und man möchte im Idealfall nicht um Platz 15 spielen. Ich bin gespannt, ob das hinhaut. Es geht ja, gehen ja dann mit Helga Sonn, mit Donkor, mit Ron-Thomas Hoffmann, die wir schon erwähnt haben, gehen wichtige Stützen des Teams. Aber grundsätzlich muss man sagen, ist Daniel Schanning natürlich der Name dieser Saison, von Eintracht Braunschweig. Und ich finde es irgendwie auch ein bisschen schön, mit so einem MLB-Takčić, mit einem Benjamin Kessel, zwischenzeitlich Marc Vitzner, der kurz an die Seitlinie zurückgekehrt ist. Hat das auch so ein bisschen was Fußballromantisches, so von wegen die alten Recken kommen noch mal zurück und retten den Verein, auch das finde ich irgendwie nett.
Ich glaube, das sind auch die Namen, die man noch mit Braunschweig verbindet.
Auch als Außenstehender, und es ist irgendwie schön, dass die das dann gewuppt haben.
Entschuldigt, weil ich hatte überhaupt keine Erwartung. Natürlich auch da wiederum sehr biased, ihr mögt es mir verzeihen, aber ja, ich weiß, dass ich auch zum Ende der Hinrunde durchaus sehr skeptisch war, woher das dann auf einmal kommen würde, aber das hat dann ja auch immer viel mit dem Umfeld zu tun. Und da scheint viel richtig gemacht worden zu sein. Lass uns jetzt tatsächlich auf einen Verein gucken, wo dann, glaube ich, doch viel falsch gelaufen ist zuletzt. Und das ist wie in Wiesbaden. Man stand auf dem 16. Platz, hatte dadurch natürlich noch die Chance in der Relegation, doch in der Liga zu bleiben. Aber die zweite Liga und die Relegation, egal ob nach oben oder nach unten, man ist einfach nicht der Gewinner. Also ich habe eben schon mal gesagt, nur drei Zweitligisten haben gegen die Bundesligisten gewonnen. Ich glaube, von zweiter zu dritter Liga sind es vier Zweitligisten, die das Duell für sich entscheiden konnten. Also statistisch einfach nicht Relegation spielen. Wenn du Zweitligist bist, es geht meistens nicht gut für dich aus. 32 Punkte sind es am Ende. Einer mehr als Hansa Rostock. Auch durchaus dramatisches Finish da am letzten Spieltag. Man führt erst gegen St. Pauli und muss dann eben doch noch die Niederlage einstecken. Geht dann eben in die Relegationsspiele gegen Regensburg. Erstes Spiel endet unentschieden. Und das Zweite verliert man dann auch durch, sagen wir mal, durchaus kritische Entscheidungen der Schiedsrichter in dem Spiel. Aber hinterher wird eben auch von Offiziellen gesagt oder von Spielern. Na ja, sind wir mal ganz ehrlich. Diesen Abstieg haben wir uns im Endeffekt auch erspielt. Man hat nämlich, ist das schlechteste Team der Rückrunde, nur zwei Siege geholt. Der letzte Sieg Anfang März gegen Elbersberg. Sonst hat man eben gegen Osnabrück, Rostock, Kaiserslautern und Braunschweig, also die Teams drumherum verloren. Eben diese Dua-Di-Spiele. Und Lisa, man kann schon sagen, wahrscheinlich der Abstieg und eben die Rückkehr nach einem Jahr zurück in Liga 3, war dann doch verdient.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist am Ende das Fazit, das man ziehen muss. Du hast ja gerade den letzten Spieltag schon so ein bisschen umrissen, dass es gefühlt ja schon ein Erfolg war, dass man sich in die Relegation gerettet hat und dass man auch durchaus direkt hätte absteigen können. Relegation, ja, das ist dann immer eine Geschichte für sich, ob das fair oder unfair ist. In dem Fall glaube ich, kann man sich von Wiesbadener Seite in dem Sinne jetzt nicht beschweren, sondern man hat da die Saison über die Zweitklassigkeit verloren. Ich glaube, man ist in der Himmelrunde besser reingekommen, als man das selber erwartet hat. Da war das ja schon eher ein solider Mittelfeldplatz. Man hat den ein oder anderen Überraschungserfolg, will ich es mal nennen, zum Beispiel gegen Hertha ja eingefahren und im neuen Jahr ist man dann im Endeffekt so ein bisschen in die Realität abgerutscht, wenn man das Böse sagen möchte. Wenn man aber glaube ich gleichzeitig sich anguckt, ich habe nicht furchtbar viele Wiesbadenspiele gesehen, aber in der Konferenz das ein oder andere gegen Nürnberg natürlich auch relativ passiv viel aktiv stehen, den Gegner kommen lassen und dann selber mal gucken, was geht. Man hat dann klar einen Torjäger mit Ivan Britein, der da auch seine Buden gemacht hat und der jetzt ja ziemlich sicher auch wechseln wird. Ich weiß nicht, was das heißeste Gerücht aktuell ist. Ich habe die letzten Tage immer mal wieder gehört, HSV, Hertha, Schalke hat eine Ausstiegsklausel und wird wohl nicht mit in die 3. Liga gehen, aber das ist natürlich dann auch kein Spieler, der den ganzen Club durch eine Saison tragen und die Punkte alleine irgendwie einfahren kann. Sich dann Ende April irgendwie noch vom Trainer zu trennen, von Markus Korczynski, war wahnsinnig nicht ehrlicherweise so diese klassische, man muss noch irgendwie was tun Situation, glaube ich, wenn man sieht, es läuft nicht, ob dann der Co-Trainer, der jetzt Interimstrainer ja auch nur war, bzw. ist Nils Döring der Richtige ist, ob man mit dem weiter macht, das will ich gar nicht so sehr beurteilen, ehrlicherweise. Ich glaube als Aufsteiger in der 2. Liga, als kleinerer Club, als den ich in Wiesbaden auch einfach mal bezeichnen würde, hast du es generell nicht leicht, musst damit rechnen, dass es auch wieder runter geht und anders als zum Beispiel Elbersberg war das glaube ich so ein bisschen die realistische Version von du kommst als kleiner Club in die 2. Liga und versuchst es, aber merkst dann halt trotz einiger ganz guten Spiele zum Start, am Ende auch auf.
Ja, das fühlt allen Belangen nicht so richtig reich. Aber weil der SC Freiburg die 2. Vertretung da im Platz 2 angenommen hat, auch das war damals ein dramatisches Finish, dass man eben über die Relegation reingerückt hat damals, aber natürlich auch mit Hollerbach einen seiner stärksten Spieler eigentlich verloren oder eben an Union Berlin, der dann direkt den Sprung eigentlich auch von Dritter in die Bundesliga gemacht hat. Und ich glaube, am Ende sind wir mal ganz ehrlich, da hat einfach zu viel gefehlt und man ist zwar nicht so wie in der letzten zweitligere Saison direkt wieder als 18er runtergegangen, aber diese Rückrunde war einfach zu schlecht und wir haben drüber geredet, es gab durchaus andere Vereine, die auch keine gute Rückrunde gespielt haben, aber eben weil man die direkten Duellen größtenteils verloren hat, ist eben das, das kostet dich am Ende den Kragen, wie gesagt, die Relegationsspiele waren durchaus auch bitter von Wiesbadener Seite, diese 2 Elfmeter, die da nicht gegeben werden am Ende und Co, das trotz auch VAR etc. ist natürlich, was dann bitter ist, aber ja, ich glaube, im Endeffekt wird es bei wehen keinen Großwunder, nur du hast schon gesagt, das steht auch daheim wie ein Umbruch an, auch da vielleicht kein, ist nicht respektlos gemeint, aber ich glaube auch, Wiesbaden ist eben so eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft oder so eine Schienenmannschaft zwischen 2. und 3. Liga. Ich glaube, für die wird es erstmal wichtig sein, dass man sich eben stabilisiert für die 3. Liga-Saison, weil auch da sieht man, das kann richtig schnell, richtig tief gehen. Wir haben einige Traditionsvereine auch verloren von der 3. Liga, eben in die Regionalliga jetzt auch Vereine, die da seit zwölf Jahren gespielt haben. Das ist, 3. Liga ist kein Kuchenessen irgendwie, das ist eine richtig harte Aufgabe und es ist eben nicht die Norm, dass alle drei Aufsteiger drin bleiben. Ich glaube, das können wir festhalten. Dank für's Zuschauen. Schön, das wird ja das geflügelte Wort. Dann sind wir bei den Vorletzten Platz angelangt. Und das ist Hansa Rostock. 31 Punkte sind es am Ende, eben wie gesagt dieser eine Punkt. Auf den Wiesbaden am Ende fehlte eben auch, weil man gegen den SC Paderborn verloren hat. Am letzten Spieltag unter anderem auch mit Spielunterbrechung. Nur 9 Siege, 4 Unentschieden, 21 Niederlagen. Mit 30 Toren hat man die schlechteste Offensive der Liga. Olli, lass uns kurz einmal erst auf Sportliche gucken, weil dann müssen wir definitiv, glaube ich, einmal neben dem Platz gucken. War dieser Abstieg am Ende noch zu verhindern oder hat sich es dann doch relativ eindeutig abgezeichnet?
Naja, so von meinen Überlegungen über die ganze Saison muss man noch dazu sagen, den ersten, also fast die ganze Hinrunde hab ich ja verpasst, weil ich noch nach der BM der Frauen in Australien und Neuseeland war. Das heißt, da hatte ich dann ein paar Spiele im Audiosstream gehört und sie hörten sich genauso schlimm an, wie sie dann später aussahen, als ich wieder da war. Aber das waren ja die, gerade ganz am Anfang der Saison, die war zumindest erfolgreich. Also saß man irgendwie vorm Radio in irgendeinem Hostel und dachte, um Gottes Willen, das klingt ja alles grausam. Aber am Ende stand irgendwie ein Ergebnis dabei. So in der Summe, gerade mit der offensiven Ausbeute, du hast es angesprochen, war das schon sehr lange in meinem Kopf, dass das passieren könnte. Und es war jetzt auch klar, oder nicht sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wir noch mal so einen Schlussspurt hinlegen, wie in der letzten Saison, wo es ja auch schon sehr finster aussah. Und dann...
Ja, noch mal kurz, um auf die Offensive zu gucken. Also drei Spieler haben maximal vier Tore und stellen damit dann die drei stärksten Offensivspieler mit Perea Brumado und Kai Bröger. Und dann eben auch gerade Standardverteidigung. Da war man die zweitschlechteste Mannschaft nach Standards, 18 Gegentore, nur Osnabrück war schlechter. Ich glaube insgesamt, ja, vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu viel Unruhe rund um den Verein. Definitiv ja, ja, ich glaube, zu viele Trainer dann vielleicht auch in einer Saison, da zu viel, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob man da, ja, ja, beziehungsweise zu, ja.
Na gut, es waren ja nur zwei, ne, aber. Na ja, das Hauptproblem ist eigentlich, also ich glaube, wir müssen schon in der letzten Saison anfangen zu erzählen. Also wir hatten ja da noch Jens Herthel, der vier Jahre bei uns war, so, wo ich jetzt auch seinen Weg im Braunschweig irgendwie auch verfolgt hatte und das sehr schade fand, was mit ihm passiert ist. Davor war Herr Herthel ja in Magdeburg gewesen, so, und er hat den schlafenden Riesen-FCM irgendwie geweckt, war da auch viereinhalb Jahre, glaube ich sogar. Ähnliche Geschichte eigentlich wie jetzt im Braunschweig, weil er da auch in den ersten zehn Spielen in der Regionalliga damals gar nichts gerissen hat und dann schon kurz vorm Rausfall stand und dann gab es einen so ein Kippspiel und plötzlich hat alles funktioniert und danach ist er zweimal mit dem FCM aufgestiegen. Darauf hatte ich jetzt eigentlich auch so ein bisschen gehofft, dass ihm das im Braunschweig passiert. Ist leider nicht, aber gut für die Eintracht, sie haben es ja dann trotzdem noch geschafft. So, Jens Herthel wurde entlassen, ja, weil man mit der damaligen Begründung eben auch die Spielweise ein bisschen anpassen wollte. Also Jens Herthel stand eben für einen sehr robusten, einen sehr einfachen Fußball mit vielen langen Bällen. Dann hat man Patrick Löckner geholt, wollte sich fußballerisch eigentlich weiterentwickeln. Hatte, glaube ich, aber dafür nicht unbedingt den Kader und auf jeden Fall hat es nicht funktioniert, sodass man dann in der Saison noch getauscht hat und Alois Schwarz geholt hat, der dann nach einer kurzen Anlaufzeit eben diesen tollen Schlussspurt hingelegt hat, der dazu führte, dass der FC Hansa auch in dieser Saison einer 2. Bundesliga teilnehmen durfte. So und ich weiß noch, wie wir ein paar Minuten vorher im Stadion hatten wir Alois Schwarz gefeiert, aber auf dem Weg raus aus dem Stadion hatte ich mit meinem Kumpel gequatscht, aber wir haben gesagt, ja, eigentlich, wenn du dieses zielfußballerische Weiterentwicklung angehen möchtest, dürftest du nicht mit Schwarz verlängern. So, und das ist dann aber passiert. Und das war in meinen Augen wahrscheinlich der Kardinalfehler, der jetzt auch zu dieser ganzen Situation geführt hat. Weil Alois Schwarz, das ist ein absoluter Top-Typ, finde ich. Aber steht eben eher für, sagen wir mal, auch sehr robusten Fußball, eher für 3. Liga-Fußball. Und ist eben genau gut, um, so wie Jens Hertl auch, dich aus der 3. Liga rauszukriegen. Und sein Fußball funktioniert in der 2. Liga, aber an allen seinen Stationen jetzt nicht für immer. Also da war klar, dass das eine begrenzte Halbwehrzeit ist. Und naja, dann haben wir einen Haufen Spieler verpflichtet, obwohl ich leider sagen muss, tut mir jetzt auch leid in deine Richtung, Eva, aber das waren halt alles Verlierer. Also das insgesamt sechs oder sieben Spieler von Sandhausen, von Regensburg und von Andina Bielefeld verpflichtet, die alle vorher eben abgestiegen waren. Und dann habe ich mich schon gefragt, gerade bei den Sandhausen-Spielern, okay, du hast einen Trainer, der da entlassen wurde, seine Mannschaft ist abgestiegen und dann holst du noch die Spieler, die das zu verantworten hatten. Janik Bachmann haben wir vorhin schon irgendwann mal drüber gesprochen bei Schalke. So und ja, Hansa hat dann eben immer ausgezeichnet, dass du so irgendwie schon eine Mentalität hattest. Da sind wir beim Thema. Aber auch so Typen, die irgendwie die anderen mitreißen konnten. Da fällt mir Ryan Malone ein jetzt bei Ingolstadt. Der beste Einwerfer Deutschlands. Und der war auch immer mal für einen richtigen Klops gut. Aber der war echt so, der hat irgendwie die Ärmel hoch gekrempelt und der ist marschiert. Und das hat seine Mitspieler mitgerissen und das hat das Publikum mitgerissen. Und davon hattest du in dieser Saison zu wenig. Na ja, und dann, tja, weiß ich nicht genau, was die Spielidee war. Aber für mich sah sie so aus. Kurzer Abstoß, dann Ball nach links und dann nach vorne. Und dann hoffen. Und eigentlich der Matchplan, um Tore zu schießen, war, Kai Bröger läuft den Torwart an und wenn er Glück hat, wird er angeschossen. Und das ist überraschenderweise sogar drei-, viermal passiert. Aber das war jetzt keine Spieleidee, auf der ich eine Saison aufbauen würde. Und dann gab es neulich beim NDR, Facebook-Post über den passstärksten, ne Moment, wo habe ich ihn hier? Genau, den besten Passspieler der Liga, was der Karel Metz von St. Pauli war und den schlechtesten Passspieler der Liga, was Alexander Rossipal bei uns war, der irgendwie 506 Fehlpässe gespielt hat. Und dann habe ich überlegt, das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen unfair, den Post so zu machen, aber gut, dann war er jetzt einmal in der Welt. Aber klar, der Ball ging immer links raus und er war der Typ, der halt immer den langen Ball spielen musste. Deswegen, die konnten ja gar nicht ankommen, weil er einfach immer da irgendwie lang nach vorne gebolzt hat. Aber das ja offensichtlich auch die Ansage war. Ja, und so kam dann irgendwie eins zum anderen, hat das insgesamt zu wenig Leute, die Fußball spielen können, aus meiner Sicht. Nämlich drei oder vier. Und die auch selten alle zusammen auf dem Platz standen. Und deswegen sahen die Spiele dann so aus, wie sie aussahen.
Also ich glaube, am Ende dieser Abstieg ist dann doch folgerichtig. Es wird jetzt auch durchaus interessant, glaube ich, mit Bernd Hollerbach als neuen Trainer in der 3. Liga-Saison. Weiß ich nicht, was für ein Potenzial es hat. Würde ich jetzt per se erstmal sagen, kein wahnsinnig gutes. Also gerade aus der 2. Liga-Zeit ist er mir jetzt nicht besonders gut in Erinnerung. Aber er hat natürlich durchaus einen gewissen Charakter auch. Aber Olli, wir müssen tatsächlich einmal auf das Geschehene neben dem Platz schauen. Weil da muss man ja leider auch am Ende sagen, hat man Hansa Rastock mehr dadurch wahrgenommen in der Saison, als dass man sie im Endeffekt durch ihre durchaus schlechte, aber durch ihre sportliche Leistung wahrgenommen hat. Du bist Hansa-Fan, du bist im Verein verbunden. Und gute Freundin von mir ist es auch. Und ich habe schon gesehen, man leidet irgendwann auf anderer Art, weil man das Gefühl hat, da läuft so viel gleichzeitig falsch im Verein. Wie schaust du denn darauf? Ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, auch beim Spiel gegen Paderborn gab es wieder Ausschreitungen, gab es immer wieder. Ob es generell Fan-Ausschreitungen sind, aber eben auch natürlich, muss man eben auch sagen, die durchaus rassistischen Entgleisungen, die es vor allem in Spielen gegen FC St. Pauli gibt. Wie schaust du auf Hansa Rostock, was da auf den Tribünen passiert?
Na ja, es gibt so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Störp langsam kennt, und da gibt es so dieses Handbuch für Terroristen, das sie dann durchgehen und wo es einfach die Situation immer schlimmer wird. So ähnlich hab ich das Gefühl auch bei Hansa, dass wir einfach so, gibt es so einen Plan für einen Untergang oder was man alles falsch machen kann als Verein, wenn es irgendwie sportlich scheiße läuft und den gehen wir einfach so Schritt für Schritt durch. Also auch auf der Führungsebene haben wir eben da auch. Aus meiner Sicht, na ja, Verlierer verpflichtet. Da kam der Christian Walter von Dynamo und Dresden, der da vorher Scout war, der war dann unser Sportdirektor. Dann ist unser Vorstandsvorsitzender Robert Marien. Aus gesundheitlichen Gründen Anfang des Jahres hat er eine Pause eingelegt. Dann wurde Jürgen Behlen verpflichtet. Der war vorher bei Osnabrück und bei Dynamo und Dresden. Also genau auch wieder so zwischen zweiter und dritter Liga. Aber wo ich eben auch dachte, naja, eigentlich wäre es ja cool, wenn wir Leute holen, die uns vielleicht aufs nächste Level bringen. Und nicht wieder dahin, wo wir herkommen. So und auch beim Thema Fans, ja, da haben wir dann auch verloren. Und ich muss leider sagen, ich habe das Spiel gegen Paderborn dann nicht im Stadion geguckt, weil ich dachte, gut, falls es noch klappt mit der Relegation, ganz schön viel Reisestress für eine Woche. Also ich wohne ja in Leipzig. Das ist ja auch immer ein kleiner Weg nach Rostock. Aber weil ich ehrlicherweise genau das, was passiert ist, auch befürchtet habe, dass dann in dem Moment, wo irgendein Ergebnis feststeht, was nicht das Relegationsspiel sein sollte, dass da Leute komplett durchdrehen. Da habe ich schon eine Weile das Gefühl, dass da manche jedes Maß verloren haben. Und das nervt mich unglaublich, weil das natürlich auch Einfluss, hier, wenn ich mit euch rede, wenn mich andere Leute drauf ansprechen, dann tut das ja weh, wenn du irgendwie über Hansa Rostock reden musst, den Scheiß-Nazi-Verein, sage ich jetzt mal so, wie es halt manche Leute darstellen. Das ist jetzt nichts, was ich mir irgendwie anheften möchte. Aber es ist ja seit Jahren so, dass dann eben die Klos auswärts kaputt getreten werden, wo ja Leute wirklich morgens aus dem Haus gehen müssen und denken, geil, heute trete ich wieder drei Toiletten ab. Dann die Geschichte gegen St. Pauli, hast du angesprochen, wo ich beim ersten Mal noch gedacht habe, es ist eine ziemlich dümmliche Provokation. Aber dafür stehen manche Leute halt in unserer Fanszene. Aber wenn dann jetzt in dieser Saison zum dritten Mal nacheinander irgendwas mit dem Sonnenblumenhaus gegen St. Pauli gezeigt wird. Da kannst du ja auch nicht mehr von Zufall sprechen oder das in irgendeiner Weise schönreden. Das finde ich dann schon erschütternd, dass da auch so wenig Bewusstsein ist. Und auch die Erklärung, die der Verein danach abgegeben hat. So sinngemäß, na ja, das war ein Choreo vom Fanclub Plattenbau. Und zu sehen waren ja die zehn schönsten Plattenbauten Rostocks. Also, das geht nicht. Hätte man ja nach dem ersten Mal, wenn da so was gekommen wäre, hätte ich noch gesagt, na ja, es ist jetzt einfach passiert. Aber man muss ja irgendwann auch verstehen, dass da Leute was anderes sehen und dass diese Lesart, würde ich jetzt behaupten, von Teilen unserer Fanszene durchaus gewollt ist. So, und das nervt mich brutal. Aber ja, und die rassistische Entgleisung hast du auch angesprochen. Es ist auch so, dass man im Hansaumfeld jetzt auch mehr als noch vor einigen Jahren, keine Ahnung, rassistische Aufkleber oder irgendwelche Sachen entdeckt. Oder auch gegen andere Minderheiten oder marginalisierte Gruppen gerichtet. Wo das offener ausgesprochen wird, als das noch vor einigen Jahren üblich war. Und da fehlt mir leider so ein bisschen die Fantasie, wie wir davon wieder wegkommen. Weil es eben auch dann auf Vorstandsebene oder durch die Kommunikationsabteilung teilweise schön geredet wird. Dann kam jetzt wieder eine Erklärung nach einem Paderborn-Spiel. Hier blablabla und erschüttert. Und wir werden das kritisch aufarbeiten. So eine Mitteilung hat man jetzt mittlerweile auch 20 Mal gelesen. Wir müssen uns einfach noch mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Wir haben es in dieser Saison zweimal fast geschafft, dass ein Spiel gegen Paderborn abgebrochen wurde. Nicht gegen St. Pauli, nicht gegen Schalke, sondern zweimal standen wir gegen Paderborn kurz vorm Spielabbruch. Und das ist wirklich... Also, da schwillt mir der Hals. Da weiß ich wirklich dann nicht mehr, was man da noch irgendwie sagen soll. Aber von der Selbstreinigung der Fanszene, da rechne ich leider nicht mehr mit. Das ist ja immer so ein Thema, was dann oft auch bespüren wird.
Ich möchte hier kurz eine Sache mit einbringen. Kommt von einer, die auch Rasenfunk-Unterstützerin ist und die damals durchaus auch zurecht am Ende der Hinrunde kritisiert hat, dass es durchaus einfacher ist, aus Hamburg, aus Bielefeld und Co. zu sagen, ja, hier sag doch einfach Nazis raus und fertig ist. Also ich glaube, man darf wirklich nicht unterschätzen, ja, was für ein Machtmonopol die Fanszene oder eben Block 9a in Rostock hat. Und dass es tatsächlich einfacher ist, jetzt in Hamburg oder in Bielefeld oder weiß ich nicht, auch Berlin und Co. aufzustehen und zu sagen, wenn da ein Kommentar fällt, ja, hier nicht. Aber tatsächlich, die unter anderem sagt, dass diese Saison und auch die letzte so viele Tiefpunkte hatte, dass sie es nicht mehr zählen kann. Und da möchte sie sogar das Sportliche ausklammern. Und dass sie einfach sagt, für sie war Hansa immer Kindheit und war immer mit sehr vielen positiven Momenten besetzt. Aber dass sie eben wie du auch sagst, Olli leider momentan einfach nicht das Gefühl hat, dass diese Problematiken, die auch herrschen, im Verein richtig ernst genommen werden. Und da richtig vorgegangen werden, du hast die Stellungnahmen gesehen. Man muss sagen, Hansa Rostock befindet sich auf Bewährung. Im Sinne ja auch und ich bin mal tatsächlich gespannt. Ich bin der letzte Mensch, der hier gerne für Kollektivstrafen plädiert etc. Aber man muss ja leider einfach sagen, es handelt sich nicht um eine kleine Minderheit. Beziehungsweise wenn es eine Minderheit ist, dann wird sie eben dafür vom Verein glaube ich zu sehr hofiert und toleriert. Ja, es gab diese Statements an die Mitglieder, an die Fans, aber man muss ja ganz klar sagen, man ist an einem Punkt, wo gerade auch in der 3. Liga, wir haben das, also man muss ja auch sagen, mit Alemannia Aachen steigt ein Verein in die 3., oder ist ein Verein in die 3. Liga aufgestiegen, wo eben im Schatten der Regionalliga-Zeit eben ein rechtsextremes Konglumerat irgendwie im Verein immer mehr Macht halten konnte. Und ich glaube, das können tatsächlich ziemlich dunkle Jahre noch für Hansa Rostock werden, wenn man da nicht irgendwann den Turnaround schafft, wenn man den Turnaround ehrlich gesagt überhaupt schaffen will. Aber ich würde trotzdem einfach mal ausgehen, einfach auch, ja, for the sake, für den Rest der Fans, weil das muss man ja auch sagen, es gibt genug Fans, die einfach genau aus den Gründen inzwischen vom Stadion fernbleiben. Und ich glaube, das ist ja was, was der Verein dann auch jedenfalls dem Rest deiner Mitglieder durchaus schuldig ist, da dann einen Turnaround zu schaffen.
Was glaube ich noch viel mehr im Mittelpunkt steht, ist als jetzt diese rassistischen Aussprüche oder die Kurse oder so, generell halt so dieses Gewaltthema. So ist jetzt Block 9a angesprochen, da muss man die Südtribüne als Hauptsupportort schon auch mitnennen, wo ich das auch so wahrnehme. So ich meine, dass 9a entstanden ist, das lag ja auch an politischen Differenzen innerhalb der Fanszene, dass dann quasi da ein Teil der Fanszene sich einen neuen Standort im Stadion gesucht hat. Dann hast du eben immer dieses Problem mit der Südtribüne, dass sie direkt neben dem Gästeblock ist. Schalke-Fans werden sich erinnern, da muss man nur eine Glasscheibe rausnehmen, dann kann man da relativ schnell rüber. Wurde jetzt auch nochmal gesichert, aber das ist so ein Thema, das seit Jahren nicht richtig gelöst ist und eben so generell dieses Gewaltding oder das, was irgendwo perver mit schwingt, was sich auch darin äußert, dass irgendwie Tubis in Rostock im Sommer abgezogen werden, wenn die da halt mit ihren Fan-Klamotten im Urlaub sind. Was mich ja dann auch umgekehrt auch in Gefahr bringt, wenn ich irgendwo hinfahre und eigentlich ein Hansa-T-Shirt anziehen möchte, dass ich mir das permanent überlegen muss. Das ist ja die erste Stufe. Dass er permanent dann wirklich so auf unfreundlichste Art vollgemauelt wird und teilweise so unterspällig bedroht wird, wenn du irgendwie bestimmte Regeln etwas anders siehst als das Teile der Fanszene sehen. Und naja, was uns jetzt auf der anderen Seite, also die Leute, die das alle nervt, glaube ich, so ein bisschen fehlt, ist irgendwo eine Struktur. Also nach dem Spiel Hinspiel gegen St. Pauli mit der Choreo hat mir auch ein alter Bekannter geschrieben und er hat dann irgendwie so einen riesigen Brief formuliert, warum das halt ein Riesenproblem ist. So, aber er hat das in den Vorstand geschickt, aber weiß gar nicht, ob es da eine Reaktion gab. So, und da fehlt irgendwo, ja, irgendein Bündnis, wo man wirklich dann eine starke Stimme hätte, oder wo man wirklich sagen kann, bei den Mitgliederversammlungen, die sind dann eben auch sehr, ja, ultra oder Szene oder was auch immer dominiert, weil da einfach eine sehr hohe Mobilisierung ist. So, meine, klar, kann man jetzt auch hingehen und da sagen, irgendwie, Antrag stellen, dass Frauen auch in den ersten drei reinstehen dürfen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so gehört würde. Also für alle, die diesen Hinweis nicht verstanden haben, gibt es halt irgendwie so ein Flugblatt, was auch an jedem Spieltag verteilt wird. So keine Fotos im Blog, alle müssen Schalom haben und keine Weiber in den ersten drei rein. Und was ja dann auch deutschlandweit immer mal wieder herausgeholt wird, aber was ich persönlich auch wirklich ein Unding finde, aber was eben auch so ein Umstand ist, wo ich jetzt sage, okay, wenn ich es auf der Mitgliederversammlung anbrechen würde, würden mir wahrscheinlich 300 Leute auslachen, wenn wir das Thema erledigen würden.
Ich kann da glaube ich sagen, lieben Dank Olli, dass du das hier noch mal so geschildert hast. Also ich glaube, jeder von uns ist immer auch Fußballfan und ich glaube, es ist nie schön, wenn man irgendwann das Gefühl hat, sich für seinen Verein schämen zu müssen, nicht weil er irgendwie sportlich immer weiter nach unten geht, sondern eben weil das, was auf dem neben dem Platz passiert, einfach kein gutes Bild lässt. Von daher auch einfach noch mal danke, dass du das hier so ein bisschen aufgearbeitet hast. Lass uns tatsächlich auf den 18. Verein schauen. Wir haben es gleich geschafft und das ist der VfL Osnabrück. 28 Punkte, es sind am Ende nur 6 Siege, eben aber auch 18 Niederlagen, 69 Gegentore zu 31 geschossenen Tore nach einem Jahr. 2. Liga geht es wie bei Wiesbaden auch zurück in Liga 3. Dabei muss man sagen, am Ende wahrscheinlich weniger sang- und klanglos, als es zwischendurch in der Saison noch so aussah. Unter Uwe Koschinert hat man da definitiv zumindest ein Aufbeben gezeigt. Man geht mit Uwe Koschinert jetzt auch in der 3. Liga den Weg weiter. Ich glaube, so wahnsinnig viel brauchen wir in dieser Saison auch nicht mehr zu analysieren. Das hat Susanne hier auch immer wieder von der NOZ ganz gut aufgezeigt. Aber Olli, sag doch einmal, wie schaust du auch auf den VfL Osterbrück?
Also das trifft sich auch gut, dass wir es kurz halten wollen, weil ich von denen exakt ein Spiel gesehen hatte. So könnte ich jetzt auch keine großen Details erzählen. Aber ich glaube einfach, dass der, dass der Verein, der komplette Verein von diesem Aufstieg total überrascht wurde. Das ist jetzt auch die Geschichte, die hier im Rasepunkt glaube ich schon ein, zwei Mal erzählt wurde. Man muss sich hier in der Erinnerung, in der letzten Saison hat Tobias Schweinsteiger da das Traineramt übernommen und eine Woche später war der VfS in der Riga 15., dann haben die irgendwann angefangen zu gewinnen und haben nicht mehr aufgehört und waren aber noch in der 96. Minute am letzten Spieltag waren sie Fünfter oder Sechster und haben dann noch das Siegtor gegen Borussia Dortmund 2, glaube ich, geschossen und sind dadurch auf Platz 3 gerutscht, was für den Aufstieg gereicht hat, weil der SSC Freiburg als zweite Mannschaft da noch davor platziert war. Und hat dann, glaube ich, relativ den Kader, den man hatte, auch mitgenommen in die Liga und war ja aber eigentlich auch kein Spitzenteam der 3. Liga. Man ist da dann einfach, weil man oft gewonnen hat, da irgendwie hingekommen. Und ja, das zeigt sich ja auch, der erste Sieg in die Saison gegen den HSV, der gelang am 7. Spieltag. Also man hat halt einfach sehr lange gebraucht, um in dieser Liga anzukommen. Ja, dann gab es wenige Leute, die überzeugt haben. Erik Engelhardt, vorne war einer, hat 10 Tore gemacht. Das war jetzt sein erstes Zweitliga-Jahr. Also das ist sicherlich ein Name, den man auf dem Zettel haben sollte. Und ja, ansonsten habe ich jetzt gelesen, 18 Spieler stehen unter Vertrag und gehen wieder mit in die 3. Liga. Das heißt, man ist jetzt sehr viel besser vorbereitet auf die neue Saison in der 3. Liga, als man das jetzt in diesem Jahr in der 2. Liga war. Und das sind, glaube ich, ganz vernünftige Strukturen. So Herr VfL Osnabrück kennt die 3. Liga gut, hat Erfahrungen, wie man mit Auf- und Abstieg umgeht. Sie haben, das ist auch gesagt, mit Uwe Koschin hat, ich finde ich einen sehr guten Trainer, zumindest für die 3. Liga. Und da ist auf jeden Fall ein Fundament da, dass der VfL Osnabrück wahrscheinlich relativ schnell wieder angekommen ist.
Das war der Punkt, dass die Causa Bremer bekam, wir haben eben schon mal kurz angesprochen, das Thema des Daches, was da eben auf einmal durchaus zu Seherheitsproblemen führte. Ich glaube, bei Osnabrück, zwischendurch dachte ich noch mal, ob sie eben Braunschweigs ein bisschen folgen und eben noch mal diesen Aufstieg mit der Leben. Ich muss sagen, für mich war am Ende eine große Überraschung, dieses Spiel gegen Schalke. Man hat es ja geschafft, sich relativ lange am Leben zu halten. Ich finde, man kann dadurch ein bisschen Parallelen ziehen zum 1. FC Köln, der ja auch sich immer weiter seine Lebenszeit noch in der Bundesliga theoretisch verlängert hat, bis es dann doch irgendwann soweit war. Was für Köln diese Niederlage bei Heiden einbar war, für mich ganz definitiv dies 4-0 gegen Schalke 04. Erstens war es eine super merkwürdige Atmosphäre da am Millantor ohne Fans. Es hatte so richtig böse Corona-Flashbacks. Und dann steht es eben nach 5 Minuten 2-0 für Schalke. Und du weißt, alles klar. Aus der Brücke ist damit weg. Das war deren letzte Chance. Und das hat mich schon ein bisschen gewundert, weil sie eben davor die Wochen sich immer noch am Leben gehalten haben. Aber das war tatsächlich eine einigermaßen Makrot-Erklärung. Und ja, mit Uwe Koschin hat in Liga 3 weiterzumachen. Mehr oder weniger wurde er ja eigentlich von Anfang an in einer aussichtslosen Position geholt. Und es war ja, glaube ich, damals schon unterschwellig klar, dass man ihn schon auf eine Zeit auch in der 3. Liga vorbereiten wird oder mit ihm in die 3. Liga gehen wird. Aber ich muss halt schon sagen, diese negativen Ausreißerspiele, die kam hier dann halt doch bekannt vor, auch aus seiner Zeit in Bielefeld. Da verloren wir dann ja auch am letzten Spieltag 0 zu 4 in Magdeburg. Und dann eben dieses 0 zu 4 in einem Relegations-Hinnspiel gegen Wiesbaden. Da hatte ich kurz ganz böse Flashbacks auch. Also, dass man da in dem letzten Spiel, wo es nochmal um alles gehen könnte und Schalke da ja auch noch nicht ganz gerettet war, eben so nach 5 Minuten komplett eigentlich ehrlich gesagt den Löffel abgibt, das hat mich schon überrascht. Aber Olli, wie du schon gesagt hast, das Fundament steht und das wird sicherlich wichtig sein. Ich glaube, man sieht sich schon eher in den besseren Top 4, 5 der der 3. Liga zu kommenden Saison. Aber auch da wird es unfassbar schwierig werden. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig. Auch was eben von unten hochkommt. Wir haben jetzt die 3. Zweitvertretung. Zwei ist Freiburg 2 abgestiegen. Aber du hast da eben Hannover 2, du hast Dortmund 2 und du hast dann eben Stuttgart 2. Und da sitzt ja auch ordentlich Potenzial hinter. Wir haben es bei Freiburg 2 gesehen. Die können zwar auch absteigen, aber die können auch ein Jahr davor mal zweiter werden. Und das wird natürlich auch klar, wenn es hinterher nicht wirklich den Platz wegnimmt. Aber die Spiele gegen die musst du trotzdem noch mal gewinnen. Von daher wird es, glaube ich, auch für Osnabrück spannend. Obwohl man da, glaube ich, sagen muss, die konnten sich als Erstes mit dem Abstieg, glaube ich, dann doch schon abfinden. Und eben da als Erstes in die Planung reingehen. Das würde ich schon sagen.
Ich meine, der Vorteil, wenn man ihn so nennen möchte, bei den Zweitvertretungen in der 3. Liga, ist natürlich, dass es dann für alle anderen mehr TV-Geld gibt. Das kommt denen sicherlich ganz gelegen, weil die zweiten Mannschaften da nicht berücksichtigt werden. Und ja, jetzt hast du diese Highlight oder diese Alles-oder-Nichts-Schwiele angesprochen. Aber ich kann mich auch erinnern, in seiner Zeit vor Bielefeld, da hatte Fortuna Köln mehrere Jahre da sehr souverän drin gehalten. In Sandhausen hat er dann, glaube ich, auch den Klassen halt geschafft. Und jetzt haben wir es ja gesehen an der Entwicklung. Sie haben 19 Punkte in der Rückrunde geholt. Also das ist ja eine ordentliche Rückrunde. Also du hättest halt eine überragende gebraucht, um noch drin zu bleiben. Aber das war eine ordentliche Sohne. Wenn du da jetzt einfach hinkommst und eben in deinem Maß normal Punkt bist, dann brauchst du ja am Ende vielleicht gar nicht diese Entheilungsspiele.
Und liebe Leute, ich will euch jetzt nicht länger quälen. Ich glaube, wir haben alles gesagt, auch wenn manche Vereine vielleicht zum Schluss ein bisschen kürzer geraten ist, aber so ist das im Rasenfunk. Ihr kennt das und ich würde jetzt einmal schon mal das Auto einspielen und mich bei meinen Gästinnen bedanken. Bei Olli, bei Thomas, bei Lisa, bei Marc, bei Anna. Vielen Dank, dass ihr diese fast fünf Stunden durchgehalten habt, die Technikprobleme mal wieder vor Anpfiff mitgetragen habt. Das ist nicht selbstverständlich. Vielen, vielen Dank und liebe Leute, werdet Rasenfunk-Supporter erinnern, denn das ist ja weiterhin werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Der Rasenfunk lebt durch euch.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.